All right, the board will continue its meeting and therefore we will, I want to need to announce that the board in closed session discussed and or took action on LAT versus state at all.
So we're now ready for our first item this morning, which is item 21 on the
Alpine Unified School District, CDE, will make the first presentation.
This is a public hearing, so each side will then have 10 minutes.
Then we'll have a board discussion on technical issues only, and then we'll have public comment, and then the board will deliberate on the issue.
I can make a few.
Yeah, could you make a few remarks?
Yes, we don't need the PowerPoints.
OK, better?
Yes.
OK.
Kind of at an awkward angle here.
I'm Larry Shirey, School Fiscal Services Division.
This morning we're going to start you off with the unification proposal from San Diego County.
Voters in the Alpine Unified Elementary School District there have signed a petition to form a new unified school district from the territory of the Alpine Elementary School District and the corresponding portion of the Grossmont Union High School District.
Alpine Elementary District supports the proposal.
The Grossmont High School District opposes it.
The county committee, San Diego County Committee, which is also the county board in San Diego, is recommending that the state board approve it.
We are taking the position that we're recommending disapproval.
And hopefully that will become clear as we go through the presentation.
Are we up?
Yeah, we're up.
OK, I'm just looking here.
OK, I'm sorry.
First of all, before we start on discussing the proposal, let's talk about what we're going to be doing here today.
And I need to go back.
How do I go back here?
I think there are some slides missing.
We had some edits to the slide, and I don't think we have the most recent version here.
But the first slide is going to talk about the role of the State Board today.
The role of the State Board today?
Yeah, go ahead.
You can tell us that.
Yeah.
The first thing you're going to be doing is listening to our presentation.
These four things I'm going to talk about are required by statute.
You're required to consider the position of the Department of Education.
You're then required to hold a public hearing and consider public testimony on the issue.
We are then going to talk about and you need to consider the nine minimum threshold standards that are required in the reorganization.
Those are, you can see that?
Okay.
There we go.
OK.
So we're down to number three, the third bulleted item.
You need to look at the nine minimum threshold standards that are listed in the education code.
You're going to be looking at if the reorganized districts are of adequate size, if they're based on substantial community identity,
if the assets and liabilities of Grossmont High School District are equitably divided, if education will continue in an integrated environment, whether or not the proposal will increase costs to the state, if there will be any effects on the educational programs of the districts,
if the proposal will increase school facility cost, if we need to make sure that the intent of the proposal was not to increase anyone's property values, and the final condition is the fiscal effects on the school district's other proposal.
Your options today are three.
You can disapprove the unification proposal.
You can determine the proposal has merit and return it to the local level for further action.
You cannot approve it today.
These are projects under CEQA.
And before you can approve a project, it has to go through the CEQA process.
And that would be done at the local level.
Or you can simply delay action if you feel you need additional information.
We're recommending, as I indicated earlier, disapproval.
Here is a map of the Grossmont Union High School District.
I have to apologize, I'm getting over this flu or plague or whatever it is that's afflicting people and if I pause to pull throat lozenges out or grab my water bottle, I'll apologize in advance.
This map shows the boundaries
of the eight component elementary school districts within Grossmont Union High School District.
And the numbers with circles around them indicate the general locations of the 11 comprehensive high schools in the district.
The district has, the high school district has about 22,000 ninth through 12th grade students in these facilities.
The high school district itself is located in the southern portion of San Diego County
immediately to the east of the city of San Diego.
In fact, portions of that city are within the boundaries of Grossmont.
The Alpine District is the easternmost component district in Grossmont.
It's the second smallest in terms of ADA at about 1,750 students.
The eight districts range in size from about 850 at Humboldt del Zura to almost 17,000 in Cajon Valley.
Just over 800 high school students from the Alpine area attend Grossmont schools.
Since Alpine is within the attendance boundaries of the Granite Hills High School, which is number three on your map, most of the students attend that school, about 520 of them.
Another 230 or so attend number nine, which is Steel Canyon Charter School.
And that's about 92% of the students attend these two schools.
The remainder are scattered throughout about five of the other nine high schools in the district.
The high school district has a policy that students can basically attend any high school they want as long as there's an opening in the high school.
Granite Hills High School is just off of Interstate 8.
I don't know if you can see that gray line that's running.
And Interstate 8 also runs through the center of the Alpine community.
It's about 12.5 miles from the middle school, which is about in the center of the Alpine community.
This distance from the high school of the community is one of the reasons that the Alpine community has been pushing for a high school in this area and also unification so that they could build a high school.
As I indicated, there's been decades-long interest in unification or building a high school in Alpine.
In fact, in 2003, there was a joint resolution from Alpine and Grossmont to approve unification.
That went to the county committee, the county board, but the county board recommended disapproval.
to the state board because they didn't think the new Alpine district would not be able to offer a sufficient educational program, that there would be increased cost for building a new high school, and the new Alpine district could not fund those costs.
And finally, they thought there would be a negative fiscal effect on a new Alpine district.
So that was a recommendation in 2003 that came to the board, but before the board could hear it,
The districts determined to work together to support putting a bond on the ballot, a couple of bonds actually, to build a high school.
One of the purposes of the bonds was to build a high school in the Alpine area.
The boards then requested that the state board disapprove the unification, which it did at its November 2004 meeting.
The bonds that were approved.
as I indicated, included funding for an Alpine area high school, one in 2004, one in 2008, but the bond language also contained a trigger.
The high school enrollment had to meet the 2007-2008 enrollment levels in Grossmont at the time construction bids were put out.
The Grossmont High School District acquired a site for the high school within the boundaries of Alpine and completed some pre-construction activities between 2009 and 2012.
However, in 2009 when they acquired the site is the peak of these enrollment projections.
Two years prior, 2007-8 is the trigger, enrollment at Grossmont as well as many high school districts started to plummet.
As a result, in 2012, Grossmont placed a hold on construction of the Alpine High School due to this declining enrollment.
Alpine community became very concerned that
Continued bond expenditures of Grossmont would drain funding for an Alpine area high school.
It's a large high school district, has a number of other issues it needs to address and it continued to issue and fund these maintenance and modernization efforts.
There was a grand jury report 2012-13 that reflected the Alpine community's concerns.
The grand jury report recommended that
Grossmont should either commit to building the high school with a timeline and put the funds aside for the construction, or it should support any Alpine unification effort that came forward.
But in 2014, Alpine Community submitted another unification proposal, again, concerned that they were not going to get the high school built by the Grossmont High School District.
Again, this went to the county.
County feasibility study, the County Office of Education contracted with School Services of California to do a study on the feasibility of the Alpine Unified School District.
That study determined that
It would significantly increase school housing costs, and also that the new Alpine district would not have the resources sufficient to address those costs.
Despite the finding, the county committee voted to recommend approval of the proposal.
But again, throughout this process, Grossmont High School District was continuing to issue bonds.
and fund its maintenance and modernization needs.
And the concern in Alpine kept growing that these funds were going to be depleted before it could get to constructing a high school.
And they were also concerned that some of the projects that Grossmont was funding were of a lower priority as listed in the bond measures than construction of the high school.
So they went to the trial court and asked for an injunction, preliminary injunction, requesting that the high school district set aside sufficient funding.
I think they were asking for $70 million at that time, sufficient funding to construct the high school.
The trial court granted the injunction and ordered Grossmont to set aside $42 million.
Grossmont appealed.
The court of appeal then determined that the preliminary injunction was valid and returned it to the trial court.
The trial court subsequently ordered a trial on the issue of whether Grossmont High School District was obligated to build an Alpine area high school.
The court ruled that Grossmont was not obligated to build the high school because the enrollment trigger had not been met.
And the district had discretion to put the construction on hold due to other economic circumstances.
They were still feeling the effects of the recession.
So assessed value in the district had fallen as well as district funding.
Alpine appealed the ruling.
Now, this last bullet has changed somewhat.
As of yesterday, the Court of Appeal issued its opinion.
and supporting or affirming the action of the trial court stating that Grossmont or confirming that Grossmont High School District is not obligated to build the high school under current circumstances.
This opinion doesn't have any effect on our recommendations because all of our analysis and recommendations were without regard to conditions in the litigation, so those remain unchanged.
What was the court's reasoning on this?
I haven't looked at that, but if you don't want to discuss it now.
Excuse me, I didn't hear you.
We can come back to that if you don't.
I haven't really looked at the opinion that closely, so I'd have to bring our legal counsel up to discuss that.
So let's move away from the historical context of this reorganization proposal and talk about what we're going to be doing today.
I'm going to go through those nine minimum threshold conditions.
I'm going to take them in order of starting with the least controversial and least complex, working through until we get to the final one, which is the rationale that we're using for recommending this approval.
We recommend that five of the conditions in Ed Code section 35753 are substantially met with no significant concerns.
One is that the districts will be of adequate size.
Two, that they'll all be based on substantial community identity.
That the reorganization will preserve education in an integrated environment.
and that there will be no significant cost to the state as a result of the reorganization, and it's not designed to increase property values.
Now, at the local level, the Grossmont High School District did express some concerns about whether or not education would be in an integrated environment.
They made the argument that Alpine could not
provide as diverse an environment as Grossmont does.
Well, that's true to some extent.
Alpine has about 36% minority students, I believe, while Grossmont is around 57%.
The reorganization itself will have minimal effects.
If there's a high school built, whether it's by Grossmont
or by Alpine, if it's a unified school district in the area, the demographics of the high school will reflect the Alpine community, regardless of who builds the high school.
In addition, the high schools in Alpine already reflect a fairly wide range of diversity.
They range from high schools that are 40% minority to those that are over 90% minority.
There will be no effects on, of course, the middle school or elementary students because no populations will change there.
If we look at what the reorganization proposal would do, if you pulled all of the Alpine students out of Grossmont, it would increase the minority percentages by one percentage point.
If you looked at the two high schools, Granite Hills and Steel Canyon, it would increase minority student percentages in each of those districts by about three percentage points.
We see that as not substantial.
Now we have a couple of conditions that have a little more concern with them.
One is whether or not the proposal will promote sound education performance.
The Alpine High School would have limited extracurricular and academic opportunities.
It's going to be much smaller than any of the high schools that Grossmont operates.
Right now, Granite Hills High School, which is the primary high school Alpine students attend, offers an international baccalaureate diploma program.
The students from Alpine are well represented in the courses of that program.
Similarly, the Alpine students are well represented in the AP classes of both Granite Hills and Steel Canyon.
There has not been any concerns raised in the Alpine community about the quality of education that students receive in these high schools.
The high schools perform well academically.
And again, there are no concerns that educational programs for Alpine kids are deficient in any way.
So we have some concerns regarding whether it can compete.
with Grossmont Union High School District for students, especially since there are a couple of district authorized charter schools in the district.
But we still find the conditions substantially met.
The other has to do with the negative fiscal effect of the reorganization.
Alpine Elementary is currently deficit spending.
This reorganization will not change that.
But as in any case where an elementary district is bringing in a high school program, it's going to increase costs somewhat.
The biggest increase would be due to teacher salaries.
Right now, the teacher salaries in Alpine are considerably lower than the Grossmont High School district teacher salaries.
If in these days of teacher shortages,
Alpine Unified would be competing with Grossmont for high school teachers, so there would need to be at least some raising of the salary schedule to have that competition.
However, we think that there would be enough time for a new Alpine Unified School District to organize
and that it would be able to, if it made prudent budget decisions, there wouldn't be a negative fiscal effect.
Of course, if those prudent decisions are not made, there may be some concern for fiscal insolvency here.
But again, we find the conditions substantially met.
Now we're gonna get a little more complex.
Whenever a,
A district is divided as Grossmont would be in this reorganization proposal.
A portion of the territory would go to an Alpine Unified.
There has to be a proposal to divide the property funds and obligations of the high school district.
And we find this condition substantially met, but we're bringing it up here because there has been
a good degree of not consistency, but a certain disagreement at the local level about what constitutes an equitable division of property and obligations.
So let's look at statute.
Section 35560, in part, states that the real property, which is the land and facilities and fixtures that are associated with the facilities, shall be the property of the district in which the real property is located.
All other properties, funds and obligations, except bonded indebtedness, will be divided pro rata.
The default standard for division, this pro rata division, is the SUS valuation.
This is kind of a relic from the pre-Prop 13 days.
But what we typically recommend and what the board typically approves is that you look at the source of funding.
and make appropriate divisions based on that.
So in general, any capital-based project funds would be divided based, pro rata, based on AV, assessed valuation, and all other funds basically would be divided pro rata based on either ADA or enrollment.
However, the Alpine proponents argue that
any equitable division of Grossmont's assets must include consideration of, boy, did that get an echo all of a sudden?
That equitable division of Grossmont assets must include consideration of real property or the monetary value of real property.
The result then is that the Grossmont High School District should provide Alpine with about $70 million after unification.
They justify this by stating that Alpine has made a promise or that Grossmont has made a promise to build a high school in the Alpine community and that any plan for division of assets should include funding for the new unified school district to build that high school.
Again, as we noted earlier,
The current court opinion is that the Grossmont High School District does not have the obligation to build the high school currently.
As we talked earlier, section 35560 clearly prohibits division of real property.
And it's C.D.'
's opinion that you can't skirt this prohibition by reducing real property to a monetary value.
So we do not see that the proponent's proposal is based in any legal or equitable standards.
The Alpine unification proponents further argue that
The authorized but unissued bonds of the Grossmont High School District can and should be used for the majority of the $70 million that they believe is owed to an Alpine Unified School District should the unification proposal be approved.
We note that there is no provision in the Education Code to allow division of the authorized but unissued bonds
under these circumstances.
There is a provision that if the Grossmont High School District would go out of existence entirely, then its remaining bond authorization would be transferred to affected districts.
But that is not an authority of the State Board.
That's an authority of the County Board of Supervisors.
So we recommend that the equitable division of assets threshold is substantially met under education code conditions.
We do have some, I don't want to say concern, but we have a lack of understanding of what the county committee recommended.
They recommended that the condition is met only under the plan put forward by the proponent.
So they made a recommendation that
The condition is substantially met only if basically Grossmont assets are used to construct a high school in a new Alpine district.
We're not sure what the recommendation of the county committee would be if it had to fall under our interpretation of the education code.
So now we're at the last threshold condition.
We're talking about whether it will increase school facility costs.
And there have been universal concerns throughout the history of Alpine's unification's effort.
The 2003 study that the county office contracted for stated that concern in the county study.
They found the conditions substantially met, but the concern they listed was that the new Alpine district would not be able to have the resources to fund construction of a new high school.
The county committee recommendation, as I mentioned at the beginning, recommended disapproval based on that finding also.
They found that it would significantly increase school housing costs, and a new Alpine district would not have the funding available to fund construction.
That's also the finding of the current school services of California study.
They find that the proposal would significantly increase school housing costs and that the new Alpine Unified District would not have the resources available to fund construction of the high school.
The county committee conditionally approved this condition.
And they found it substantially met, but only if the new unified school district basically did not build a high school, that they use existing facilities to provide the secondary program.
So they also made at least some acknowledgment of the difficulty of funding a high school in the Alpine School District.
Proponents themselves are concerned.
They stated that this unification effort is an exercise in futility if the new district does not receive appropriate funding from the Grossmont High School District to construct a new high school.
So with that context, we're recommending that that condition is not substantially met.
There will be new cost of at least $45 million.
Again, there's no local sources of funding identified.
The new district would not have sufficient bonding capacity.
They have expended all of their approved bond funds.
And the Alpine voters have not supported a bond measure in 20 years.
There, of course, would be the potential for state bond funds available.
We have the 2016 approved bond fund.
about $3 million set aside for new school construction.
But those funds are rapidly being gone through.
It's unsure that there would be anything available.
And even if a new bond was issued before Alpine started construction, it's unsure whether the Office of Public School Construction would determine that the Alpine Unified District would have eligibility for state bond funds.
Regardless, typically, the district would need to have a local match.
for those funds, and as we stated earlier, those local matches usually come from approved bond measures, and there has been a difficult time approving such bond measures in this district.
So as you know, even if you find one of the conditions not substantially met, you can still approve this or move it forward anyway at this time.
If you determine that the condition cannot be, the conditions is not met, cannot be literally applied to the reorganization proposal and that there is an exceptional circumstance or a compelling reason to approve it.
There are a number of compelling reasons out there.
One is the longstanding interest and support for a high school and the reunification in the Alpine community.
There have been historically joint efforts by both Alpine and Grossmont to build a high school in this area.
As you saw in the map, the Alpine area is about 12 and a half miles from the nearest Grossmont High School.
Certainly, there are some distance and safety issues regarding transportation to the school that can be considered.
And also, you can look at some county-wide support for unification.
The county committee is recommending you approve it, and the county grand jury also has some support for the Alpine community on this measure.
Again, on the other hand, even if you find all the conditions substantially met, you don't have to recommend approval or move it forward.
You can deny it or disapprove it based on other concerns you have.
One of the concerns we haven't discussed yet are the enrollment declines in Alpine.
It's been, enrollment there has been declining for about 15 years, even though the most recent enrollment projections or data show that there was a slight increase and projections are that will continue to increase.
But that's kind of, it's not, those enrollment projections are not necessarily in line with the San Diego Association of Government projections.
Even though those projections do eventually, by 2035, show high school students rising, increasing, until about 2020, they look at declines in the high school student population.
Overall, Sandag has projected by 2035, population in the Alpine area will grow by about 24%.
but those increases are not.
the same across all age levels.
The student population by age five through age 18 is projected to grow by 15%, while the age 65 and older population is projected to increase by 110%.
And those types of changes in the enrollment and general population could affect the size, scale, and financial support for a high school.
We've already talked about the
the effects on educational program, facilities, and fiscal.
So I'm not going to go into any more detail on that.
We do have some other concerns.
Well, now just one other concern.
There is some inconsistency or lack of clarification and supporting data for some of the county committee's recommendations.
As I indicated, they recommended that the increase in facilities costs condition is met only if the new Alpine district does not build a new high school.
But on the other hand,
their conditional recommendation that the equitable division of property condition is met only if Grossmont provides funding for the new high school.
So that's kind of confusing to us.
You certainly have the authority to direct the county committee.
to come back with new plans and recommendations.
We don't recommend this.
I'm just pointing that out because you do have that authority.
We don't see that any clarification from the county committee would affect our findings, our recommendations.
And the issue about the pending litigation is no longer current.
So last slide, your options restated here.
You can disapprove the unification proposal.
You can determine it has merit and return it for local action, which is primarily CEQA.
Or you can delay action today until you have more information if you think additional information is required.
Based on four general conditions, we are recommending disapproval.
We don't find the facilities condition substantially met.
It will increase.
The unification proposal will significantly increase school housing costs.
And there is no evidence that there would be resources in the Alpine community to fund those costs.
Number two, under our interpretation of the education code,
There is no legal or equitable rationale to support using Grossmont assets to fund construction of that high school.
The current court position is that Grossmont does not have that obligation.
And finally, in our opinion, there exists no compelling reason sufficient to overcome the shortcomings of the proposal.
So now you will turn to a public hearing.
I'm here to answer technical questions right now if you would like, or certainly I'll be here after public testimony.
Yes.
Could we hear what the court said yesterday?
It is relevant to our deliberations.
And so if you can't do that, is there somebody here who can do that?
Yes.
Here's Peter Stubbs in our legal office.
Good morning, Mr. President, ladies and gentlemen.
I have read the Court of Appeals opinion.
And in summary, they made
Well, three findings.
Number one, they held that under the unambiguous language of Proposition U, which was the ballot measure that authorized these bonds, an enrollment trigger was required to be met at the time of request for construction bids.
That enrollment trigger, I think, was 23,245 district wide.
And the court found that
That enrollment trigger had not been met.
While it was true that Grossmont had done some preliminary site work, the court found that that did not amount to construction, at least under the terms of Proposition U.
They also found that although Grossmont had appointed a leaseback contractor, which as you probably know is one method of paying for the construction of a school, that did not involve any construction bids.
So that didn't count either.
The court also found that although Grossmont did not have an unfettered discretion whether to build a high school, nonetheless Grossmont did have some discretion, provided it was reasonably exercised, to prioritize other construction projects, because Prop U had not just the high school construction, but other projects listed on it.
And the court found that Grossmont reasonably exercised that discretion in deciding to postpone construction of a high school because of financial circumstances, declining enrollment and budget cuts after the 2008 recession, and applying those funds to other projects which were prioritized.
Finally, the court found that there was an action for what is called waste, which was bought by Alpine taxpayers for bond accountability or some such organization.
The court, in essence, found that it was not waste for Grossmont to devote those bonds to other projects, even though
That might result in all of the bond funds being exhausted because Grossmont was never obligated to build a high school because the enrollment trigger was not met.
And furthermore, that trigger may never be met, but at any rate,
Grossmont was not obligated, in essence, to set aside any portion of those funds to pay for the construction of a high school, at least until such time as that enrollment trigger was met.
So in essence, the Court of Appeal affirmed the trial court's judgment on every single issue, actually, that was decided by the trial court.
Okay, thank you for that.
You may stay up because we may have questions on that.
So we can, I guess, move now to the public hearing.
and then the board can discuss.
And so I guess you should sit down and I'll convene a public hearing.
We may have questions for you later.
So I would like to start with 10 minutes for the groups that support the proposed formation of a new Alpine Unified School District.
One point that my colleague has drawn to my attention.
That is that this decision was filed on the 18th, but it is not yet final.
Just so that you're aware, this decision will become final at least as to the Court of Appeal 30 days after it was filed in the Court of Appeal.
During that 30-day period, the appellants
do have the right to petition the Court of Appeal for rehearing, they have 15 days to do that.
That does not affect the finality after 30 days.
Once that 30 days has expired, the appellants then have 10 days in which to petition the California Supreme Court for review, if that is their decision.
And then the California Supreme Court effectively has a further 90 days after that in which to rule on the petition.
So if you add up the 90 plus the 10 plus the 30, you have 130 days from January the 18th for the Supreme Court to rule on a petition for review should one be filed.
And I don't know what the appellants of course at this point intend to do.
Thank you for that.
OK.
All right.
So now we're ready for the proponents to make their 10 minute presentation.
Good morning, board members, community.
My name is Dr. Rich Newman, and I'm the proud superintendent of the Alpine Union School District.
The people of Alpine have shown unwavering support for a locally controlled K-12 district for almost 20 years.
The Alpine Unification story is not simply about matching what is happening in our local traditional and charter high schools.
It is about providing a local high school that is built with the community's involvement, where our students will not need to travel an hour or more each way to and from school by bus, where Alpine residents will be given a choice to attend their high school, and where we will also match the elements of a traditional high school.
The CDE provided in its report that it believes a new Alpine high school would not be fully operational until 2025 at the earliest.
The report also noted Alpine does not have the facilities to house a high school.
When I read this report, I realized nobody
who worked on it has visited Joe McQueen Middle School.
Our middle school campus has permanent classroom capacity for over 1,000 students, which is 200 students more than the high school that was proposed by Grossmont.
It has a full-size gym designed with a full stage that doubles as a multi-purpose performing arts center.
We have nine acres of existing sports fields.
We have a 10,000 square foot library that has the potential to be utilized for additional labs,
to meet a high school curriculum.
Our district has a capacity of up to 3,500 students, and we have the facilities to implement a high school.
We can house a phased-in high school tomorrow.
Let me also tell you about our programs.
We have a dual-immersion language school, and this program would also matriculate into our high school.
We offer robotics as part of our core curriculum, and as a result, we've had great success.
Our team were the national champions in solar car racing last year.
We currently have electives such as Culinary Arts, Performing Arts, Music, Coding, Spanish, Makerspace and Computer Science that would expand into our high school.
We have an athletic program that competes against other schools in the county.
As you can see, there are many rich programs that were not taken into account in the staff recommendation.
We will not begin a school with 800 students, which is stated as a reason that unification would harm Grossmont.
We plan to slowly build our program, beginning with the ninth grade, and expand each year thereafter.
This board created precedent in the Bonzell Union School District, which is a school district in our local area and which houses its high school at its middle school.
Their high school began with approximately 60 students.
Again, our current facilities can be reorganized now to begin a high school.
All of our speakers will share with you why Alpine is an exceptional case and the tremendous community support we have.
We are simply asking for our students to have the opportunity to stay in their local community for high school.
For me, being here today are the moments that remind us that all things are possible.
I was brought to Alpine in part to help implement a high school.
I was the former director of learning support services and the director of innovation for the Poway Unified School District, a 35,000 student K-12 district.
I helped develop and build what is considered one of the most innovative schools in the county and state.
I know what it takes to open an innovative school that engages the local community.
I submit that Alpine is a place with not only tremendous hope, 20 plus years of hoping for a school, but the possibilities of creating an innovative high school program in Alpine are real and achievable.
We stand ready to bring unification to Alpine and to make the dreams and hopes of our students a reality.
I ask that you give us that opportunity.
I invite you to visit our community and reconsider the recommendation you have before you today.
Thank you.
I'm Sal Casimacema, and I chair Alpine's High School Citizens Committee.
First, let me address the decision that came down yesterday from the court.
It just basically said, as was presented, that they did not have a legal obligation to build the Alpine High School.
However, that decision just reinforces the primary reason we decided to pursue unification.
Grossmont will never build a high school, and unification is our only option.
Let me now deal with the CDE report, which rejected the unanimous decision and recommendation of the San Diego County Committee in support of Alpine, and instead relied heavily on the 2014 feasibility study, mentioned by Larry Shirey, submitted to the county.
CDE determined, as he said, that eight of the nine criteria were met, but that the real stumbling block is criteria three regarding the division of assets and liabilities.
CDE interprets the code
to require Alpine to assume 100% of Grossmont's liabilities, but not the same share of its assets.
This makes no sense.
It's akin to a divorce in which one spouse gets to keep the house, while the other spouse has to pay the mortgage.
CDE stated Alpine could only take the vacant Lazy A school site, but is not entitled to a share of any of the value of other Grossmont real property assets.
The Grossmont bond program
has generated about $850 million, which was used to upgrade Grossmont High Schools and greatly enhance their value.
We're not asking that these schools be partitioned or sold off.
We're simply asking they be included in asset valuation so that Alpine receives a fair and proportionate share of their value, enabling Alpine to finally do what Grossmont will not, build its high school.
The Ed Code gives the State Board wide discretion to determine equitable sharing of assets and liabilities.
The feasibility study said exactly that and told the County Committee it had discretion to recommend an equitable split of assets and liabilities, yet CDE never mentioned this.
And it also fails to disclose that the study relied on State Board precedent.
The 2012 Bonzell Unification, which is very similar to what Alpine is doing and has occurred in San Diego County, moved forward because you, the State Board, adopted a resolution saying, quote, all assets and liabilities of the Fallbrook Union High School District shall be divided proportionately.
The feasibility study quoted this resolution and said regarding Alpine, the SBE may call for division of all assets similar to the action taken in Bonzel.
Certainly, your resolution complied with the Ed Code back then and was fair and equitable to Bonzel and Fulbrich.
The common sense of that resolution equally applies to Alpine.
Clearly, with the very unfair and inequitable division of assets in the CDE report, there would not be enough money to build a brand new high school on the Lazy A site.
However, there would be sufficient funds to convert our existing middle school into a high school.
As described by Dr. Newman, who just stated, our middle school is fully capable of accomplishing all of our high school age, accommodating all of our high school age students.
We therefore ask the state board to approve Alpine's unification and send it back to the county committee for determination of a fair and equitable division of all assets and liabilities consistent with this board's decision in Bonzell.
With that approach, Alpine's unification, 20 years in the making, can finally be achieved.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Travis Lyon.
I'm an Alpine school board member and the elected chairman of the Alpine Community Planning Group.
I have a unique perspective on what this unification means to our community.
You, the members of the state board, have a tremendous responsibility today.
Our community's future rests in your hands.
The CDE demographic report missed the mark.
Alpine is already a community of 18,000 residents with over 1,000 high school aged children living within our district.
But more than that, we're a community on a trajectory for growth.
Sandag actually projected that our community will double its housing units over the next 20 years.
We have one of the largest communities in the state that does not have a high school.
Compounding that problem is the fact that we are geographically isolated from our neighboring communities and specifically our closest high schools.
This forces a high school worth of kids
to make a dangerous commute or travel on buses for over an hour each way every school day.
Today, you'll hear from over 25 members of our community.
What moves me most is that so many of these speakers no longer have a stake in the game.
Let me explain that.
My motivation is simple.
I have three young children that will be educated in Alpine over the next 12 years.
I am intimately invested in the success of the district.
But so many of the speakers' children have promoted past eighth grade.
They're not here because their children will receive a direct benefit from a long-promised high school.
They're here because it's right.
They've made sacrifices that I will be eternally grateful for.
The fact that so many of these people have traveled over 500 miles to speak to you today should tell you something about our resolve and the ability of our community to do this and that how important this unification is to our kids.
We have the facilities now.
Our unification reasons are overwhelming.
Please follow the recommendation of the county committee and approve unification.
Give our community the choice it deserves.
Thank you.
Okay, now that you've used your time, I take it, and now we're ready for the opposing side to come up.
You will have 10 minutes.
Dr. Kirst, fellow board members and staff, I am Dr. Tim Glover, and I'm the proud superintendent of the Grossmont Union High School District.
And with me today, I have board president Rob Shield and deputy superintendent Scott Patterson, and they've been involved in this discussion for well over a decade now.
We're thankful for this opportunity to speak to you and share our concerns during this public hearing.
And our presentation is going to have three parts.
First, we're going to recognize and validate the thorough and impartial analysis completed by your CDE staff.
Next, we're going to provide how we oppose the unification and share some additional insights to the points of the petitioners.
And then finally, we're going to close by reinforcing our wholehearted support for CDE's recommendation and ask that you adopt CDE's recommendation.
Again, CDE's analysis was thorough and impartial, and it validates that it was a sophisticated review by multiple members of the CDE staff.
We recognize that it's a respectful analysis and that it aligns with education code.
We also want to restate that there's some significant highlights in CDE's report.
CDE is right to be concerned with the county committee's recommendation.
It's politically charged, it is inconsistent, it lacked clarification, and it is without supporting data.
Next, we agree with C.D.'
's concerns that the fiscal study of the County Committee, that actual fiscal study concluded that there is not or does not meet regarding the equitable distribution of assets.
And then finally, you heard C.D.
mention specifically about the nine criteria and we agree with him that the errors in those nine criteria are not minor, they are significant in this discussion.
Additional concerns that we agree with CDE on is that you should be concerned about the cost of a CEQA study if you were to refer it back and that there's no clear clarity around the funding of that CEQA study.
We also agree that you should be greatly concerned about the enrollment declines.
28% over the last 15 years in Alpine with 13% decline in enrollment in the last five years.
And also the fact that our Grossmont Union High School District has 2,700 spaces for high school students in it now.
C.D.'
's analysis also indicates very accurately that the division of property suggested by the petitioners is prohibited by education code.
And C.D.
also notes in its study that if they were to unify, they could very well have qualified status on their financial reporting during their first couple of years at risk of economic failure.
also notes very clearly that any alternative division of assets that you may come with
Warrant the idea of expanding the vote for unification not within the Alpine district, but the Grossmont district as a whole Now I'll turn it over to Scott Patterson for our reasons for opposing unification Good morning, Scott Patterson deputy superintendent of business services for the district I've held that position for almost a dozen years and it seems like for that entire time I've been observing and studying this issue.
So why is
does the Grossmont District oppose the unification proposal?
Well first it will result in harm to the Grossmont students and we believe to some degree the Alpine students who are currently Grossmont students.
We're in declining enrollment and we're talking about a potential 800 student decrease to the Grossmont enrollment.
That won't happen across
The system, that will happen at two of our high schools, representing about a 20% cut to those high schools.
As those resources go away, the programs deteriorate.
We're facing teacher layoffs and other cuts, including co-curricular and extracurricular.
The oddity about this is per the feasibility study that was commissioned by the county committee, the LCFF rate for Alpine per pupil actually goes down.
So they visit harm in terms of the per pupil rate.
It's unreasonable to believe that Alpine would get the resources necessary to build a high school.
First, as you've heard, there's no interpretation of the Ed Code that gets them the resources anywhere near what would be necessary.
Then turning to the prospect of passing a bond, there's no reasonable expectation that they would pass a bond.
You heard in the report that they haven't done so in over 20 years.
And in fact, their last attempt to pass a bond in Alpine resulted in a 55% no vote, about the opposite of what you need to pass a bond measure.
On the operational cost side, it's unreasonable to expect that they would be able to operate a high school program.
We talked about the LCFF rate going down.
And the big disparity between teacher salaries of the current Grossmont District and the Alpine District, it's nearly $16,000.
So when you talk about having to either level up or create a uniform salary schedule, that's a tremendous cost burden unlikely that they would be able to bear.
And when you think about the fact that Grossmont's robust educational and co-curricular programs are already in place, why put those students in that position?
And the fact that, I will say that the relationship between the Alpine District and the Grossmont District is very good, from the superintendent's office, to the business services, to the educational services, we collaborate and articulate those students very well now.
So I'll wrap up my comments with concerns about the petitioner's recommendation.
They clearly recognize CDE's thorough analysis and data, then ask you to ignore it.
There's a disconnect.
They speak highly of the county committee, then ask you to ignore the feasibility study commissioned by that committee.
They ask you to ignore CDE's interpretation of the Ed Code with regard to division of assets, and they want access to all Grossmont assets, but they don't want Grossmont to vote should it get to that stage in the process.
And they ignore the concerns of declining enrollment in both districts, which is occurring.
To wrap up my comments, you simply don't go build a school when you've lost more than the equivalent of a school in enrollment over the last several years.
To conclude our comments, I'd like to invite Mr. Robert Shield, our board president, to the podium.
Thank you.
I am the board president.
I thank you very much for this opportunity to speak.
Besides being board president at Grossmont, I happen to be an eighth grade teacher in a neighboring district, Lakeside.
And if you look at the map, they touch.
And so I'm very sensitive to issues, not only as a board member, but as a teacher who watches his students every year matriculate into our schools.
One of the concerns I would have is a lot of assumptions that have been made are sort of best case scenario.
There's discussion about a high school of 800 students.
The current eighth grade class in the Alpine district is approximately 160.
And there is always attrition from the freshmen through senior year.
But the one assumption that's not addressed at all is all Alpine students will stay in Alpine.
We have a significant number of students in our high schools right now that are involved in swimming, diving, performing arts, IB, other programs that Alpine will not be able to offer for the foreseeable future.
So I think it's unreasonable to assume that they will retain all the students because, in my opinion, many students will opt to come to our high schools the same way that even now many of their middle school students
opt to attend neighboring middle schools because the programs that they are able to offer, but a cash-strapped elementary school district are unable to offer, as evidenced by the differential in teacher pay of Alpine versus every other district in San Diego County.
Let's see.
Sorry.
No one is questioning the quality of the educational program being offered at Grossmont.
We are doing a fantastic job of educating students throughout our district, including those students that currently reside in Alpine.
That has not been challenged.
The impartial voice of reason in this entire process are your experts.
And we're asking you to adopt their recommendation and disapprove the Alpine unification petition.
I have other notes, but I think out of respect for time, the evidence is clear.
We are committed, the board, I can say the board throughout my tenure in the last 11 years, is we are committed to building a high school in Alpine when it is appropriate.
As recently as 2007, there was unanimous approval, or not approval, but unanimous support
for building a high school in Alpine, as at that time, there was some contention over what do we call it?
What is its name going to be?
And that argument was among what the Alpine supporters would say is the greatest opponent to the construction of an Alpine, or to the construction of a high school.
We're committed to that process.
But enrollment, the demographics, especially aging demographics of Alpine, and the finances simply do not support it.
Simply put, as a trustee for the Grossmont Union High School District, I cannot in good conscience support unification knowing that every single student in the district is going to pay for that unification, including the students that would remain in Alpine.
So I thank you for your time.
Thank you.
So now we will begin the public comment.
The board nearly always hears the public comment as well before we begin our deliberation.
So staff will then identify the people to step forward in the order as the staff reads the list.
Public speakers, Eric Way, Glenn Dickey, Priscilla Shriver, Roger Garay, Sal Casamassima, Colin Campbell II, Lisa Campbell, Rhonda McClavittal, George Barnett, Jessica Manning, Katie Yossi, Scott Yossi,
Nick Marinovich, Sharon Haven, Albert Haven, Richard Haverstock, Nicholas Katarabic, Charles Katarabic, Neville Collin, Christine Connell, Robert Welsh, Hayden Lorry, Chris Lorry, Priscilla Schreiber, and Joseph Perricone.
Please come forward.
Good morning.
My name is Eric Ray.
I'm a trustee for the Alpine School Board.
I have a letter I want to read from Diane Jacob, who is the San Diego County Board of Supervisors Chairwoman.
And it reads, I would like to express my strong support for the unification of the Alpine Union School District.
Unification would enable the district to add the high school and expand the grade levels being offered under AUSD from K to 8 to K to 12.
It is essential to consider the importance of local control over the education of students within a community.
The constituents of Alpine have a unique and specific vision for what they would like to implement and build for their students.
The Alpine parents, staff, and board members are credible, forward-thinking individuals who care about the well-being of their students.
I am confident that the unification and transfer of control to a new and enlarged Alpine Unified School District will better serve the community and pupils of Alpine.
This is a letter of support from the Chairwoman of the Board of Supervisors.
I have seen between 2002 and 2014 the support for Alpine.
Thank you.
Good morning, trustees.
My name is Glenn Dickey.
I'm an Alpine parent and the board president of the Alpine Union School District.
Although the Department of Education recommends a local Alpine election area for unification vote, it cautions that a district-wide election may be needed if the State Board accepts a division of assets that veers from what the Department of Education recommends.
First, such advice contradicts the CDE's own handbook, which states that a district-wide election is needed only where a local election area constituted invidious discrimination in violation of the constitutional equal protection clause.
Because the CDE found no significant racial or ethnic impact arising from an Alpine unification, then a local election is called for under the DELAFCO case.
Second, only a local election provides an equitable outcome.
With less than 6% of the district population, Alpine would have no chance against Grossmont in a district-wide election.
Rosemont has campaigned against us from the moment we filed our petition and have shown they're willing to outspend us.
A district-wide election would effectively override any decision.
I therefore ask for your support and the unification in the local election area.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Priscilla Schreiber, former Grossmont Board Trustee for 16 years.
You have before you my written statement for your thoughtful consideration.
During my tenure from 2000 to 2016, the Grossmont Board brought complete chaos and confusion to the district by making promises to Alpine they never planned on keeping.
When Prop H passed, Alpine and Grossmont jointly withdrew the 2004 unification petition.
When Prop U passed, the site was purchased and a campus and curriculum were designed.
However, any further progress, grading, infrastructure ceased just prior to carving out the promised sports fields to benefit the families of Alpine.
Building plans were secretly pulled from the Department of State Architecture and without board approval.
Make no mistake, this is about denied equity, hollow promises, and failed leadership.
Throw in some self-serving politicians and you have the complete breakdown.
When all else fails, and it has, Alpine must unify.
The grand jury agreed, as did the county committee.
It is vitally important for this board to recognize the harm that Grossmont has done to Alpine, and in its prudence, grant a fair, equitable move towards unification.
Thank you.
Good morning, and thank you for listening to our comments.
My name is Robert Welch, Jr., chairman of the Viejas Band of Kumeyaay Indians in Alpine.
I'm in the minority category for the GUSD.
The Viejas Band of Kumeyaay Indians supports the unification of the Alpine Union School District.
Our tribe has a positive working relationship with the public schools in our area, and we are proud to send our students to K through 8 right here in our own community.
The unification of the Alpine Union School District will allow the students of Alpine to continue that community pride throughout high school by enabling us to have our own school.
I was privileged to go to a high school that was really small in Ramona, 600 students.
200 was my graduating class.
The high school was the soul of the community and the heart.
We played football.
The town closed.
They came to watch the game.
Football fell on Halloween.
The stores closed.
Nobody gave out candy.
They went to watch the game and celebrated Halloween the next day.
Time.
Thank you.
I'm here speaking as an individual, but a member of the Sweetwater Union High School District Bond Oversight Committee, a member of the California League of Bond Oversight Committees, and a former member of the Grossmont Bond Oversight Committee, plus 40 years of professional experience in government.
The issue here is what's the most effective government structure for the students of Alpine?
What particularly struck me in preparation for this hearing was the organization of the community involved.
Secondly, the Grossmont bond program was not transparent and not accountable to the public.
There were problems with that wanting to build the high school.
I recognized it from the very start being on that committee.
Finally, I want to say it's difficult to really capture the geographic isolation of Alpine.
The amount of miles these students have to drive up and back is unconscionable.
In closing, if you remember back in 1970, there was a governor in California.
He had hair then.
He said, small is beautiful.
That applies to the Alpine School District.
Thank you.
Good morning, ladies and gentlemen.
My name is Joseph Perricone.
I'm on the Alpine School Board, as well as being chairman of the Alpine Chamber of Commerce.
In those capacities, I've talked to thousands of our business people and citizens of Alpine.
And I can tell you almost to the person, they're in support of a high school.
Having said that, the word decline has been mentioned a lot this morning.
But let me bring you to a very specific point.
If voters vote for a bond and then don't get what they pay for, is that ensuring our democracy and that our voters will be heard or will it equate to decline in their confidence in our system?
This is the question you must grapple with this morning.
Can we, as society, go forward and have credibility if voters vote for a measure and they never get what they pay for?
I thank you for your time.
I won't go without it.
You have a picture of what I was going to put on the screen.
I'm Dr. Albert Haven, chief petitioner and former superintendent of Alpine.
I also represent the 25% of the registered voters who signed our petition.
Our group of citizens began in my living room 20 years ago and has since enjoyed strong community support and participation in seeking a high school and local control.
For 20 years, Grossmont has consistently shown that their word cannot be trusted and that our 6% share of the district is unimportant.
While we watched with dismay the board's action to again and again reprioritize Alpines High School further into the distant future, disregarding the devastating impact of hours on the bus and lost study time, their board built high-cost items not listed in the bond language, like performing arts and aquatic centers
artificial turfs at all schools, you have the power to bring justice to our community today.
Thank you, sir.
Thank you very much for coming.
I'm Colin Campbell, a chief petitioner.
I represent and help collect over 4,000 Alpine resident signatures.
I campaigned for three Gross Bond Prop 39 builds
bonds to build an Alpine High School.
The most common phrase I heard was, they will never build it.
And the residents of Alpine were right.
The Alpine High School is the only project within all three bonds that have contingency factors.
Grossmont has 2.5 billion reasons to hold Alpine hostage, as we have the highest assessed valuation of any community within Grossmont.
In lieu of Alpine's high school, bond funds were diverted to enhance every other campus.
Alpine students have been neglected and unsheltered since 1921.
We have been in the Grossmont District for 97 years, and we still don't have a high school for our over 18,000 residents.
13 families were removed by condemnation from the 93-acre site.
$23 million were wasted.
Instead of a district-wide enrollment trigger, the Alpine Boundary Study and educational needs of our community should have been-
Further growth is in Alpine, not the landlocked portion of Grosmont, where a campus was seriously considered for contraction.
The appellate court found yesterday that Grosmont has the discretion to refuse to build the Alpine High School into perpetuity.
Their 5% problem is our 100% problem.
Good morning.
I'm George Barnett.
I'm a grandpa with four kids in the Alpine district who are the kids of a kid that could have gone to a Grossmont school.
San Diego Association of Governments and the County of San Diego have commenced reprogramming of their
planning updates.
Alpine's designated as a village growth area.
Sandegg's forecasting a doubling of residential housing units over the next 20 years.
I've provided a chart through your staff.
We can operate a comprehensive high school.
Grosvenor's Bond Promise is not a comprehensive high school.
No facilities, no sports facilities, no performing arts.
It was going to be operated as an adjunct to an existing high school.
We already have a far superior capability and ability than the Bonzo unification.
We already operate 1,000 student designed middle school with complete facilities, sports facilities, gymnasium, performing arts, and so forth.
Our community groups administer sports facilities and education to 2,000 kids.
We're ready.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Sharon Haven.
I've spent some 60 years in Alpine, and I've been in a unique position to watch it mature as a community.
When I came, it was a village of 2,000.
No one expected it to have a high school.
I went to school in El Cajon, 15 miles away.
Years passed, Alpine grew.
There was a sadness to the fact that children who formed tight bonds in grammar school were sent off to one of four or five high schools down the hill.
Whichever had room, there were no high school reunions in Alpine.
Even siblings often attended different high schools and not from choice.
In the late 90s, when we were a community of 13,000, we were told the next school to be built would be ours.
Then Grossmont got a better deal, and Hamul and Steel Canyon was born.
We are now over 18,000, and Grossmont has let us know that despite Prop H and Prop U, our best hope for a high school from them will be in 2030.
Unfortunately, there won't be any money then.
Our community and our children deserve better than that.
Please let us unify.
Thank you for your time today.
My name is Jessica Manning, president of the Alpine Education Foundation.
I have been fortunate the past few years to help facilitate grants in upwards of hundreds of thousands of dollars to further our district programs and our facilities.
One of those being a $150,000 field that we put in one of our elementary schools that was solely produced from community support and county funding.
That model is being used again currently for a $1 million project.
Funds coming again outside of our district for our middle school campus to have improved fields.
But more than that, I'm a mother and I feel that
Our district has offered fantastic educational opportunities for my children, diverse programs that enhance that education and the facilities for my kids.
I humbly ask each of you to hear our collective plea to see the heart and the leadership and the resources that we already offer and grant the opportunity for us to have our own high school.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Christine Connell.
In 1999, Alpine had only a 3,000 square foot library in a storefront setting and obviously needed a new library.
Applications for bond funds from the state in 2004 and 2008 were unsuccessful because the state did not have Alpine as a priority.
In 2009, Alpine Library Friends began to work with our local supervisor.
We broke ground in 2013, and in 2015, we opened a 13,000-square-foot, award-winning, state-of-the-art library.
It's lead gold, net zero, Wi-Fi, computer labs, laptops for use, books, CDs, DVDs, programs for all ages.
It's absolutely marvelous.
Cooperation works, we discovered.
Who has a demonstrated ability to work with local officials and design-build professionals?
Who can and will ensure that all monies gathered in Alpine bond payments will benefit Alpine schools?
Time.
Who cares most about Alpine?
These guys do, and we'll get the job done.
My name is Katie Yossi, and I'm the mom of a student in Alpine.
Why does Alpine want and need a high school?
Because a high school further defines and strengthens our community.
Let me tell you about our community and why we all support a high school.
I'm the vice president of a strong education foundation that supports our district with thousands of dollars every year in the form of robotics and leadership programs, a 5K, computer licenses, equipment, and summer break programs.
Teachers and principals live in our neighborhoods.
Our kids play after school sports together in all volunteer-based programs.
When we have a family in need in our community, we set up meal schedules, we decorate businesses and streets with yellow ribbons, and we donate money and time and whatever is needed to help support that family in our community.
But when our kids graduate middle school, they are immediately scattered across San Diego County to various schools.
We're tired of them having to drive 15 miles minimum to football practice or a school dance.
We're tired of our kids dying, driving home from school.
We are tired of paying bond-increased property taxes and not getting the local school that was promised.
We are a good community, we are a strong community, and when we build this school, we will continue to grow and strengthen in outstanding ways.
Good morning.
My name is Scott Yossi.
I'm a board member of the Alpine AYSO, a coach, and a parent.
I went to high school in Alpine to benefit the youth athletic community and to help that community grow.
Community, it's a common theme you've heard today.
And our youth athletic program is a community too.
Our students grow up playing together.
They form strong bonds to be remembered over a lifetime.
They feel pride in playing for Alpine.
They deserve the chance to continue growing and competing together at an Alpine high school.
In growth, Alpine youth sports are some of the only programs in East County San Diego that are growing today.
A high school will act like a magnet to retain and attract more members of this community.
A high school in Alpine, for youth athletics, for community, and for growth.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Rhonda McLaughlin.
I'm a mom, not a politician.
And I helped pass the bonds two times for a high school in our community.
I'm engaged with our district through the Education Foundation, Youth Sports, and PTA and will be engaged for the next five years from middle school to high school.
I am president of Alpine Pop Warner and I'm treasurer of San Diego Pop Warner.
Pop Warner's philosophy is that athletics and scholarships go hand in hand in developing sound character while having a good time.
This year I brought Pop Warner to Alpine School District sports fields after a gross unified school district denied us home field use on fields we have paid for, punishing our football program.
The kids, they won't let us play on their fields anymore.
Or they will charge us $1,000 a day to play for kids.
Punishing our kids because we're trying to unify.
They say that that's not true.
I'll drive by the field, there's nobody on it.
My husband and I moved to Alpine 10 years ago.
Hello, I am Hayden Laurie, and I'm a freshman at Granite Hills in Grossmont District.
I attended Alpine Elementary and Joe McQueen Middle School in Alpine.
In seventh and eighth grade, I participated in a brand new engineering program at Joe McQueen, which included competitions in robotics, public presentation, and mechanical design.
In eighth grade, our team earned first place in an innovation competition against more than 400 middle schools.
Later in the year, my school's team dominated a regional school or car competition.
My team represented California for the first time at nationals, where we swept all three scoring categories among more than 800 teams nationally.
Alpine schools have prepared me and my classmates for success at high school and beyond.
I'm in the most rigorous courses offered at Granite Hills and my GPA after the first semester is a 4.66.
We have great teachers at Granite but we are unfairly disadvantaged by one hour each day compared to our classmates.
I can only imagine what more we could achieve with an extra five hours each week.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Lisa Campbell.
I'm a mother, clinical psychologist and a resident of Alpine.
My son is a freshman at Steel Canyon High School.
This morning he woke up at 5 a.m.
to take a 605 bus.
On many days we choose to drive him to school so that he can have an additional 30 minutes of sleep.
This drive entails us driving 17 miles of backcountry winding road through six communities,
We repeat this process most afternoons, as there is no afternoon activity bus, and he plays sports.
Each round trip takes us one hour, which represents many dangerous hours on the road for our family.
As a mental health professional, I'm acutely aware of the critical importance of sleep.
It is particularly important for adolescents, as they have a delayed sleep cycle.
Healthy adolescents require nine hours of sleep or more for optimal physical, emotional, and cognitive functioning.
We are asking Alpine students to drive to school many hours before they should be awake every day.
Negative outcomes for teens include declines in grades and test scores in addition to many mental and physical health problems.
Please carefully consider your decision.
I'm Richard Hoverstock, and I support the Alpine unification.
I've been the treasurer of the Alpine High School Citizens Committee for seven years, and I've been pushing for an Alpine high school for 11 years.
But just as important, I'm a grandfather with three grandsons living in Alpine.
I want a high school for them.
Based on the curriculum designs and plans already completed, this will be a comprehensive high school and will provide my grandsons with an excellent education and preparation for college.
Alpine parents are very concerned about our children busing down the hill to a high school not in our community.
Our students can be traveling for more than an hour each way on a winding, dangerous road.
They are at a disadvantage to other students who only travel short distances to school.
Also, the longer that our children are on the road, the greater the risk of an accident.
I collected many signatures door-to-door for this petition, and I have spoken personally to many Alpine citizens and grandparents, and they want this high school.
Good morning, I'm Dr. Neville Connell, and before retiring I was a director of the Palo Alto Research Center.
I reached this position because the 800 student high school in the small English working class town that I grew up in gave me a tremendous start.
In retrospect, there were two things that made my high school successful.
First, excellent academic and extramural activities.
Second, the efficient use of everyone's time.
It was the inattention to the second of these that shocked me when I moved to Alpine.
There are only a small number of hours in the day to get things done, yet Alpine students spend between two and three hours of this precious time on a school bus.
This represents 30% of their school day completely wasted.
Just imagine if you had to spend three hours of your working day on the school bus, what would happen to your productivity?
So when I had the opportunity to vote for bonds, two of them, one of which had no demand.
Time.
I took it and hope you will too by voting for unification.
My name is Nicholas Katteraback and I am a student at Gilmore Queen Middle School.
Under the Grossmont School District I would have to get up at 5 a.m.
which would give me 55 minutes to shower get dressed and eat.
Whereas I and then I would have to go out of my house walk a 20 minute walk in the dark to catch a 6 15 bus which will get me to school by 730.
And outside, I saw a poster that said, Serve.
How is Grossmont going to serve their students' needs by having them on a bus three hours a day, five days a week?
Thank you.
good morning my name is roger gray i am licensed as an enrolled agent that is someone licensed by the internal revenue service to advise and represent taxpayers anywhere the i a r s exists in two thousand and two i chose the location in alpine that i've been at uh... since uh... may have that year that is my business we took over an existing business of about three hundred and forty three hundred fifty clientele and uh... just last week
My office sent out over 1,400 appointment cards to our clients.
The community is not declining, at least the part that I serve certainly is not.
It is my sad duty to listen to folks as I sit with them every year about their concerns and their problems.
And the issue that has been repeatedly mentioned here is the issue of transportation.
We have a fairly well integrated community.
in terms of retail and education for our lower grades.
I happen to also participate in the Alpine Education Foundation, and I would like to see the voting that we did as citizens to be paid for.
We are going to be paying for those bonds in Alpine for the next 40 years, whether or not we get a high school.
Thank you.
I'm surprised that one of the nine conditions isn't that you take into consideration what's best for the students of Alpine.
Could you tell us who you are?
Excuse me?
Identify yourself, please.
I'm Charles Katarabak.
I came up here to talk about time, opportunity, and money.
The time to commute to the nearest high school from Alpine can never be recovered.
It's being stolen from our students, their parents, and their siblings.
This loss of time robs our children of the opportunity to participate in activities surrounding high school, like swimming, band, sports, theater.
You cannot do these things while you're riding in a car or riding in a bus.
People outside our community will never care for our children the way we will.
We are here today fighting for the right to determine the best way to spend our money to benefit our children and our community.
A high school in Alpine would be one of the largest employers in town.
Keeping our money in Alpine will help our community to thrive.
Some people have said that we can't afford a high school.
If this is true, it's because someone else took it and spent it.
Thank you.
Chris Laurie, equitable, reasoned, reasonable, extraordinary, discretion.
These are the words strewn throughout the education code.
There's only one mechanism within the education code whereby the SBE or county are empowered to construct an educational solution for Alpine using these words.
This is where we are today, the unification process.
The county committee dismissed the boilerplate interpretation of the division of assets by the consultant because they deemed that the code was not equitable and not reasonable in our situation.
After three hearings, they used their given discretion in our extraordinary circumstance and recommended a division of assets based on equitable value of assets and liabilities, the mechanics which still need to be defined by arbitration.
Please don't undermine the local controlling agency that knows the situation best.
It is the same agency that in 2012 oversaw the asset allocation for our northerly neighbor, Bonzo.
Please approve the county committee recommendation and send it back for methodology.
Thank you.
That concludes the public hearing phase and now we're into board member questions, technical questions for the staff.
Board member Strauss.
So I want to thank everyone for coming and sharing the background and the history.
I think just as a member of the board I know we so appreciate this and we really we have some clarifying questions certainly I do but I just want to personally thank everyone who came and spent time to get here today.
I just want to start by saying, clearly, you've got some emotions and some community.
You've got Clara, community identity, and a long history, so Larry, I really appreciate you sharing that.
It sounds like Alpine's gone on this pathway for a very long time with the belief
that they were gonna get a high school and then there's been some changes along the way.
And so I have quite a few clarifying questions.
So I have four or five of them.
The first, we heard, I was here when we heard the Bonsall hearing and several of us were.
So in this case, what I'm hearing Alpine say is they are gonna take their middle school and make it a middle high school, much as Bonsall did small community also that feeds into Fallbrook.
How is this situation different than the Bonsall situation?
Number one, the proposal here in Alpine is not to convert a middle school.
I'll talk more about that in a moment.
It's to build a high school.
And you've heard that throughout the conversation.
So we had to put our primary focus on
on the construction of a new high school in the Alpine community.
Bonsall was very different.
Bonsall had come to this board for a waiver of who was going to be the first board of a Bonsall Unified.
Typically, it's an elected board, so you can't really
use the actions of the Elementary Board to guide what's going to happen by the Bonzell Board, by the Unified Board.
But Bonzell has a waiver or had a waiver from this board to allow the county superintendent to appoint
the first board of Bonzell Unified and a letter from the county superintendent indicating that he would appoint the elementary school board to the Bonzell Unified board.
So we gave greater weight to the Bonzell Elementary plans.
They had very specific plans about how they were going to convert.
the middle school.
Here we, you know, we don't have that.
You know, we have in Alpine, we have for the Alpine unification, the focus is on building a new high school.
Further, the intent of Bonsell was not to compete with Fallbrook Union High School District in terms of a comprehensive high school.
They had planned an academy-style high school.
They understood that they would not be able to retain all of their students, that there would be that group of students who wanted a larger high school experience.
And even though Bonsell Elementary was about 30% to 40% larger,
And then the Alpine Elementary, it opened, as you heard, it opened its first year with about 65 ninth grade students.
It's in its fourth or fifth year right now, and it has, I think, about 330 total high school students, and this coming from an elementary district that was larger than Alpine is right now.
Larry, I'm not sure if you're going to answer this, but there's an issue of the bond, and I believe we heard White Spern's issue, which fed into Centennial Valley Union High School District, and there was a bond issue there, so that the local people were paying, and there was some agreement, or they had to work out the agreement.
of what the commitment to the bond was.
I mean, again, I know each of these are different, but in some ways you've got Union High School District and you've got elementaries feeding in and there's some financial issues that maybe you could help clarify about the bond commitment that they had for high schools and what the issue is if we would support the unification and whose commitment to the bond would be.
I'm not sure if other board members could clarify, but I didn't understand the financial
Was it that they don't agree on how much Grossmont would pay?
I think there's some financial... Okay, well let me, I'm not quite sure I understand, but let me just sort of ramble for a little bit, and maybe I'll get lucky.
Wiseburn was a very different animal.
Wiseburn had already, as an elementary district, had already passed a bond to build a high school, so they had the funding.
The issue that, you know, the complexity of the assessed valuation and the bonded indebtedness in Wiseburn
was that Weisbrenner is right next to LAX, so it had a lot of the commercial, you know, the Boeings and the industry that goes along with an airport.
So it had a pretty high assessed valuation relative to the other part of the Sentinella Valley.
The concern that Santanella Valley had is that if you pull Wiseburn out, you pull a large portion of the bonding capacity as well as assess valuation.
So they actually had special legislation that would allow the commercial assess valuation at Wiseburn to continue being applied to the Santanella Valley.
high school district to get around the concerns of pulling out.
They had a lot of things in place, but it was a different issue.
In terms of what might happen, and specifically with Alpine, the Alpine community believes that a portion, about $70 million from the gross month, unissued bond funds,
should be transferred to Alpine should it unify to construct the high school.
If that happens, the debt associated with that $70 million would also transfer to Alpine.
And that's something that would be in the, but again, let me back up for a moment.
We don't see there's any way to do that, to require that these unissued bonds should be transferred to Alpine.
But if somehow they were,
The debt obligation that goes along with those funds would also transfer to Alpine.
In essence, they would have to be voting on an increase in property taxes also.
If those monies don't transfer, then Alpine, if it unified, would be responsible for
It's pro rata share of Grossmont's current bonded indebtedness, which we based on assessed valuation.
If, for example, if Alpine is 7% of the assessed valuation of Grossmont, it would have to take on 7% of the existing bonded indebtedness of Grossmont.
for Alpine to build then a high school, they would have to pass a new bond because the funds wouldn't be there.
And if they were to be able to pass a bond, then the debt, of course, the property taxes would go up to accommodate that increase in bond level.
Is that kind of getting at where
Yeah, and this assumes they would get the bond transferred from Grossmont, I mean, right?
Well, they wouldn't have any funds transferred from Grossmont.
They would only have the debt transferred.
Yeah, and there's no way to... Okay, maybe we ought to have our liaison talk on this first, and then we can take more questions.
Well, first of all, thank you to everyone who came today to speak.
And thank you, Larry, and your team.
It always impresses me how much you know about all these situations, you compare them.
In our liaison call a while ago, I asked all sorts of detailed questions, and you always have an answer that is based on fact.
And so thank you very much for that.
There's one thing that Member Strauss said just a moment ago in your response I want to clarify.
In a charter school petition, for example, we're going to hear several of those in just a minute.
We are obligated to look at the petition itself that is submitted and not a new change to the petition that happens the day before or during public hearing or whatever.
In this case, you said that you were examining this unification based upon the fact that they are asking
in it to build a new high school.
And yet today we heard about an alternative plan that didn't involve a new high school.
What's our responsibility in that sort of situation?
Well, number one, you can't force an Alpine Unified School District to convert a middle school.
You can't force them to build a high school.
That cannot be part of the provisions that you place in a reorganization proposal.
I will back up for a moment and the issue of the cost of converting a middle school or another site in Alpine to a high school has been addressed.
It was addressed in the school services of California report.
to the San Diego County Committee.
It was addressed in our facilities folks report.
And our finding was that regardless of whether they're building a high school or they're converting a middle school or another facility, it's still going to significantly increase school housing costs.
So we didn't spend much time on that because again, that wasn't part of the proposal.
And there's a lot of stuff, you know, it was like 85 page report.
There were a lot of stuff we didn't, for time constraints we didn't bring up.
But the finding of both school services to the county committee and the finding that we have is that even if they go with that option, which is not part of the current plans, it would still constitute an increased cost in school facilities.
There's a lot more than just changing the sign on a school.
You have to have labs.
In a high school, you're going to have to expand the parking lot.
In grade, you may have to acquire more land.
for the high school.
If they start work, everything will have to be ADA compliant.
And I'm not sure if whatever site they have currently is ADA compliant.
But if they do start working construction to convert, they will have to make sure the entire site is ADA compliant.
So there are a lot of costs that go into transforming an existing facility that serves elementary or middle school students into a high school facility.
OK.
Other board member questions?
Board, pardon?
Yes, board member Valdez.
OK.
So I want to thank everyone who came today.
And I am actually in a K-8 district that has been looking at unification for years and years.
So I kind of understand the sense of the community and the difficulty it is not to have a K-12 continuum of services and programs.
But I just had a couple of questions.
What you just asked is just that, you know, it is on the paper, on the books.
We have to follow what was presented today.
But there is that idea of creativity.
There is nothing preventing them from going with a charter or doing something like Bonzel did and doing a specialty high school and being able to grow into a community high school.
I mean, that is one option.
I saw a chart that showed Grossmont's decline, but what is Alpine's decline?
I heard also that it might be growing or there is projected development coming forward in the next 10 years.
Alpine has been declining enrollment for at least 15 years.
The most recent year for which we have data showed a slight increase, and their own demographers have indicated that
enrollment, K-8 enrollment, will increase in the coming years.
The San Diego County Association of Government also reports that eventually enrollments will increase.
High school enrollments are going to lag behind elementary school enrollment.
So yes, there is an increase, as I indicated in my presentation.
Sandeg's report is that projections are that
Ages 5 through 18 by 2035 will increase by 15%.
As indicated by their proponents, there are plans to, there's been approvals in place for an increase in housing.
Approvals for housing and actual construction of housing are two different things.
In an area like Alpine, they're going to have to deal with finding water.
and infrastructure, so those are issues that will have to be addressed.
Additionally, one of the concerns we brought up is the 110% increase by 2035 in the 65 and older population.
You can't guarantee who's going to be in those increased number of housing.
The demographer who did the Alpine's enrollment projections specifically stated that Alpine, like all East County areas, has a number of problems with enrollment growth.
One is the lack of available housing.
Petitioners have addressed that to some degree.
Two is the lack of a job base in Alpine.
and other East County communities.
And three is the distance that people in Alpine would have to travel for those jobs.
So those were three concerns that Alpine's own demographer brought up when they did the enrollment projections.
Does that answer?
Just one last clarification question.
So if they pulled the high school and it was a $45 million cost, they're also not going to have to go into the CEQA costs and all of those other, the report costs, is that correct?
Well, the CEQA costs have to be, would have to be addressed up front.
There are two types of CEQA, and I'm not sure where Grossmont is in CEQA costs for the actual construction of the high school.
There may be some additional costs for that.
But the CEQA costs for which we're concerned are the costs for the unification project itself, which is different.
And those costs are, you are the lead agency for CEQA in a unification proposal.
And those costs, as your past practice has been, will have to be borne by local agencies.
And no one right now has come forward with the willingness to address those costs.
One would assume that would almost have to be Alpine Elementary.
But again, no one's really addressed who's going to be responsible for the local cost of a CEQA review of the unification proposal as a project under CEQA.
OK.
Patricia Rucker.
Hi Larry, how are you this morning?
I also want to, these are the kinds of hearings that become very difficult to go through because there's so many different perceptions about a number of the factors and one of the concerns that I'm confused about is the bond
and is the debt or what the indebtedness currently is.
There were several statements that were made here that stood out to me.
One is that the district currently is in deficit spending with their budget, but at the same time, I am hearing
from members in the community, some perception that there is a deposit or a cash of funds for doing this building that Grossmont seems to have.
And so this is where I started getting confused.
I understand what you explained that
if the approval to do the unification goes forward, there is going to be a transfer of something.
And so what I'm hearing that seems to be confusing me is there is a perception on one side of this table that there would be a transfer of asset.
But I believe what I heard you say is that there would be an actual transfer of debt.
There wouldn't actually be new money.
It would be a transfer of debt.
from that existing bond.
Could you clarify that for me?
In any provision to divide Grossmont's funds, property, obligations, et cetera, we're going to look at a number of things.
In terms of real property, real property that's in Grossmont and the remaining portion of Grossmont will become property of Grossmont.
The property that Grossmont has in Alpine is this Lazy A site that they purchased back in 2000 or acquired back in 2009 and have done some preliminary work with.
That would become property.
of the new Alpine Unified School District.
That's real property.
Then there are the other funds and obligations of... I want to be sure.
So the property is an asset that would transfer over to this new unified... If it's part, if it's geographically located with the Unified School District.
Okay.
All right.
I'm tracking.
Okay.
So the education code specifically pulls out real property from
any proposal or any plan to divide assets that you as the State Board That's where I got lost.
So real property is gone from those considerations.
In our interpretation of the Education Code, you cannot decide that a high school in Grossmont, for example, can be
on the ledger side of an Alpine unified.
Got it.
That's where I got lost in the conversation.
OK.
So when you talk about division of assets, division of property funds and obligations, the Education Code explicitly excludes real property from that.
So Alpine would get some portion of Grossmont's fine funds if there are some bond funds in capital or bond monies in capital project funds.
then Alpine Unified would get a pro rata based on the assessed valuation share of that.
Other funds that come from the general funds and that sort of thing that Grossmont has, Alpine would be due a share of that, likely based on their pro rata share of enrollment.
The other piece that I heard very clearly from you is right now the Unified School District could not afford another bond.
Is that correct?
I forget the exact dollar amount.
It is in the report.
They would have some bond cap available.
Our concern is twofold.
One, it is not enough.
to cover the cost of a high school and two, the Alpine community has not in the past showed a willingness to access the bond, you know, to pass a bond measure.
And so that was the other place where I got confused because there were people who testified who seemed to think they already have a bond in existence that would pay for this.
Right.
And that's, that's the issue of it's a Grossmont bond.
Okay.
Got it.
So Grossmont does have at any given point in time, it has the funds, the bond funds that it's issued and are using to fund modernization and maintenance of existing school sites.
But it's, it's, it's like a credit card.
You know, when the, when, when, um, when the voters approve a bond, they give you a credit limit that you can spend.
And as you issue bonds, that becomes debt.
So what I think many of the proponents are talking about is that Grossmont still has this credit limit there, these bond funds that they haven't issued yet.
And that's what they see as the source of funding for a new Alpine high school.
But again, our opinion is that the Education Code does not allow those funds to be divided and transferred.
Great, thank you.
OK, board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
So what I heard also in terms of Alpine residents feeling that they had a bond is because it seems like they campaigned and actively worked to pass this bond for Grossmont, right?
So when you look at Prop U, it says that there's going to be modernization, but
it says constructing a new school in Alpine Blossom Valley.
So I think that here is definitely an issue of trust because they were to pass this bond thinking that they were going to get a high school but the devil's in the details and when you unpackage this bond there is a trigger number that has to be met to get that high school.
And so, unless you're in the weeds of the proposition, you may not know that in order to get that high school, there's a trigger number.
But you're under the assumption that because you worked and did the walking and knocking the doors to get this bond pass, and they told you, and it's in the header, that you're going to get a high school.
And so I feel for that because I do think that this is a community that worked to pass this bond and at the end of the day didn't get the high school.
And I feel for the students that have to get on that bus for an hour each way, because I'm a commuter in downtown LA and I know how that feels, as an adult to have to endure a three hour round trip.
And when I looked at, and I don't know that we have a lot of power here to say, because now there is a number that we have to work and we need to be responsible for what we're approving here.
But when you look at your chronic absenteeism rate, Grossmont, you have a higher chronic absenteeism than most of the surrounding districts, 15 point something.
And it's alarming to me when you look at your Native American population, which is at 25% of that.
So there is something that you have to look at when you're looking at the students that you're serving.
And that commute may be accounting for that chronic absenteeism.
I can't see it by school, because I know there's two feeder schools that you have.
But there is definitely something there, that data point that you have to look at, and then look at the students that are most impacted.
So I invite you to do that analysis, regardless of the outcome of this meeting, to really understand your student demographic and look at who are the students that are not coming to school.
Because it may be your students coming from Alpine.
So I have a question, though, about the third option of delaying our action here.
You said that as the lead agency, we would then decide who pays for the CEQA study?
No, under the delay, nothing would happen at all.
You would just decide as a board, well, we're not ready to take action on this.
We think that there is more information we want to gather or more information that's forthcoming.
The second option, I think, is the one you're addressing, which is that you consider the proposal to have merit, and then you will move on to the next step, asking the local community to take that CEQA step.
Under the public resources code, the cost for CEQA can be billed by the lead agency to the proponents of a project.
In this case, it's the chief petitioners.
Now, that's kind of a difficult thing to ask three community members in Alpine to fund the cost of CEQA.
So in the past, what the practice of this board has been is that you don't direct anybody, you can't direct anybody to pay for it, but you simply say CEQA has to be taken care of.
We are the lead agency.
It must be conducted under our supervision.
So local folks, work it out.
And then do we set a time period for that?
There's no time frame.
Okay, so delaying action, do we anticipate any additional information that would change?
I mean, other than the population trends, you've said it, there seems to be an increase, but the housing units or housing projects are just that, they're planned.
I'm wondering if, and I know, you know, it's already happened, but when Prop U was passed, that was 2008, there had to be some projections, 10 years out at least, and Grosmont knew that if you build another high school, you're going to lose students.
I mean, they knew that when they put that on the ballot.
So, for me, that point's irrelevant at this point.
You knew that.
You planned to lose students when you were going to open another school.
But did they not see the projections that the student enrollment projections at that time?
I don't know specifically what was going on, you know, 10 years ago when, or
12 years ago, 14 years ago.
But, you know, the Grossmont folks are here.
And if you wanted to ask them to clarify, you can.
I mean, it's definitely a trust issue at this point.
Certainly, all school districts do housing projections and have five-year, 10-year plans or whatever.
So, you know, we did not look at those, so I'm not sure what any school district had in front of them 12 years ago.
that they say we're going to lose students.
Well, you knew that when you propose a new school, a high school you're going to some of your students, and there's a decline in enrollment.
You had a projection, a student enrollment projection, and when you pass a bond that's part of what you look at.
You look to see is there a need for this in the future.
I think at some point we have to get back to, you know, where Grossmont's made comments about their priorities for this bond money and we need to get back to that at some point.
Go ahead.
I actually had two questions.
One I think might be for Grossmont, Larry, but the first one, I'm trying to clarify back to board member Holliday's point.
This issue that was raised today about the Alpine community has a middle school site that they think could house a high school is a new issue as I understand it.
Well, not really.
It was brought up at the, during the county committee consideration.
The school services report looked at that issue.
But, again, like us, they were looking at a proposal that contemplated a new high school.
They did indicate in their analysis that even if there is this excess capacity available at Alpine, they could explore a less expensive option to provide a secondary program in terms of converting or using existing sites.
But they still found that such conversion would result in an increase in facilities costs.
Therefore, the condition would not be met.
That's pretty much the finding that our facilities folks said.
We didn't focus on that because that was not part of the proposal.
Certainly, going back to the County Committee, that was their recommendation, that this condition is met only if the Alpine Unified School District used existing facilities to house high school students.
But, again, in our report, even though we've been talking about building a new high school because that's what everyone's talking about and that's what part of the petition is about, we found that even converting a middle school would mean that this condition is not substantially met.
So just to follow up on board member Ortiz-Lincoln's line of questioning, this issue of 10 years ago, what was the enrollment projection for Alpine?
And it sounds like they did not meet it.
They have not met it.
That's why we're at this point, right?
So.
Right.
The enrollment, as you saw in the graph, peaked in 2009, 2010 year.
And then since then, it's been on a decline.
OK.
And also, may I just add to that, a court, we had a full court hearing and a court just ruled on this.
Can you comment on that?
You know, beyond what our attorney has, you know, I might have to bring them up, but basically bring him up again, but simply put, the Court of Appeal decision affirmed the trial court's decision that under current circumstances, which are declining enrollment, that the enrollment trigger has not been met.
that there are fiscal costs to opening a school, that Grossmont can consider when using its discretion to decide whether or not to build the school, that Grossmont High School District is under no obligation under the current circumstances, those circumstances of enrollment decline and fiscal issues, to build a high school at this time.
Okay, Board Member Sun.
So when I read this item and I looked at the staff analysis, I was actually going to go with the staff recommendation.
And after hearing the proponents of the unification, so my bias is that school buildings don't make schools.
Heart, mind, and spirit make schools.
And what I'm finding is that all of this analysis, what the court is doing is looking at comparing, looking at the cost of building a high school based on our very traditional way of looking at what a high school is.
And I believe that this community does not need a high school with an Olympic pool and huge football stadium.
They want a high school program that best serves their students and their student needs.
And after hearing the petition, I feel like they can do it.
And there are other ways of building a high school program than the construction of what we're talking about here.
So that's my thought.
Well, just in response, certainly,
Certainly, those are options that have been discussed at the local level, as well as issues that we've looked at here.
As I said, the petition itself
And as you've heard by proponents, and even throughout the course of local consideration of this, the primary focus is on building that high school.
The focus has been on obtaining Grossmont funds to fund the construction of the high school.
That was the whole point of the litigation that we looked at yesterday.
So we can't make changes to a petition.
That's what the petition asked for, a high school.
You cannot tell an Alpine Unified School District that you cannot build a high school.
if we approve this.
That's left up to the new governing board of the Unified School District.
So certainly, certainly there are options out there.
And we have looked at those options to some degree.
And we still, even under those circumstances, as I said, both the school services report for the county committee as well as our fiscal, our facilities folks have found that there are significant
increase costs to providing something at the local level using existing facilities.
Certainly, our role is to focus on these threshold conditions.
Your role is to decide whether or not
they're that relevant or not.
And you can use compelling reasons, as you've been discussing, to say, okay, even if this condition is not met, even if there are significant increased costs as a result of approving this unification proposal, we think there are compelling enough circumstances to move it forward.
That's your role.
Thank you.
Board Member Williams.
Well, I'm finding myself sympathetic with board member Ortiz-Lacon and Ting.
Oh, son.
I'm sorry, going back and forth between first and last names.
Sympathetic to the problems, the challenges that Alpine is facing.
And I'm no expert in all of the bond stuff and all of the rules and all the court cases and stuff like that.
But my sense as I hear this is how important it is to Alpine
There are a lot of things important to Alpine.
The ideal, I'm sure, for Alpine is give us some bond money and let us build a full comprehensive high school of our own, and we'll figure out how to do it and how to fund it.
That's like the ideal scenario.
But if you don't get the ideal, whether it's because of these threshold issues and all of that stuff, if the ideal is not possible, then what's the tweener?
What's the thing in between that may get a kind of school, which may or may not, as you were saying, may not be a full campus, may not even actually be necessarily part of the middle school building facility, but could be use of another facility within
within the town, could be a dependent charter school, could be, I don't know that those options, once you let go of the ideal and you're willing to kind of think outside that box and think, okay, what else could we do that would allow
Students that want to stay in a high school in Alpine stay, and those that are willing to go ahead and ride the bus so they can have after-school programs and swim and be on the soccer team and all of that stuff, it might mean that some of their kids go to Grossmont and some of their kids stay for a different kind of high school experience in Alpine, but at least there would be an option where now all the options are long-distance driving.
and all of the concerns that were raised about time on the road, time on the curvy roads, time taken away from what you could be doing otherwise as parents as well as students.
Even the whole issue of getting up that early in the morning to get to school, there's plenty of research that indicates that that is not healthy in any way for students in terms of loss of sleep.
So my sympathies are with seeing if there's a way, if they were interested in trying to explore further other options, if there's a way for us to move forward to let that happen.
Well, certainly.
Certainly there are options out there.
The problem that we have is that who is going to tell you that this district can follow those, what your recommendation is.
We don't have a board for an Alpine Unified School District.
We don't necessarily have a superintendent for an Alpine Unified School District.
The current superintendent is not assured a position with the new Unified School District.
The superintendent will be determined by this new board.
We cannot get any assurances.
from anyone locally that they're going to follow some alternative.
Certainly, the elementary school district now has the option to work on getting a charter school, charter high school, that may address some of the issues, but I have not heard a whole lot of conversation around that option.
That's something that the current board, the current administration could explore.
But, again, we haven't seen much around that discussion.
But maybe that's because they were going for gold, and now we're looking for a different kind of option, and if they had more time, they could find one.
Certainly.
And that's one of the reasons why we gave you the option, the third option, is to just delay and see.
I'm going to back up for a moment.
We spent a lot of time here deciding whether or not we were going to recommend that the State Board delay hearing this because there were a lot of unanswered questions.
The primary reason that we decided to bring it to the Board is, as I mentioned in the report,
this divide between how Grossmont's assets would be divided at the local level.
Grossmont is stating that you can't use our credit limit, our unissued bonds.
We agree with that.
But the Alpine community was saying, no, we need those bonds to move forward with our plans.
We decided that would be in the best interest for everybody locally is if we went on record and perhaps the State Board could go on record as saying here's what we think the division of assets should look like and here's what you're going to have if this new district is formed.
That was the primary purpose and not delaying.
So I think we've done that and I'll throw it back to you.
Yes, I would like maybe if we get a motion on the floor.
Board member Holliday was our liaison here.
Thank you to all the board members for all your comments and questions.
I am very, very sympathetic to the Alpine community in this situation.
I think as member Ortiz-Lacombe said, trust has been broken and that's a very sad thing in a community.
I am concerned about the financial obligation should we, that will be put onto Alpine, should we go ahead and approve this unification.
I am concerned, deeply concerned about that.
I do think it is our responsibility.
to be as fiscally prudent as possible in these sorts of situations, and that is a serious concern that I have.
I have been through the process, literally, of converting an elementary school into a middle high school, and it is a very expensive proposition.
I really wish someone along all these years had put together a charter high school in this community because I think it could have solved a lot of issues.
I think it also could have given the community a real look at what their students want, whether they demand the full-blown high school with a swimming pool and the track and field and football team and all the rest, or whether
an alternative form of high school such as a charter school might have been really a good thing for the community.
I would like to ask a procedural question before I make a motion, and that is if a motion does not pass here, what happens at that point?
For example, if either for the invocation or against, if there is not if that first initial motion does not pass procedurally, what happens next?
I'll take that, Larry.
So what would happen if an initial motion does not pass, another board member could bring a different motion, and until there are no motions on the floor, if no motion carries, ultimately the hearing would end with no action by the board.
But the item is still active in front of the board, though.
It would essentially just be sitting here.
It would be up to this board to bring it back at some point.
It would be up to local folks to say, OK, we think conditions have changed.
We're ready to bring another proposal forward or another explanation of issues.
Maybe there are some negotiations between Grossmont and Alpine that could take place.
Maybe special legislation, like in Wiseburn, could be obtained.
If you don't take action here, it's just simply like delaying action.
It doesn't go away.
It's still here.
Yeah, okay.
Board Member Williams is next.
I just want to make sure, you gave as an illustration voting, making a motion to approve unification or not, but isn't one of the options to delay the decision and give time for more communication and planning?
Okay.
Put the options up again, please.
Oh, it went away.
Board member Strauss, then I'd like to get a motion on the floor.
So I just want to follow up on what member Sung and member Williams was saying.
So if they don't go for the gold because financially there's a problem with build and they decide they want to go for to convert the middle high school.
I'm just thinking, I'm not sure how we're gonna go on this, but if that's what they say, okay, we can't get a whole separate high school, but we could go, is the best, is one strategy then to allow them time to come back with a different proposal that would then have different financial implications, or, you gave us several options, Larry, and I'm just trying to say, to me, it sounds like they,
there's some real reasons why we should support their ability to maybe try a smaller one, or do they have to go completely back and start with a charter high school, and so then we say no, or we say nothing and they come back.
I'm just trying to figure out the options.
You're dealing with a specific recommendation from the County Board of Education, the County Committee.
That's what you take action on.
So if you delay action and
and allow negotiations, allow special legislation, allow people to gather more data.
You're still dealing with that recommendation on that petition.
The process of reorganization starts with a petition.
Now, certainly, the Alpine community could go back and start a new petition.
Or Grossmont and Alpine could get together and bring a joint proposal for something else.
But nothing that
that the community is going to do in the interim, nothing that the districts are going to do in the interim, is going to change the fact that the proposal you have now is what's in front of you.
You don't have authority to change that.
School districts don't have authority to change that.
Chief petitioners don't have authority to change that.
This petition, this proposal is what was brought forward by voters by petition in the district.
The only way to change what's in there is to bring a new voter petition forward.
Yeah, I'm going to ask board member Holliday to make a motion and then we can talk from that.
Thank you.
Once again, I feel deeply about this break in trust.
I feel deeply for the Alpine community.
I do believe that the CDE
has done a thorough review of this.
I am concerned about the financial implications.
And I do hope that the Grossmont Unified School Board will understand that there are fences to be mended and there's a lot of work to be done to bring this community back together again.
And I pray that that can happen.
However, I will vote, pardon me, I will make a motion to recommend the CDE's recommendation.
Is there a second on that?
Second.
Okay, I haven't spoken.
So I would say on this, I support the motion that this is a long complex situation that's gone on for years.
And I don't think this board has heard enough information about the complex local situation to overturn the CDE recommendation.
We've heard some people from the community.
We've heard of converting a middle school.
We got very little information on that.
And if we did, if we approve Board Member Holiday's motion, the community is free to come back with another petition to their County Committee.
So rather than us getting in the middle of negotiating this and continuing this proposal by delaying on it, I say that I personally would support the motion and hope that the community can resolve this and bring back something different.
But I'm not willing to go on the information I have today to intercede in this situation and say, I've heard enough.
I know what's best.
We're going to, you know, let them go.
And so that's my view.
Board Member Williams, you've been waiting to speak.
I would just say, as I understand it, this has to be acted upon one way or another.
Even if we delay it, you can't move on to another petition until this petition is settled.
Well, you can.
You can consider another petition while there are no time limits on you for taking action on this.
Certainly, if there was another petition that came in, you could consider both of them at the same time.
You could, you know, then
and perhaps prove another petition that came in.
There's nothing that prevents multiple petitions for kind of the same issue from being before the board at the same time.
You do not have to kill this for another action to start.
Okay, but a motion has been made seconded to deny the unification at this point in time, but there appears to be quite a bit of sympathetic sentiment on the part of many board members to have the petitioner come back with a different solution that they would like us to consider, with more pieces put in place, more issues addressed if we were to approve a unification.
that they've got a new way of approaching it, that we would be sympathetic to them coming back with that.
Certainly.
Regardless of whether or not they come back with the districts or the county or anyone comes back with a different petition for unification or other reorganization, it is really not relevant to what it is that you have to do with this proposal.
You are either going to disapprove this one or you are going to move it forward.
That is completely independent of what else
If you disapprove it, then the community can come back with another one.
Or if conditions change under your regulations, they can ask you to reconsider the existing, the disapproval.
If you let it go for two, three, four years, or however long it would take to get a new proposal through the county, through the petition process or the resolution process through the county committee, and then through us and back to you, I mean, that's probably a four-year process.
then it still does not change the fact that you have to at some point in time take action on the proposal currently before you.
Okay.
Are we ready to vote?
Yes.
Okay.
Clerk, call the roll then.
Patricia Rucker.
Karen Valdez.
Feliza Ortiz-Licone.
Sue Burr.
Eileen Strauss.
Mike Kirst.
Yes.
Ting Sun.
Trish Williams.
Nikki Sandoval.
Jayden Gray.
Bruce Holliday.
It passes.
Okay, the petition passes and then we'll move on then.
Motion passes, I'm sorry.
Yes, not the petition, the motion.
So we need a break.
So let's come back at 11.25.
Okay, the board will reconvene and we're ready for item 23, which is a petition for establishment of the preservation, I'm sorry, Preserverence Preparatory School.
CDE will present.
to give us an overview and then we'll proceed to a public hearing.
Is it on now?
Yes?
Okay.
Go ahead.
Thank you.
Good morning members of the board.
My name is Lisa Constancio and I'm the Director of the Charter Schools Division about three weeks now.
Thank you for the California Department of Education.
Item 23 is an appeal by Perseverance Preparatory School to establish a new charter school which was denied by the San Jose Unified School District and the Santa Clara County Board of Education.
Pursuant to statute, petitioners for a charter school that have been denied at the local level may petition the State Board of Education for approval of the charter subject to certain conditions.
The Perseverance Preparatory School, PPS, submitted an appeal to the State Board on September 28, 2017, and staff has reviewed the documents submitted.
Based on our review, the California Department of Education proposes to recommend that the State Board hold a public hearing to approve the request to establish PPS with special conditions for a five-year term effective July 1, 2018 through June 30, 2023.
The CDE recommends the following conditions to be met as outlined and prior to PPS opening for operation in 2018-19.
By January 30, 2018, provide evidence that the PPS Board has accepted the State Board conditions of authorization.
By February 15, 2018, the PPS Board will provide the CDE with a revised charter petition containing the necessary changes needed to reflect the State Board as the authorizing entity.
By May 15, 2018, the PPS Board will provide the CDE with verifiable and substantive evidence that PPS has received the funding anticipated from Silicon Schools Fund.
By May 15, 2018, the PPS Board will provide the CDE with a fully executed facility lease agreement.
By June 15, 2018, the PPS Board will provide the CDE with a revised 2018-19 budget with complete narrative and assumptions.
PPS proposes to serve 128 pupils in grade 5 in 2018-19 and expand by 128 pupils and one grade level per year to serve 512 pupils through grade 8 in 2021-22.
The CDE finds that the petitioner has a sound educational plan, but did find that the petitioner is not able to successfully implement the intended program due to unrealistic financial plan.
The CDE did find that this finding can be resolved if PPS is able to present evidence of the receipt of the funding included in the budget from Silicon Schools Fund, which is one of the conditions before the State Board.
PPS will also provide a revised 2018-19 budget once the facility lease and or rental costs have been determined.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the PPS petition for establishment at its December 7, 2017 meeting.
The ACCS moved staff recommendation to approve the PPS petition for establishment with conditions.
The motion passed unanimously.
CDE staff is here to address any of your questions.
OK.
Well, I think we ought to open the public hearing.
Yes.
OK.
Well, I'll now open the public hearing.
Each side has 10 minutes to present the case.
And so I would allow then to the petitioners for the charter, new charter, the first 10 minutes.
Please come forward.
Is it all right if I remove this flash drive and pull up our?
Oh, actually, it's right here.
We got it.
Good morning President Kirst and Trustees of the Board.
My name is Alexandria Lena Talley and I am the Lead Founder and Proposed Executive Director of Perseverance Preparatory School.
We are extremely grateful for your time today, for the recommendation for approval from the California Department of Education, as well as the unanimous recommendation for approval from the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools.
We would like to thank the staff for their time and the careful review of our full petition and are looking forward to sharing Perseverance Prep with you today on behalf of the community and the families that have worked so hard over the past year to bring this school to the children of San Jose.
I have been living and working in San Jose for the past nine years.
As a founding fifth grade teacher at Cornerstone Academy, I personally recruited 22 of the 30 students I taught.
I sat with parents in coffee shops, libraries, and living rooms to create a common vision for their children, the dream of college and the power of education.
When students reached sixth grade, I was tasked with finding a high-performing middle school to continue the work we had begun and further the academic gains they had made.
I began to understand how few quality options our parents had to choose from.
Each of my students applied to at least four different high-performing schools, and of the 30, all selected randomly through lotteries, three got in.
Parents and students were heartbroken when they received the news,
They now knew what an excellent education looked like and the power that it possessed.
I'll never forget the conversation I had with a distraught and tearful mother who asked where her child would go given the lack of options.
This mother had seen what a rigorous program could do for her son and how it shaped and informed her child's vision of himself.
He had entered Cornerstone almost two years behind grade level.
And by the time he was finishing sixth grade, he was testing well above the seventh grade reading level.
His story, like so many others, is why I became a teacher.
I brought him and his mother into my classroom to further discuss other options, given the harrowing news.
The student was quiet throughout the conversation, but at the end he turned to his mother and said, no matter what, I will be able to succeed because I have grit and perseverance.
It's amazing how children possess such clarity and poise in times of great disappointment.
And so Perseverance Prep was born.
The mission stands at the heart of everything we do and what we believe in.
It remains our North Star as we guide our students and prepare them to be the ethical leaders who will drive positive change in the future.
While difficult to explain an entire school program in 10 minutes, there are three key takeaways.
First, Perseverance Prep is a homegrown effort with a high capacity founding team.
Second, our community stands with us and our school design has been modeled and created in direct response to the conversations we've held with parents.
Third, there's a deep need for a high-performing middle school in San Jose and proof of parents seeking other options.
Our founding team is deeply rooted in the community.
All of the founding board members have lived or worked within San Jose and have a wealth of experience in various fields, including law, finance, facilities, and with a combined experience of over 30 years in education.
This team has engaged in over 350 conversations with community members, more of,
more than 250 of which have been with parents.
Through these conversations, a resounding sentiment rang out.
I want my child to go to college.
There are a number of other questions raised centering around these three buckets.
Would the school prepare my child for college?
How would my child be served if he was ahead or behind grade level?
And does the school solely focus on academics?
Through these conversations, we began to craft our vision.
Perseverance Prep is a college preparatory middle school serving grades five to eight.
We seek to ensure our students are firmly set on the path to succeed in a rigorous high school program and will thrive in a ninth grade honors English course when they matriculate from our eighth grade.
Each of our students will take speech and debate to develop argumentative skills and critical analysis.
Knowing that we will likely have a large population of English language learner students, we have strategically aligned our speech and debate curriculum to the English language development standards.
Modeled after the debate course at classical charter schools, a blue ribbon school founded through and supported by building excellence schools, students will participate in structured debates as they will be required to properly create their arguments, refute counterclaims, and prepare for a rebuttal.
Building this foundation in middle school provides students with a head start they will need for high school.
Many of our parents had concerns if their students were ahead or behind grade level.
Being located in the heart of Silicon Valley, we have the opportunity to be a one-to-one school, where each of our students will have access to a Chromebook, and with it, access to personalized learning platforms.
to grow every student every day in a way that honors and supports their challenges and maximizes their growth.
We allocate and prioritize time within our daily schedules to have students work on individual academic goals and will leverage a multitude of personalized learning platforms to reach these goals.
During our reading power hour and math power hour, we strategically use small group instruction to target students' specific skill gaps.
Data aggregated from these personalized learning programs allow teachers to drive instruction based solely on the needs of their students.
This occurs during our daily tutoring block, which allows teachers to remediate and give support where necessary.
While academics is our main focus, the content of our students' character is equally important.
We have integrated a service learning curriculum throughout our school, both in the culture of the school as well as direct instruction during the weekly leadership class.
Students work on a community betterment project to identify challenges within the community, create an actionable solution, and then work with the community to carry them out to fruition.
We will teach our students that by finding the power and potential of their voice, they may elevate others.
Perseverance Prep is different in many ways.
We seek to partner with parents and create an open line of communication, beginning with home visits, followed by weekly progress reports and cafecitos with the executive director.
By beginning the relationship early on and sustaining it throughout the year, the school will have a family feel.
We have held over 20 information sessions, three literacy nights, and even a fun summer barbecue to engage and welcome the families.
Our parents have been an integral part of the formation of not only the mission of Perseverance Prep, but its continued presence in the community, as evidenced by over 142 applications for the 128 seats for our inaugural class.
This many parents interested in a school that has yet to be approved is a testament to the belief in the specific mission and model.
As seen as a common thread throughout our presentation, student leadership is an integral part of the school culture, instruction, and everyday life at Perseverance Prep.
We have personalized learning and individual supports for our students to target the instruction to their exact needs.
To ensure everyone learns every day, we also provide robust professional development for our teachers through early release days and professional development for three hours, as well as weekly observations and coaching cycles.
there is a need to speak about the performance of students within San Jose.
While the overall scores for the SBAC show about 50% of students reaching proficiency in reading, and a little less than 50% reaching proficiency in math, when the data is disaggregated, its scores drop drastically, with fewer than a third of socioeconomically disadvantaged students able to score proficient on the SBAC, and fewer than 20% of Latino students able to perform math proficiently.
There is a clear need in San Jose.
Parents want this option, and parents have fought for this option.
Currently, almost 700 students are on wait lists for charters that serve grades five through eight.
Parents want more options.
Parents want choice.
Not only parents, but students.
Fortunately, she had to be in school today, so we took a video of her.
which may not work.
That's okay.
We'll show perseverance.
So she testified at the county board hearing.
Can the tech guys help with this?
We could try closed captioning.
Yes.
Is there audio?
Hmm.
It's playing, but we don't hear it.
No, is that online?
Mm-hmm.
OK.
Hmm.
Should be hearing it.
Turn it all the way up.
Might need to restart maybe, but it's just a browser, so I don't know why.
It's OK.
No problem.
I appreciate your help.
Yeah, it should be working.
True to form, it's all right.
So this was, it's okay.
It was a video of a student who's very excited and enthusiastic about attending Perseverance Prep.
We would like, once again, to thank the CDE staff and the ACCS for their diligence and the positive recommendation for approval.
While we gave a detailed response agreeing to the stipulations, we are happy to answer any and all questions you may have.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Christelle Johnson.
I'm the Director for Charter Schools for Santa Clara County Office of Education.
I'd like to provide you with a brief historical account of our decision-making process.
On June 30th, 2017, the Charter Schools Department of Santa Clara County Office of Education received a petition for a District Appeal Charter School for Perseverance Preparatory School Team to establish and operate a public charter middle school for grades five through eight for one year for planning plus an additional five years serving students through June 2023.
SCCOE complied with all applicable timeline requirements established by California Ed Code Section 47605B.
A public hearing was held on June 19th, excuse me, July 19th, 2017.
SCCOE Charter Schools Department staff analyzed the petition following California Ed Code and the board's guidelines regarding consideration of district appeal charters.
The analysis was based on review of the petition supported by information gathered during the capacity interview, which was held on July 25, 2017.
SCCOE staff found that the petition met requirements for required signatures and affirmations, although there were significant questions regarding mandatory school uniforms and fees.
Additionally, the staff also concluded after careful analysis that the petition presented an unsound educational program.
that the petitioners were demonstratively unlikely to successfully implement the program set forth in the petition, and that the petition does not include a reasonably comprehensive descriptors of the number of required charter elements, including, but not limited to, an unclear rotational model of instruction, undefined and unsound educational services practices for addressing English language learners and special education students, an overall lack of coherence between the deliveries
of core areas while integrating multiple or other instructional elements, the lack of metrics for target student performance and growth, a coherent system of analysis of, excuse me, to analyze and validate instructional effectiveness, deficiencies in employee qualifications, health and safety, admission requirements, and student discipline, including student suspension and expulsion.
There are also significant concerns in the areas of fiscal budget analysis and the petitioner's ability to attain and sustain enrollment, which is crucial for fiscal solemnity.
SECBOE held a decision hearing on Perseverance on August 16, 2017.
Although the staff found that the petition offered a program that might benefit students in a middle school educational system, due to the numerous deficiencies and issues as aforementioned, the SECOE Charter Schools Department staff made a recommendation of denial of the Perseverance Preparatory School petition.
The board reviewed and considered all information and voted as follows.
Four denials, two approvals, one trustee was absent during the decision-making process.
Good morning President Kirsten, members of the board.
My name is Nancy Alboran and I have the privilege to lead the San Jose Unified School District.
It is the most diverse and largest district in the county and I'm just really proud to do the work there.
This morning we are going to very quickly give you a brief
set of examples of why we believe this petition is deficient, and we also want to offer a path for moving forward.
So in San Jose Unified, we are incredibly committed to quality and equity.
It's something that we have been doing for the last 25 years.
We were the first district to go bankrupt, but we were also one of the first districts to pass an equity policy in the country.
We have a board that is committed to high quality options for all families and we work diligently to do that.
We built a robust evaluation system because 80% of our funds go to people and we know having the best and the brightest are going to deliver the outcomes we're looking for for students, particularly the students that have been underserved, not just in our public system but across the country.
And so with an accountability system for our employees, both leaders and teachers, and looking at charter operators that have high quality options, we are open to charter schools in our system that are of quality.
Good morning, I'm Steve McMahon, Deputy Superintendent for the School District.
We definitely wanna walk through some of the context.
Santa Clara County has 31 school districts, and when you include the County Office of Education, that's 32 LEAs.
Across those 32 LEAs, 84 charter schools have been approved.
So our county is one of the leaders in honoring the intent of the 1992 Charter Schools Act.
Charters have been very welcome in our community.
We have a diverse portfolio of schools throughout Santa Clara County, as evidenced by the 84 approvals.
A subset of Santa Clara County is the city of San Jose.
Often, when you hear a comment about San Jose schools, it's intertwined with San Jose Unified.
They're not the same thing.
We just happen to be the only of the 19 school districts in the city with San Jose in its title.
But there are 18 other school districts.
The petitioner mentioned Cornerstone.
It's not in our district.
It's very important when you consider the facts that you differentiate between the city of San Jose and San Jose Unified School District.
We are one of only 19 school districts.
in the city.
Across those 19 LEAs, 65 charters have been approved.
We're this little sliver compared to that prior big county map.
There are 10 charter schools currently open in the Santa's Unified School District boundaries.
Our board initially approved five of them.
Two of them were approved on appeal at the county level and three went directly to the county as countywide benefits.
So there are already 10 charter schools open.
The petitioner mentioned demand.
We want to make sure we're very clear on differentiating between San Jose and San Jose Unified.
The petitioner in the petition on pages 12 and 13 of the petition has a chart of wait lists.
It neglects to show you the wait lists of the existing charter middle schools in our boundaries because they don't have them.
And we called Sunrise yesterday, they do not have a wait list.
They are accepting students in all grade levels.
Downtown College Prep Middle School, Ace Middle School, Sunrise Middle School, all charter middle schools, all in San Jose, all serving the same demographics.
the petitioner seeks to serve.
We are concerned, like the county offices, about demand.
Are there a sufficient number of students to add a fourth charter middle school in the same geographic area, which is a small subset of the city of San Jose?
Perseverance did not qualify for Prop 39 facilities.
They did not have enough in-district students to be eligible.
If you look at their petition, there are no family signatures.
They submitted with teachers.
We've wondered from the beginning how many students there are within the San Jose Unified boundary
to substantiate the demand for this school, which we think is incredibly important because the CDE review found that the petition was deficient on 20% of the legal requirements, most notably the budget.
The CDE says the school cannot implement its program with the budget that was presented.
I've been doing budgets for school districts for a long time as a CBO.
If revenue is fixed and you have a substantial increase in facility costs, which the CDE says is going to happen, which is why they put the condition for a new budget, you're going to have to do something else on the expense side.
Fixed revenue, more for facilities, questionable enrollment demands, you have to cut expenses somewhere else.
We met with the petitioners last week regarding facilities since they're not eligible for Prop 39.
Sunrise Middle School, Ace Middle School have existing leases with us as charter schools.
We use the exact same template.
Perseverance is underestimated by at least 72% the cost of facilities in San Jose.
We are in Silicon Valley, you know how expensive it is.
Facilities are incredibly expensive in our area.
$155,000 is a generous estimate for the minimum cost for 15,000 square feet in San Jose Unified.
We think that presents a substantial problem to the state board and the legal process for charters.
If revenues fixed and expenses go out for some facilities, the petition has to change.
Increased class size, reduced support staff, something on the expense side must be adjusted to satisfy the state's requirement of a revised budget.
We feel that that means the petition is going to be a different petition, and you have a process to remedy that.
The petitioner should make the corrections,
return it to the local level.
We actually are thinking Perseverance is maybe one of the best positioned charters in the entire state.
It has feedback from the district, it has feedback from the county, it has feedback from the CDE.
Take the feedback, resubmit at the local level, the San Jose Unified is going to be approving it.
Because all of the deficiencies, if they're corrected, we won't have the legal ground to deny it again.
We are very concerned, though, that if the state board is putting conditions on a petition and forcing changes to it, that does not align to the process that the legislature intended.
Schools are supposed to come from the local communities.
It's local charter demand.
The teachers that signed this petition signed for a certain class size, certain support staff, certain budget.
Changing that budget without reengaging them on that budget, we don't think honors the intent of the Legislative Act of 1992.
So, we wanted to recommend a path forward.
We do think the best path forward is to take all of this feedback from the local level, the district level, and the CDE, incorporate it into a revised petition, and resubmit that petition.
We thank you very much for the time.
Santa's Unified staff is here.
We encourage you to be curious, ask us lots of questions, and we think it is essential to seek information.
Evidence is critical in discussions like this.
The wait lists, which schools are in Santa's Unified, which schools are in Santa Clara County, evidence and factual information is essential to the work you do.
We have our enrollment center team here, our tech team, bilingual, all of our departments are represented, and we're happy to answer any questions you may have today.
And we look forward to discussion.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the opening statements and our process is to take public comment and then you get all the input that we can.
And so the staff will call the roll and on the public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Janelle Rooley, Claudia Rossi, Gemma Ables, Joanna Latz, Melissa Urbach, Grace Ma, Joseph DeSalvo, Claire Crawford, Peter Ortiz, Brian Greenberg, Brett Bymaster, Stephanie Palmieri, Maria Marcello, Juan Torres, Janet Duran, Araceli Serrano, and I'll call additional names later.
Good morning, state board members.
My name is Janelle Rooley.
I'm an attorney with the Law Offices of Young, Middy, and Core here in strong support of Perseverance.
I think I just heard San Jose Unified School District saying that the district would approve this charter if the petitioners were to go back.
Have to say the other thing that I heard this morning was a evidence of a broken relationship or broken trust in a community I think that's what we have here It's frankly, it's very difficult for perseverance to believe that they would get a fair shake at the district This is the same district that
First of all, forced them to wait 49 days for a public hearing, 62 days for action, required a second set of petition signatures, and actually told the petitioners they had to get signatures from 100% of the meaningfully interested teachers when the law clearly says 50%.
In addition to that, the district stated at the advisory commission meeting that they proudly stated that they do not work with petitioners in the process.
So I hope what you're going to do today is vote on this petition that's before you.
The city has recommended approval.
The ACCS has supported it, and we look for your support.
Thank you.
Good morning trustees.
My name is Claudia Rossi.
I serve on the Santa Clara County Board of Education.
Thank you for this opportunity and for all you do.
I think I have a little idea of what you go through as you attempt to serve community.
I am here as an adult that arrived in California when I was seven years old.
I was an English learner and
And so I understand the importance of a strong curriculum that supports English language development.
So I come to examination of this petition in particular with that lens.
And I want to read to you something that I found very concerning.
What staff found is that the perseverance plan would only offer a bare bones curriculum to its students.
and would also make it difficult to maintain small group instructional settings.
Further, it found that there was insufficient time for ELD instruction.
And what that means is significant given that they organized community members.
I urge you to consider the suggestion made by San Jose Unified.
I think it would be best to serve our families.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Grace Ma.
I'm on the Santa Clara County Board of Education.
I've been on the board for 10 years.
I'm also a former engineer, Silicon Valley engineer, recovering as I say.
And I'd like to present some data, which I believe has been passed out to everybody.
It includes on the first page a map of the San Jose downtown schools.
And I've marked the elementary schools, middle school, and high school there.
The following three pages are data from the CDE website with the five by five placement performance indicators.
The first page on page two shows that all six schools which are in the downtown area are in the orange, red, and yellow areas.
San Jose has a number of schools all in the blue and green, I won't say that, they don't, but the schools in the downtown area to be served are all in yellow, orange, and red.
And that's in English language.
The next chart is on mathematics.
Likewise, the six schools are also in the red or yellow section.
And the last page is English learner progress.
Thank you.
President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the State Board of Education, thank you for your public service.
My name is Joseph DeSalvo.
I'm a trustee on the Santa Clara County Board of Education.
As a trustee on that board, I humbly request you to approve Perseverance Prep.
As a former middle school principal in San Jose and Santa Clara County, I know that leadership is a critical component of an effective school.
Perseverance has an extraordinary leader, as you just saw, that has led the work to build its vision, seek support, secure funding, and write an exemplary petition.
In addition, strong parent and city support is essential for success and Perseverance has successfully earned that support.
Perseverance will add essential and excellent middle school experiences to our city's portfolio of schools with developmental, social, emotional, curricular, and instructional best practices that will be scalable to all middle schools within the city.
Thank you for your support.
Good morning, my name is Johanna Latz, I'm a special education teacher in San Jose Unified School District.
I feel that the school plan and the budget for promise, perseverance indicate that the school
Plans only offer minimal services to students with special needs.
It indicates that the schools will either fail to meet the budget or practice discriminatory enrollment practices towards students with moderate and severe learning disabilities.
I didn't see anything in the plan that talked about students with IEPs nor students with 504s.
Students with 504s need accommodations in the curriculum.
that provide for a medical disability.
Students with IEPs need individual support services including speech and language services, adaptive PE, occupational therapy.
It could be vision and hearing disabilities.
There's nothing in the plan that addresses, that explains how perseverance will help students with those needs.
Thank you.
Hello, I'm Melissa Urban.
I'm an ELD teacher and resident and voter inside San Jose Unified.
My concern with this proposal is the ELD services that they're proposing in a mainstream speech and debate class.
We know that state and national guidelines say that best practices required a dedicated ELD instructional time.
Two-thirds of the students in our community are ELL, and this program just does not adequately serve our ELL students, and so I urge you to reject this.
Thank you.
Good morning.
My name is Brian Greenberg.
I am the CEO of the Silicon Schools Fund.
Our foundation works with the most innovative and best schools in Northern California.
In the past five years, we've made grants in the tens of millions of dollars to support now just about 40 schools that are district, charter, and independent schools.
In short, our expertise is quality.
That is our job from day one.
We've spent more than a year now with this Perseverance prep team.
And what you heard from other county board members about the quality of the founder and the team, we also are staking our reputation on.
It is because of this that we have now given and deployed $250,000 of support to Perseverance already, and we have plans to distribute another $550,000 of support.
We do not do this lightly, and we do this because we have such a strong belief and faith that this school will execute as the rest of our portfolio has done.
Our grantees score at the top quartile of the state of California.
These are exceptional schools in which we're honored to hopefully have perseverance be a part.
This is the kind of school the San Jose parents want and deserve.
Thank you.
My name is Brett Bymaster.
I'm a pastor in the San Jose area.
I spend my life working with low-income kids in the downtown community.
I want to make an illustration.
I want you to imagine that there are 300 or 400 students walking onto a tarmac, and there are two planes parked on that tarmac.
One of those planes is piloted by a pilot who has 15 years of experience and is licensed and credentialed to fly that airplane.
The other airplane is piloted by a pilot who got his pilot's license a year and a half ago and is not licensed to fly that airplane.
I want to ask, which one would you put the 300 students on?
I'd like to make an argument that running a school is just as complicated, if not more so, than flying an airplane.
I'm sure that Ms.
Lena Talley is a great educator, but she received, according to the California Department of Education, she received a clear credential in July of 2016.
She is not credentialed as an administrator.
According to the County Board of Education, the requirements for the executive director appear specifically designated to fit the current executive director, which may preclude any other person from filling this role in the future.
Leadership matters.
Good morning, my name is Stephanie Palmieri Farias.
I am a principal in a downtown school in San Jose Unified.
I'm also a parent in the district for 21 years.
The state found that perseverance did not have a sound description of suspension and expulsion policies and procedures.
My school has welcomed many students who have been expelled and basically kicked out of other schools for behavior issues.
We have supported those students and families when other charter schools did not.
All charter schools should have clear, transparent, legally compliant suspension and expulsion procedures, or we see the effects on it for everyone.
I'd also like to say that I have a lot of parents here who are going to need translation.
So we have our parent liaison who could do that translation, but I hope they're given two minutes so that they can give one minute in Spanish and that we can have the one minute of translation if that is OK.
That's OK.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Good morning, my name is Maria Marcelo.
I am a parent of student for more than 17 years now.
I am a president for United Mothers in the community of Washington.
To me, it's very important that if you guys are going to open new schools, to make sure that these schools are fully qualified.
First of all, that the students are the first priority.
With the community.
And also with the academic achievements as well.
I also want to comment that we're going to leave before the next topic, next school, Promise.
Personally, I don't believe that this school is capable of helping our kids in our community.
We need schools that are on top of everything academically.
And if they are not capable, why would we waste money on opening new schools when we can fix the ones that are already established?
She believes that working with the schools that are already established and investing more money will be more effective in opening new schools.
OK.
Come.
Good morning.
My name is Juan Torres.
I'm also a parent of the San Jose Unified School District.
I come here to share my opinion on the opening of the school, Perseverance.
As this have been denied twice for our county and San Jose School District, I believe that it's already enough.
For example, not having plans for ELD.
The lack of experience from the leadership.
Planes deportivos.
PE programs.
Apoyo a estudiantes que no renan sus estndares educativos.
Support for students who don't meet the standards.
Y carecer de firmas de la comunidad teniendo necesidad de estas escuelas.
And the lack of interest from our community.
No signatures.
Con respecto a la relacin de Promise.
Esta solicitud tiene faltas de apoyo para estudiantes aprendiendo el idioma ingls.
For Promise, I believe this school has the lack of plans to support students who speak other language.
They don't mention plans for kids who have a lack of, or disabilities learning.
They lack sports plans, or PE.
En la comunidad hay escuelas como por ejemplo Rocketship.
In our community there are schools, for example, Rocketship.
Donde los nios hacen deportes sentados.
With the kids do sports sitting down.
Por no tener las instalaciones adecuadas.
For the lack of facilities.
Dicha escuela est ubicada a dos bloques de nuestra escuela, Washington Elementary School.
This school is located two blocks away from Washington Elementary School.
Thank you.
I would like to ask the next group of speakers to please line up.
Silvia Valderrinos, Victoria Cuenca, Noe Guzman, Monica Vasquez, Vera Sloan, Robin High, Tim
Terang, Chad Italy, Marissa Alonso, Vitu, Andrea Sosuna, Vanessa Luciano, Nina Goswami, Eric Premack, and Ken Bird.
Good evening, my name is Jeanette Duran.
I am also a parent of the San Jose Unified School District.
I have two children in the elementary school Washington and one on the Sacred Heart.
My point of view on perseverance prep
Should meet the requirements that the state has required already previously.
Thank you.
Good morning my name is Silvia Valdovinos.
I am also a parent of the San Jose Unified School District.
Okay.
La Preparatoria Perseveranza.
Siga.
Veo que no tiene clases para ayudar a las personas que vienen de Mxico que apenas van empezando el ingls.
I see that the school perseverance lacks on ELD classes for students who are learning English.
No le brindan el apoyo a las personas, nios que necesitan tambin ayuda de bajo nivel?
They don't show any help for students who are or have low level.
I see that they have a bit of experience.
They lack on experience.
Tengo amigas donde tienen nios que tienen problemas especiales y andan buscando escuelas.
I have friends that have children with disabilities.
Y donde no los agarran en algunas escuelas porque no tienen el apoyo para sus hijos.
Where these schools have not welcomed their kids because of their disabilities.
Y ya que quieren hacer alguna escuela nueva que tenga todo para nuestros hijos, para los estudiantes, para que ellos salgan adelante.
If they're gonna open a new school, we would like these schools to be able to receive every single one of them.
Thank you.
Good morning, my name is Araceli Serrano.
I am here representing the San Jose Unified School District.
Perseverance Prep School doesn't show to have the right personnel for the students.
We need leaders with more experience to help our children.
I am a parent of a child who is diagnosed with autism and it is very hard for us to find schools that can help us.
And the few that exist might lose their funding because of these new schools.
For regular kids, it's very hard to learn.
Imagine for kids who have different disabilities.
Thank you.
Not my own.
I'm also a parent in the San Jose Unified School District.
And again, the state has found many things or lack of programs that will help and benefit those kids who are learning the language or that lack on, you know, they don't have high standards in school.
And we are receiving them in our schools right now currently.
And we see that they are promising things to parents that are not real.
I see it all the time.
Parents come to me and say, no, this school is gonna close at fifth grade.
They start rumors that are not real.
And a lot of our parents are thinking that we are gonna close the school because these new schools are gonna open.
And just, you know, in our neighborhood, we have three charter schools, and these three charter schools are doing an excellent job, and we are pro-charter schools, but these charter schools that are trying to open, they're not ready.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Claire Crawford.
I'm the senior policy analyst within the public interest, and I'm here to urge you to uphold the denials of the charter petition for Perseverance Preparatory School.
Unfortunately, the State Board of Education has a troubling practice of approving deficient local charter petitions that have been rejected by school districts and counties in which they're expected to operate.
In an analysis that we submitted via email, and which I have copies of here if you'd like printed copies, we found that between 2002 and 2017, the State Board of Education approved 71% of charters that had been denied at the local level.
More troubling, our analysis found that fully a third of the charters approved at the State Board were not in operation any longer.
Many of the problems identified by San Jose Unified and the Santa Clara County Board of Education in this petition are issues that have been raised before in petitions that resulted in SPE approval followed by school failure.
I think the San Jose Unified School District has offered an alternative path forward and it might be a good option to take.
Thank you.
Good evening.
My name is Victoria Cuenca.
I also a parent of the San Jose Unified School District.
I have a son in the Washington Elementary School and another one on the Sacred Heart.
In my experience as a parent,
has been very good in this case.
I believe all schools should have good personnel, qualified personnel.
And we'll speak about Promise School because we're leaving.
For me, personally, it's very important the type of education that my children receive.
Academy Promise does not have any criteria specifically for students with low academic standards.
How are they going to help our kids if they don't have it in the plan?
Thank you.
Gracias.
Good evening.
My name is Monica Vasquez.
I am here representing Washington Elementary School from the San Jose Unified School District.
I have two kids in Washington Elementary.
We have a very united group of mothers who are always on top of our kids, helping each other.
We're always united, looking on our surroundings of our school to make sure that everything is functioning properly.
Creo que las escuelas nuevas que aqu piensan abrir, deberan de tomar una opcin para mejor darnos fondos a nosotros como ya somos una escuela plantada, todo ese fondo que se utiliza para acadmicamente nosotros tambin nuestras escuelas abrir mejores programas para nuestros hijos, tratando que otras escuelas abran, unas escuelas nuevas y les falle.
Instead of opening new schools, I would rather see this money invested in our schools of our kids who are losing funding throughout the years.
And not wasting the money on these new schools.
Instead, investing in the schools that are already existing, I would love to see this happening.
Creo que las escuelas nuevas que quieren hacer tengan la idea de mejorar para otras personas que en verdad lo necesitan, no porque quieren abrir una escuela y si no les funciona, sea dinero perdido.
I want the schools that are forming as charter schools to think about the benefit of the people and not just thinking about opening schools.
Hi, my name is Vera Sloan.
I'm a San Jose Unified School District parent at a downtown elementary school.
When I read Perseverance's petition last spring as a parent and a person from a poverty background, it broke my heart to think about vulnerable children being in the environment it describes.
One where children are punitively denied what little arts education is offered if they do not have enough money in their account because of public punishment for developmentally normal behavior.
an inexcusably vague education plan built around a self-help book written by a businessman, failure to designate appropriate programs and funding for special education and ELD students, and a director who has meager teaching experience of any kind.
San Jose parents and community members spoke out locally against Perseverance and its differently troubled counterpart, Promise, which unfortunately the mothers here, we have to go pick up our children.
We're not going to be able to stay and speak.
We spoke about that in our own district and county, and our democratically elected representatives rightly did not issue these schools a charter.
Most of these parents and community folks cannot drive for hours to Sacramento during a work and school day, so they created a letter to all of you, I have copies, asking you to respect our right to local control.
Over 75 others have signed on just overnight.
Please respect the decisions already made in your local community and vote to deny.
Thank you.
Trustees of the Board, my name is Tim Terarug, and I've taught at Cornerstone Academy for six years.
I grew up on the east side, and I know the difference between the schools that I attended and the schools that I work at today.
Cornerstone, in many ways, has become my home, and I've learned how a school can become a family.
Cornerstone Academy was founded by Shara Hegde, a Building Excellence Schools fellow with commensurate experience as Ms.
Lena Talley.
Through this national nonprofit, Ms.
Hegde worked relentlessly to create a successful school after studying the highest performing schools across the nation over one year.
She was able to bring back what she had learned to better the community in San Jose.
Currently, Cornerstone Academy outperforms their district by 20 points in ELA and almost doubles the district scores in math.
Both Mission Prep and Cornerstone have strong track records and significantly outperform their districts as shown in the handout.
If Shara, if Ms.
Hegde had not been given her chance because of her youth,
Cornerstone would not have existed and the 560 youth that we serve today wouldn't be placed in lower performing schools.
Thank you.
Hello, trustees of the board.
My name is Andres Osuna and I'm a resident of San Jose.
After hearing the model and mission of Perseverance Prep, I became involved with the community outreach and engagement.
I find that San Jose Unified's claim that there isn't any community support is extremely hard to find because given the number of applications we've already received for an unapproved charter without a facility is just not balancing.
Clearly, parents are excited and passionate about the mission and model of Perseverance Prep, and they have already signed up, having full faith that the charter's value will be clear and evident.
Perseverance Prep is an opportunity to be a proof point in San Jose's community.
We need schools like Perseverance Prep.
And I really urge you guys to approve it.
And I would just also like to add real quick that I am a student pilot.
And I was the fastest pilot to ever be given a solo license.
And if you never give somebody their wings, how on earth are they going to fly?
Thank you.
Good afternoon, trustees of the board.
My name is Marissa Alonzo.
As a parent, I want nothing but the best for my son.
I want him to go to school and learn and be inspired.
I want them to have a deep sense of compassion and empathy.
Perseverance Prep's focus on service learning and general servant leadership is exactly how I hope to raise my son.
I want them to be able to critically analyze the world around them while simultaneously being able to seek to serve and help others in need.
The service learning component of a perseverance preparatory drives at the true purpose of education, to create and mold conscionable leaders.
We need to reinvigorate civic engagement and ignite a fire of curiosity and a love of learning within our children.
Through the service learning model, students will be able to see and understand why ethical leaders are necessary.
I've been a social justice activist, and I believe in serving my community and leaving this world a better place.
I don't pretend to know what my son will become, but I do know who he will become, a well-educated, compassionate person who also seeks to leave his community a better place.
I deeply urge the board to approve Perseverance Prep.
Thank you for your time.
My name is Eric Escobar.
I'm here on behalf of Vito who couldn't make it today.
Good afternoon members of the board.
My name is Vito and I am currently a parent of a fourth grade student named Vanessa.
Education is a top priority in our family.
It is very important to choose the best school for our daughter.
As parents we have to make sure that schools can provide good quality education both academically and socially for our children.
After researching schools for our daughter we found that many children struggle in middle school.
Our daughter, Vanessa, currently loves to read, is excited to learn new concepts in math, and is thrilled by technological projects.
As we look for middle school options, we know they are limited.
We have seen an excitement and joy of learning grow in Vanessa and want to see it continue.
We were so excited to hear about Perseverance Preparatory School, the mission, vision and service learning suits our daughter's needs.
We are looking for a school that helps students succeed and we are confident that Perseverance Preparatory School will ensure our daughter's academic success.
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon State Board of Education.
My name is Vanessa Luciano and I am a former student of Ms.
Lena Talley.
During the finality of fifth grade my mother decided to withdraw me from public school since after researching no San Jose middle schools appeared to be a compatible fit for me.
There's a dire need for quality options in San Jose.
Right now I live in downtown with the zip code 95112.
My options for middle schools in my neighborhood Hoover and Burnett rank at a dismal three according to great schools.
Alternatively when looking at the California dashboard and all of the San Jose Unified School District only two schools are ranked blue or high performing in both English language arts and mathematics.
One elementary and one middle school.
No wonder parents and students are seeking other options.
You simply can't funnel all the students into the one high-performing elementary and the one high-performing middle school.
One is simply not enough and as a student and a leader I demand more than one.
I'm a firm believer that all students deserve an excellent education and here at perseverance preparatory school we have an opportunity to do just that.
I strongly urge you to vote to approve perseverance prep today for the children of tomorrow.
Thank you for your time.
I'd like to call the final speakers.
Please line up.
Colin Miller, Patrick Bernhardt, Ona Kelly, Terry Burns, and Roxana Maracci.
Hi, everybody.
My name is Robin Gokawin, and my daughter will enter San Jose Unified, I'm sure much sooner than I expect.
My father was an immigrant, and my husband is also an immigrant.
And I want to send my daughter to a school that celebrates and promotes her rich history.
Perseverance is not that school.
They are not prepared to serve English language learning students, nor the students with special needs and without the support of a diverse student body.
The school cannot be a place that welcomes diversity or immigrant families and communities.
plan on paper, and they don't have the experience to execute even a perfect plan.
Further, they do not have the support of a lot of local San Jose parents, and if they do open and are not able to fill their school, then it will be a huge waste of money.
I'm not against charters, but I am strongly against perseverance and also promise, which I cannot stay for.
I will not only keep my daughter in attending a school like this, but I will also come all the way here to Sacramento and speak to all of you.
So thank you so much for listening to us during your lunch.
Promise not to be that cute.
Eric Premack with the Charter Schools Development Center.
We support the staff recommendation to grant the charter.
I did want to raise a concern, though, about what we see as an ongoing trend of raising new types of criteria before a charter is granted in this one.
department staff found that they were demonstrably unlikely to succeed because they hadn't received a grant pledge in cash form yet.
And we think that that's way beyond normal expectation.
We've worked with hundreds of schools that have received grant pledges well after the time the charter is granted.
Adding those sorts of requirements to what it takes to get a charter approved is leading to what we call the charter arms race, where you have to write more and more and more stuff into your charter petition that just makes the process more complicated and leads to more appeals coming up here in the first place.
And we would hope that the department would review some of those criteria and dial them back to what the law is really requiring us all to focus on.
Thank you.
Ken Bird on behalf of the California Teachers Association, I want to object to the one minute.
It does disservice to what we're doing.
Number two, I hope that this board picks up the cue that was said again and again.
It's all about local control and you become a local control board but you don't carry that concept over here.
So I hope it's not necessary for the legislature to put serious restrictions on you.
Now the last point I want to make is
I actually agree with Eric Premack.
I want to go on record, but for a different reason.
Either you gots the money or you don't.
Either you have the financial ability or you don't.
This is an expansion of saying, I'm going to let you have a charter if you can get your money on the come.
That's wrong.
Either you have the money and you've got a financial base, and the board does not need to get caught on another one of these charters
either under fraud or inability to fund itself.
So that's a new requirement.
I don't think it ought to be there, but I think it's a condition of getting the charter of having adequate financial foundation.
If you don't have that, you don't have anything, unfortunately.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
I'm reading on behalf of a parent who had a work commitment today.
My name is Chad Hall, and I'm currently a parent of a third grade student named Chase and an 18-month-old named Alexandria.
Our family, like so many others, value education.
When I met with the founder, Alexander Elena Talley, I had never heard of a college preparatory program so set on empowering middle school students.
Perseverance Prep isn't just about how well students read and write, but it also places a huge focus on character development.
Now more than ever, we need ethical people.
We need to be teaching students that their voices matter and they can be transformative leaders who seek to better their community.
San Jose needs high performing middle schools.
Each time I see the scores of students within San Jose, I am both deeply saddened and slightly enraged.
That information you have from earlier.
As previously mentioned, San Jose leaders with commensurate experience have gone on to lead successful and high-performing schools.
Perseverance Prep is a school dedicated to raising those scores and raising the next generation of leaders focused on serving.
As a parent, that is the kind of school I would want to send my children to.
Please vote to approve Perseverance Prep.
Thank you for your time.
Good afternoon.
I'm Cullen Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
We're in strong support of this petition and the CDE recommendation to approve it.
Not all charter schools that get denied at the local level make it up to this level of appeal.
Mostly you'll see just the ones that are really put together and the ones that CCSA supports also have gone through a very rigorous review process.
So I wanted to just make that clear.
I agree with Eric on the budget situation.
I would want to note that while we're discounting things that are not in the bank, money that's in the bank, there are a lot of things that are changing.
A budget is a plan, and as we saw just last week, the governor proposed a budget that included, you know, full implementation of LCFF, which will be a huge boost for this school as it moves forward next year.
as well as $28 million for charter school facilities, which would also be a benefit to this school.
So those things are not represented, as well as the charter school grant program, which the application has not been put out yet for them to even submit for yet.
But if they're successful there, that's another $600,000.
So there's a lot of money available.
Budgets are fluid and planned, so I would just point that out.
Thank you.
Good morning, board members.
My name is Patrick Bernhardt.
I'm the president of the San Jose Teachers Association.
We oppose the perseverance petition, but SJTA does not reflexively oppose all charter schools.
We have been supportive of several of the charter schools that are existing in San Jose Unified today, both at the point of initial petition and reauthorization.
We do, however, in evaluating charter petitions, prioritize evidence of local community support.
We have some evidence today and at previous public hearings of community support from families that live outside of the San Jose Unified School District, but we have ample evidence that families that live inside the San Jose Unified School District are not interested in the perseverance petition.
We've heard that there are 142 applications for the school, but we also heard today that the school had an insufficient number of in-district students to qualify for Prop 39
facilities, which indicates to me that of the 142 applicants, the vast majority of them live outside of the San Jose Unified School District.
We urge you to decline the petition and invite them to re-petition with San Jose Unified if they can demonstrate community support.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Ona Keller.
I'm with the California Teachers Association.
I'd like to point out that, according to the Santa Clara County staff report, there are no employment positions at PPS, including the executive director, that require any type of general finance or public school finance, in particular, knowledge, training, or experience.
Additionally, the petition does not comply with the Political Reform Act, Government Code 1090, and doesn't specify which positions would have to file a Form 700.
I unfortunately was able to work with the teachers and the students and the community at Livermore Valley Charter School in their last year before they closed.
It was a school that was authorized by you and then went back to the district level because they were not impressed with the level of oversight you were able to give that school.
That school went bankrupt, and it was because they didn't have proper conflict of interest policies.
They didn't have proper fiscal controls.
They didn't have knowledge of
of how to run a school budget.
And so that had a devastating impact, not only on the almost thousand students that went to those charters, but also in the Livermore Valley Joint Unified School District, which had to pick up the pieces and accept hundreds of students into their schools.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Terry Burns, California School Boards Association.
As Member Holiday noted earlier this morning, the State Board should be judging appeals of charter applications as they come to you without significant changes from the applications.
that were reviewed at the local level.
We don't have a particular position on this or any of the charters before you today, but we believe it's inappropriate for the Board to approve a charter with material revisions that have not been part of the initial discussions in the community.
Likewise, we believe that a State Board action to approve a charter with material revisions can work to discourage good dialogue at the local and the county level.
As a principle, CSBA encourages charter determinations to be made locally based on dialogue between the parties.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Roxana Marishi.
I'm the education chair of the San Jose Silicon Valley NAACP.
I'm also a researcher studying local school closures and charter growth, specifically the disproportionate negative impacts of charter expansions on communities of color.
You've been informed of numerous red flags and clear deficiencies in the Perseverance Charter petition.
I've outlined some of these on the EDU Researcher blog, brought some hard copies for you as well with additional questions.
The NAACP Movement for Black Lives, Journey for Justice, dozens of community, youth, education, and civil rights groups have backed the resolution calling for moratorium on charter expansion until laws can ensure transparency, effective oversight, democratic governance, and fair enrollment practices in the charter sector.
You are in a critically important position with responsibility to serve and protect children in the state of California.
We urge you to not turn a blind eye to the serious deficiencies that have been raised.
To do so would be a disservice to the communities you serve.
Please respect and uphold the unanimous decision of the San Jose Unified School District to deny this petition.
Okay, that concludes the public comment and I now declare the public hearing closed.
So we're ready for board member questions or responses to this.
Pardon?
Yes, the liaisons want to speak first, board member Holliday.
Thank you and thank all the public speakers.
I wouldn't prefer at this time to go ahead and let the board members ask any questions they have.
I have some questions too, but I think it'd be best if we just open up conversation.
Okay, Board Member Strauss.
I would ask CDE to explain the conditions that you have now put on this, that you're recommending approval of conditions.
So I'd like to understand the conditions and whether they're addressing some of the issues that were brought up in our testimony.
So I think that would just be helpful.
Okay, I will do my best.
There are five conditions.
So one is to accept, basically for the board to accept the state board conditions of authorization.
But the others are in terms of reflecting the state board as the authorizing entity.
because that currently is not in the petition.
So that is something that would be obviously after the fact if it is indeed approved at the board level.
We do have the third condition is about the fund, the 200,000 that is identified coming from the Silicon Schools Fund.
So there is a condition to ensure that that is indeed part of the budget.
The fourth condition is in terms of the facility.
We do not know at the time, and the petitioner did not know at the time, in terms of whether they would have a Prop 39 facility through San Jose.
What we heard today, it sounds like they do not.
And a lot of times when they do come before us, they don't have the facility piece worked out yet.
So we do want to know what the facility lease agreement is going to look like.
And the fifth stipulation is a revised budget with a comprehensive narrative and assumptions.
A big piece of this, again, is the facility costs.
What are those costs going to be and how are they going to be reflected in the budget?
Sure.
Yeah, I'd like to ask, there's a, I think somebody testified for here that's from the Silicon Valley Schools Fund or is there some?
Yeah, I'd like to ask that gentleman to come up.
Can you describe what the situation is with your funding and a little bit about how you work and then
Whether you support facility costs and how long you fund people.
Often funding goes away after two years or something and then they're on their own.
So I'd like to get a better idea of that.
And then finally, what is the status of this application before your fund?
You're a non-profit 401c3?
Go ahead, just give us an overview.
So I'm frankly a little surprised that this has caused so much confusion because we operate the same way any foundation would.
We make a commitment.
It goes through our board approval process.
As I said, we've now deployed tens of millions of dollars over the last five years in the Bay Area for 40 plus schools.
We've never once had a letter questioned.
We provided two letters to staff affirming this commitment.
The short version of this is any foundation will set requirements for what they expect a grantee to do.
And if a grantee doesn't do that, they can't necessarily take you to court and enforce a future claim against you.
That is the only requirement on our money.
In 95% of all cases we have made grants, we have fulfilled the full and complete grant promise.
They're only counting $200,000 of potential funding for us.
We intend to make $800,000 of support.
So, if any of the board members have any concern about fiscal adequacy from Silicon Schools Fund, I would say our track record of 40 schools and tens of millions of dollars should put your mind at ease in that regard.
Our funding model is that we generally fund schools in year zero before they open, and then years one, two, and three, at which point their financial models hit break-even, and they can sustain themselves on per-pupil revenue, and that's what our funding is designed to do.
I just want to say, in general, when I read this particular point, I also do work with charter schools and I depend a lot on foundations, so typically there is an award letter that goes out to folks, to the recipient.
As somebody that subgrants, I'm not going to give you the money until you're approved, right?
But once you're approved and you show approval, then there is an award letter and then becomes a memorandum of understanding or whatever that may be.
So this is not an uncommon practice.
This is someone that, if you're involved with foundations, non-profit world, even corporate grants, this is very typical.
You do get a pledge for funding, but then there are some requirements that have to be met, and one of them is approval.
You can't release money if there is no school to run.
But there is pre-implementation funds that could be given.
There's different levels of funding.
And then there's a pledge.
Once you get started, we will pledge this amount.
But of course, you need approval before that happens.
So I do have questions about the charter, but that wasn't one of them.
That is accurate.
Yeah, and of the 40 charters you've funded, how many have gone under quickly, or after you left them?
Yeah, so all 40 are not charters.
As I said, we work with district schools, including San Jose Unified.
We have granted them as well, as well as independent schools.
Zero schools have gone under.
Our schools score at the 75th percentile of the state.
Average same FRL.
We don't support every school and as CCSA said you're seeing the best petitions that we've seen in a long time It's very ironic to find myself here twice in one day for two different petitions coming out of the same district I've never taken a step of driving to Sacramento to testify before but that's how strongly we feel in the quality of these applicants Thank you Yes, like member Ortiz Lacone I have wait a minute Brian I
I also have, as you do, experience with philanthropies, and these are philanthropies.
They are tax exempt the way that philanthropies are.
But in particular, I also know Silicon Schools Fund.
And I'll make the same comment at the next agenda item.
Silicon Schools Fund and, what's the other one, SV,
New Schools Venture Fund.
I know both of them.
They only support the highest quality petitions and schools with the most promise.
And schools, primarily schools that are dedicated to raising achievement in the lowest income students who might go on to become first gen students.
And it's a kind of, so that's a common practice, number one.
And second, they are the kind of organizations with the kind of reputation that don't squelch on their letters of commitment.
If they've got a letter of commitment, it's money in the bank.
That is accurate as well.
Any other board member questions?
Board member Ortiz-Lacombe.
Board member Burr will go first.
Just a clarification, and this is either for our liaisons or for Lisa, the conditions that you just enumerated again, my recollection is those are fairly common other than the ones that are specifically tailored to this one that we just heard about from an outside funder.
but the revised budget that we always ask for that as I recall because there's typically both a delay in it coming to us that would affect what resources are available and as we heard earlier there's a governor's budget that's pending that would increase funding for all LEAs.
So just wanted to clarify that because I heard a lot of testimony about us accepting material revisions which I did not see in this petition.
I would agree.
There are certain conditions after the fact that once the board takes action, and if it is a state board authorized charter, that then we do work out with the petitioner on behalf of the board.
Board Member Ortiz-Lacon.
You know, every time we have one of these hearings, there's the local control argument, and we absolutely believe in local control, but it is also in our responsibility to hear appeals, and there is a process for that.
You know, we're not bypassing local control.
That is something that we have the responsibility to do, is to hear these charter schools' petitions.
And so, I just wanna say that, because every single hearing, we get that argument.
But I have questions and I don't know if this should be directed to you or to the petitioner.
One of the things that as a Latina, as a former English learner, as somebody who wants to make sure that our students receive the best quality education, it's always great that folks want to come into communities of color and assist.
But there's always a chance that they won't.
And it's on the backs of our students.
So it could be successful, and that's great for our students.
Or it could really be an experiment, and that's on our students.
And my question is specific to EL students.
I heard a lot of the parents mention that.
I saw that throughout the petition.
We received a letter, and I just want to clarify that this is actually true, that the initial petition had, under identifying, serving, and assessing English language learners, that the petition spelled out the acronym for SIOP, which is Shelter Instruction Observation Protocol, as Society for Industrial and Organizational Psychology.
That's a huge mistake for somebody who is working with EL students if you don't know the proper protocol or what it stands for.
So for me, it's great that you wanna serve our students, but do you know how to serve our students?
So I wanna know a little bit more about the experience of this charter petition or the leadership in working with students, with English learners, and in particular, in reviewing the petition
That seems to be one of the items that needs improvement.
Is that correct in terms of the educational plan?
I will look through the petition and get back to you on that question.
But I know that as we did go through the petition, we did identify in that area for English learners that they did have a comprehensive description of the plan for English learners.
But I can look a little further and get back to you on that question.
But in the meantime, if you wanted to hear.
Yeah, because it's so easy to go back and look for the right terminology and put in the right practices.
But if it's textbook and not experience, then that's very different.
Thank you for your question.
We did also receive the same blog post this morning, and frankly, there's no excuse.
I do apologize for this oversight.
I am familiar with SIOP.
We use it regularly at Cornerstone Academy, and it is seen throughout the petition.
So the reason why they think that we had a significant understanding of the ELL population that we're going to serve is because
All of the nine protocols that SIOP includes are throughout the petition.
So from training our teachers during the summer professional development, including both language objectives as well as content objectives, to ensuring that students are accessing their background schema, to ensuring that teachers are able to use Realia for ELL students to allow them to access that content.
The strategies are all throughout the petition.
I would hate for our entire petition to come down to this one error, but I do understand the concern.
20% of the students in San Jose Unified are EL students, so it's not an error.
It's an entire population, and that's my concern.
Thank you.
Board member Valdez.
Okay.
I just have a question.
I'd like to have clarification on the leadership.
Who's going to be running this school?
Who has an administrative credential?
Who understands the day-to-day operations, the financial considerations that have to be made on a daily basis?
Who's going to be doing that?
I am the proposed Executive Director.
Ultimately, the Board will need to approve me as the Executive Director.
I have taken part in a Building Excellence Schools Fellowship, so the two schools that you have been given, both Cornerstone Academy and Mission Preparatory School, were also founded through the same program.
Overall, there's 668 hours of training, including
budgeting, including finance, including curriculum, including instruction, as well as simply leadership training and coaching with teachers.
So I have undergone that fellowship from the 2016 to 2017 school year.
Charter schools do not need administrative credentials, right?
Correct.
Okay.
Any other?
I have a question while we're waiting.
So, there's been this distinction between children who would go to this school who are in San Jose Unified and those that are not in San Jose Unified.
And I want to explore that a little bit.
I live near San Jose.
The district, as they pointed out, has 19 school districts in its boundaries.
And I think San Jose Unified has been described as a banana which sort of goes through the middle of the district.
So there are a lot of small districts that have bought San Jose Unified, some medium-sized districts.
And there has been, I know, in charter schools in San Jose, movement across boundaries.
I talked to the
superintendent of Franklin McKinley very recently and he said in one of his schools and it was typical that 45 percent of the students in his in the charters in Franklin McKinley were not from Franklin McKinley.
So it's a little unclear where, you know, these students are going to come from but they're I wanted the board to know it's there are adjacent and you can't
Uh, you know, when you go from the Union District to whatever the next district is, it's, you know, you go through some suburban streets and there's a shopping mall, a shopping strip and there's not a lot of clear delineation of, of a lot of the
of this area.
Yeah.
So I, I wanted to explore, you know, what the demand is.
And so maybe if San Jose Unified could come up and talk about this issue.
As I understand our responsibility, we, we do not have to certify that the people will come from in the district.
They can come from anywhere.
So maybe you could comment on this, Matt.
Can I just clarify?
So our schools themselves are built so that anyone in this entire state of California can apply to our school.
So if somebody from L.A.
really wants to make the commute, they absolutely can.
What our safeguard is, is our lottery preferences.
So once we exceed our capacity, which we already have, of 128 seats our first year,
We've already had 142.
Our lottery protocol allows for us choosing or preferencing in-district students first.
I believe for our very first year, it's in-district students first.
For subsequent years, we allow siblings in ahead of them, and then go to out-of-district students.
So no matter what, our lottery preferences allow for those in-district students to be allowed into our school first.
We totally agree, charter schools don't have district boundaries, but one of the concerns we have is the health of the system, including the existing charter schools.
So we talked to all the petitioners about doing a demand analysis and making sure they're very aware of the landscape.
When we received this petition, we flagged right away that none of the existing middle school charters were cited in the petition for their wait lists.
That doesn't mean this couldn't be a good quality program, but it is, in the intent of the law in 1992, it's to create competition and opportunities for families and teachers.
We also think we have a responsibility to balance that against schools opening and closing.
We've tried to get all of the charter operators in San Jose and the county together so they start coordinating on when they submit petitions so they're more likely to be successful.
And we showed in the slides, Santa Clara County is a charter welcoming county.
San Jose Unified has 10 charter schools open already.
One of the concerns is they're not at full capacity.
In downtown San Jose, in our borders, there are three charter middle schools serving the same demographic and none of them are full.
That puts a budget pressure on all four of them if Perseverance were to open.
They're going to compete for the same population of students.
And that just is something that the board, we think, should consider.
We understand that under charter law,
That is what potential finding when the CD says demonstrably unlikely to implement the program because of budget concerns That was our point that we do think it is worth noting.
There are three charter middle schools accepting applications accepting students and some of them are
struggling with enrollment already.
So the competition in our area is happening.
We think it's essential that the board distinguishes us between other counties where there is not parent choice.
Right now as family in downtown Santa Zena has three charter middle schools to choose from and because of the desegregation court order in the 80s, all of our schools are choice schools as well.
There are 10 charter middle schools in our boundaries and 41 traditional schools with a choice enrollment process.
We maintain what's called a voluntary integration plan
All of our families have the ability to move schools.
So families often choose schools for various reasons, neighborhood, commute, work, but in San Jose Unified, you can choose any of our schools.
We have high-performing schools, we have schools we need to do better with, but we value that choice system, we value the equity system.
You heard the superintendent say we want high-quality options.
We've approved a lot of charters, and I want to make sure you understand there are three charter schools in the same demographic, in the same location, and none of them are full.
Hey, Board Member Holliday?
Yes, thanks.
Pardon me.
To go back to Terry Byrne's comment earlier, I do think this board is very sensitive to the notion of material revisions that are inappropriate and change what the local district and county examined in the petition.
And I do think that we certainly in this case are not stepping over any line whatsoever.
Secondly, I also think that it's very clear that there's a significant amount of funding promised to this school, and I see no reason why that funding wouldn't come.
I do have a concern about the English ELD comments that Member Ortiz-Lacombe made, and I'm not entirely satisfied with the response from the petitioner.
I'd ask you to come back up one more time, please.
So a mistake was made, an error was made.
I don't think in any sense you meant to discard a significant population of students who may attend your school.
But you do need to prove to us that as best you can, that you and your team will be capable of serving these students in a high quality professional way.
Can you do that?
And thank you for your question and thank you for allowing me to clarify.
Again, Cornerstone Academy worked very closely with a high population of ELL students.
We had over 20% of our students were ELL, and as you can see, our test scores prove that our ELL students were outperforming the district by upwards of 20 points.
So, as a teacher there and as a teacher who was able to reclassify 100% of her ELL students when I taught fifth grade and 97% of my students when I taught sixth grade, it is very clear that I know and understand how to serve those students and how to get them where they need to go.
Okay, thank you.
Yes, please.
I'd be happy to hear your perspective.
Thank you.
Thank you so much, I appreciate it.
I'm Jackie Zeller, I'm the Associate Superintendent in San Jose Unified, and I oversee Division of Instruction.
This is Jodi Lacks, she is our Director of Elementary Curriculum Instruction, has worked for years with English learners, and is adamant about rights of English learners.
We judge the petition based on what's written in the petition, not what was the intent or what we think that they might mean or are going to do.
So, I'd like Jody to talk just for a minute about what we saw in the petition.
Good morning.
I think it's still morning.
We had some serious concerns about speaking to the program, and I do understand that Ms.
Natale, I'm sorry, I probably said that wrong, but she may have been a wonderful teacher, but that does not always equate to coaching and being able to lead other people.
and being able to train them to do what is needed for English learners.
The plan does not have any focus on English language development.
There's a minimal reference to the ELD standards, but their focus for supporting students that are English learners is based on basic skills.
And we know that there's a difference between ELA skills and English language development.
There's no focus on using their home language or honoring their home language and building on that.
and there's no focus on quality reclassification processes.
They haven't even mentioned the fact that teachers have input and should be a part of the reclassification process.
They don't even list that in their reclassification criteria, which concerns me.
The other piece that concerns me is that the EL focus, the ELD support that they're planning on providing, they would be pulling students out of speech and debate or content area.
It's different in different parts of their plan.
And I don't believe that our English learners should be pulled out of those core pieces of content and instruction.
Thank you.
Board member Williams.
If I could hear from the petitioner again.
Can you explain the speech and debate and ELD connection and how that would work?
Thank you.
I appreciate your question.
So we are not pulling any students out of speech and debate.
Speech and debate is an integral part of our core curriculum.
We have specifically aligned it to the ELD standards so that students have designated instruction during that time.
So each of the students, based on their specific levels, are placed in different speech and debate
So for example, if you have 128 students, 32 students who are at a level one, for example, would all go into this classroom for their specific lesson.
So speech and debate, we then restructure the students to going to each of their levels based on their current classification.
So we're not pulling students out during speech and debate.
It's so critical that they're there for that.
So what I envision when you say that, and I'm not a specialist in either one of these, is that you're using the speech and debate format and the critical thinking skills and the arguing from evidence and all of that stuff as the format for also doing ELD.
Correct, for our designated instruction.
For our integrated instruction, that takes place throughout the day.
So for our designated instruction, which is also very clear because our speech and debate scope and sequence is aligned to those English language development standards.
So I'm unclear as to why we would align them if then we're gonna be pulling out our ELL students.
Right, it makes it unnecessary to pull out.
I have another question and that is,
I know ELD instruction is not the same thing, is very specific, but I have some, I'm wondering what, the students that have signed up, the parents that have signed up indicating interest in enrolling, what is their demographics?
We do not pull their demographics.
That's part of our lottery process.
We just have their name, their address.
So in terms of where you're planning to locate and where you've recruited and that kind of thing, what is the demographic?
It is a large ELL population and a large Hispanic population.
And large low income?
Yes, that as well.
Again, given that we don't know necessarily where our facilities are, we were looking at the 95112 zip code and the 95126 zip code.
But based on where we find facilities, we may be having to bus students or to change our location.
And what is your response to the district's point that there are three middle schools in a similar kind of geographic area that aren't at capacity right now?
Again, I think that we have very different programs.
We have an extended school day.
DCP and ACE don't.
I also think that we have a very different, quite frankly, academic model.
We are a college preparatory program.
And while DCP is, they're located in a very different area.
To the best of my knowledge, ACE, in fact, does have a wait list, according to the call that I had with them yesterday.
And one of their leadership team members sits on our board.
So I think we just have very different information.
Okay, one last point I wanna make while you're still standing here is that I have some data on San Jose Unified School District and this is the most current data from 2016-17 that was posted by CDE in late September.
And it indicated that on the CASP that students meeting or exceeding standards that the Latinos population in San Jose Unified School District, 35% of the Latino population.
met or exceeded those standards compared to 72% of the white and 86% of the Asian, and pretty much roughly the same for math, that the graduation rate was lower for the Latino population, 83% compared to the mid-90s.
for those other two, and the percent of students who have graduated and have completed college admission requirements, CSU, UC, 33% for Latino, 61% for white, 78% for Asian students in the San Jose Unified School District.
So how would you describe what you hope to make different for the Latino students in that area?
very similar to, again, Cornerstone Academy, ensuring that we are reaching and not only surpassing the typical proficiency of any San Jose Unified student, but are in fact making them beyond or more advanced than their white or Asian counterparts.
We want to ensure that they're set on the same trajectory that everybody else is.
The fact that you have 83% of students on a college trajectory, whereas it drops drastically, I think that that's unfair and unequitable.
Okay, thank you.
Vote number holiday.
Thank you.
You may sit down, please.
Thanks.
Based upon the ACCS unanimous recommendation, based upon the CDE's recommendation, based upon what we've heard today, I make the motion to approve the CDE recommendation.
I second the motion.
Further board discussion?
Okay all those in favor raise your hands.
Okay there's one abstention.
Okay the motion carries.
Thank you and I think we'll take a break.
So let's come back at 1.15.
program due to an unrealistic financial plan.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Promise Academy petition for establishment at its December 7, 2017 meeting.
The ACCS moved staff recommendation to deny the Promise Academy petition.
The motion did not pass by a vote of 3 to 2.
Five votes are required to move an ACCS motion forward to the State Board.
Therefore, no recommendation was moved.
Promise Academy proposes to serve 210 pupils in TK through grade 2, 5, and grade 6 in 2018-19 school year.
Promise Academy will then expand their services each year over a seven-year term to 280 pupils in TK through grade 3 and grade 5 and grade 7 in 19-20.
385 pupils in TK through grade 9 in 2021-22, 420 pupils in TK through grade 10 in 2022-23, 455 pupils in TK through grade 11 in 2023-24, and 490 pupils in TK through grade 12 in 2024-25.
The CDE finds that Promise Academy does not provide for adequate accommodations for all subgroups of pupils, including English learners, long-term English learners, foster homeless youth, and pupils with disabilities.
Based on information listed in the petition, under Promise graduation requirements,
Pupils must complete the Scholastic Aplitude Test, SAT, or the American College Testing, ACT, to University of California or California State University eligibility standards.
They must complete three advanced placement tests,
Yes, or college courses, I'm sorry.
Did I say, I apologize, college courses.
Complete a college readiness course, develop a college plan, complete at least four applications to four-year colleges, and gain acceptance at at least one four-year university.
The only required courses for high school graduation offered in grade 11 and grade 12 are AP English Language, AP English Literature, AP Biology, AP Physics, AP US History, and AP Government and Economics.
Additionally, the CDE finds that Promise Academy's graduation requirements would appear to constitute an impermissible pupil fee and therefore violate Ed Code section 49011B1.
The requirements to complete three AP tests, SAT and ACT, and submit at least four applications to four-year colleges would constitute an expense to the pupil.
CDE notes that Promise Academy has made no provision either in the petition, the projected monthly multi-year budget, or the budget narrative and assumptions to offset these expenses to pupils in order for them to meet Promise Academy's graduation requirements.
Subsequently, the CDE also finds that Promise Academy is not able to successfully implement the intended program due to an unrealistic financial plan.
Promise Academy's budget includes fundraising targets for each year and does not provide estimated rent for a private facility in the downtown area of San Jose Unified School District.
The CDE was not able to determine if the 2018-19 budget amounts, particularly for facilities, would be sufficient.
CDE staff is available for any questions that you may have.
Thank you.
Okay, we will again have a public hearing to start then public comment.
So I declare the public hearing open and we will give the proponents for the charter the first shot and with 10 minutes.
Okay.
Good afternoon, I believe, President Kirst, board members, CDE staff, and guests.
My name is Dr. Anthony Johnson, and I'm the school founder with Promise Academy.
And on behalf of our families and supporters, I would like to thank you for the opportunity to present today about our journey in our school.
I would also like to thank the CDE staff for their work and feedback on our petition.
Over the past year and a half, a dedicated group of parents in San Jose have worked to help design a small school with robust individualized supports for each child.
A small representation of those parents are here today on behalf of our larger group of parent leaders.
As I've personally spoken to and met with hundreds of families in downtown San Jose, many times in their living rooms, they've expressed what they want in a school for their babies.
What's resonated with me most is that you can't hear their stories and be unchanged.
My story is their story.
Just like the majority of our families in downtown San Jose, I'm a person of color who grew up in poverty with a single mother and loving grandparents.
They did not know much about the schools or other options they may have had.
It wasn't until the 11th grade that a teacher pulled me aside and gave me personal attention.
She showed me my work and the work of other students.
She changed my schedule without my permission, and she placed me in advanced classes.
She changed my trajectory and made me to see myself as a scholar instead of just an athlete or an at-risk kid.
This led me to attend college, where I gained my bachelor's degree in English and a minor in Spanish, played professional baseball for a short time, and then got a master's degree in curriculum instruction and my doctorate in educational leadership.
I've dedicated my life's work to education and changing the trajectory of our most vulnerable students and families.
The lens I bring to Promise Academy is that of father and my hopes for my own children.
And this is my most important job.
But in my professional experience as a teacher of English language development and as a school leader for seven years,
I know the importance of a quality education.
And I also know the importance of experience.
I've launched a large comprehensive high school from the ground up, a $90 million project in the Central Valley, in the city of Merced.
This was a one-to-one school.
And I feel blessed to be able to stand before you because deep down I know, after being a high school principal for a long time, that 11th grade is too late to start having high expectations for students and robust individualized supports.
A student's preparedness for college and career should not be based on luck, but rather on a strategic approach and systemic supports that make sure no matter a child's address, color, or income level, we have the same expectations and a better outcome.
And that's how we designed Promise Academy.
Very briefly, what you see on the left side of your screen are the core values that our parents established prior to designing Promise Academy, and these values are aligned to the best of their family values they hold so dear.
The goal for our school is to provide an environment of rigorous daily instruction, be culturally responsive to the needs of our students, to help them to understand, and ultimately use what they've learned to better understand and affect the world around them.
How this plays out is listed here on the screen for our students who will be entering our school, hopefully next year.
Let's call this student Esmeralda.
Her school day begins with social-emotional learning and developing empathy and awareness towards people and situations.
The theme for this unit is the contribution of persons with disabilities.
Throughout this unit, Esmeralda will participate in discussions, journaling, guided reading, research, guest speakers, et cetera.
In her math class, she'll be learning the concept of slope,
in small groups, direct academic instruction.
In her English class, she'd be reading a novel written by a person with disabilities and learning to analyze text and research the challenges of persons with disabilities.
And lastly, in the Innovation Lab, which is inspired by and in partnership with the Tech Museum of Innovation in downtown San Jose, she will complete a design challenge where she measures and assesses the slope of ADA ramps,
of local stores and organizations, plugs her data into the slope formula, then researches ADA regulations to determine if these ramps are compliant.
If they are not, she will build a prototype of those in our innovation lab that make them compliant.
Thank you.
In our more than 100 pages that we submitted with our petition, there's one page that has garnered more attention, and that is the chart on page 82 that lists our goals for graduates.
We've gotten really good feedback from the CDE staff and the ACCS, and we realized that this page in our petition could have been clearer.
And we're glad to have the opportunity to clarify our intent on the record and highlight how all supports for students with various learning styles and abilities are fully outlined in this petition.
First, I want to give the reason behind having a school with high expectations, especially as it pertains to our community in downtown San Jose.
As it currently stands in downtown San Jose, only 35% of low-income students of color graduate from high school having completed all requirements that make them eligible for four-year colleges and universities.
We wrote our petition based on community need and our aspirations for our children.
This is not to say all students will choose to enroll in a four-year college or university, which is perfectly fine.
But as parents, we are fearful that this trend, if not corrected, will continue and more than 60% of our children who we feel have limitless potential will not even have the option of attending college.
Other great schools such as Summit, Aspire, East Bay Innovation Academy have similar or even more rigorous graduation requirements and are getting great results for our traditionally mostly underserved students.
They made the big bet that if they closed the expectation gap for some students versus others and provided additional supports to ensure they met those expectations, then more students would have an opportunity to experience college, change their trajectory, and change the lives of their families.
We're confident that we can achieve our goals for students because we have robust systems of support in place.
Here on the screen, you'll see how multiple protected categories of students will be served along with all students.
Some of these are our one-to-one weekly reflection meetings, which is rare in most schools, college readiness course and plan, application and AP test fee support as required by law, college course fee support, and academic counseling services.
Each of these supports are outlined in our original petition as written as well in our budget.
Lastly, we have been and will continue to advertise these systems to our target population of students so they realize that this is an option for them in their community.
After successfully launching a much larger school with the College Prep Pathway, I know it will be important that our elementary students will be college focused from a very young age.
The College Prep Pathway that I launched at my last high school consisted of 300 students who were within the general population of about 1,500 students.
These were students who were students, mostly students of color, mostly low income, mostly C average students who we challenged and placed into AP courses with supports.
We experienced success.
Our first graduating class of 280 students, we had a 96% graduation rate, and approximately 60% were accepted to a four-year college and university, mostly low-income, mostly students of color.
Unlike other large comprehensive high schools, we will only have 35 graduates per year, which will allow us to give individual attention to those students and families who need more help and guidance.
Additionally, our first graduating class will be in the year 2025, so seven years from now.
We're essentially an elementary school that will grow very slowly into the high school portion of our model.
Much longer runway with students we think will get us there, and also more time to make adjustments to their needs.
Here are other questions that we've provided responses to that were great questions from the ACCS Commission and the CDE staff.
One that I would like to focus on very briefly is the courses offered.
There was a question of sample courses listed versus courses that we will actually offer at the high school levels, which begins approximately four years from now with 35 students in ninth grade.
As we get closer to the launching of our high school portion of our model, and as we know the needs of our children, we are serving better.
and better, we will have developed a full complement of courses in our course catalog.
This will include intervention courses, elective courses based on student need and interest.
In the handout provided to you, in that middle tab, we gave four different examples, samples of what a high school matriculation for different types of students, different students, different classifications would look like.
And we appreciate the clarifying questions.
And we did not include a sample schedule in the body of our petition.
So you have that there.
I'd also like to point out that after leading high schools for the past seven years, this is the norm when it comes to determining which courses you must offer your students based on need and interest.
Lastly, in closing, Promise Academy is essentially an innovative, research-based elementary school that will grow slowly into a world-class high school.
We aim to prepare students in San Jose, downtown San Jose in particular, our most vulnerable, low-income children of color, to attend college, be innovators, and social entrepreneurs who are prepared to change the world.
On behalf of the more than 300 parents in downtown San Jose who are supporting our school, I passionately ask you vote to approve Promise Academy.
And with your support, we'll be able to address a local need and accomplish our goal for our children.
Thank you.
Okay, thank you.
Now, 10 minutes for the opponents of the petition.
Good afternoon.
My name is Christelle Johnson.
I'm the Director for Charter Schools for the Santa Clara County Office of Education.
I'd like to provide you with a brief background that led to this decision.
On July 11, 2017, the Charter Schools Office of the Santa Clara County Office of Education received a petition for a district appeal charter school from the Promise Academy team.
Promise Academy sought approval to establish and operate a public charter school for grades TK through 12.
for one year of planning plus an additional five years serving students through June of 2023.
SCCOE complied with all applicable timeline requirements established by California Ed Code 47605B.
A public hearing was held on July 19, 2017.
SACOE charter staff analyzed the petition following California Ed Code and the board's guidelines regarding consideration of district appeal charters.
The analysis was based on the review of the petition supported by information gathered also in the capacity interview.
In reviewing a petition for approval of a charter on appeal from a district denial, Ed Code states that California
excuse me, that the County Board of Education shall grant a charter of the petition in the school under this part if it is satisfied that granting the charter is consistent with sound educational practice and further specifies that a charter petition may only be denied if the County Board makes written factual findings specific to the particular charter supporting one or more
of six reasons for denial of a charter.
Unsound educational program, petitioners are demonstrably unlikely to successfully implement the program, required number of signatures, affirmation of each of the conditions, reasonably comprehensive descriptions of the required elements, and a declaration that the charter school shall be exclusive public employer for employees of the charter school for purposes for educational employment relations.
On September 6, 2017, a decision hearing was held on promise and staff findings were presented to SEC BOE.
Staff found that the petition met requirements for required signatures, affirmations, and exclusive public employer.
Staff also found that the petitions demonstrated the capacity to successfully implement the program if the board allowed the following deficiencies to be corrected in the petition.
Staff concluded that the petition did not meet sound educational program with major elements including but not limited to graduation requirements, appropriate credentialing, and educational practices for English learners.
Staff also indicated that the petition had additional gaps in fulfilling the recently comprehensive descriptions which require refining and editing
if the board were to approve the petitioners.
Although the staff found that the petition offered a program which may benefit students in TK-12 grade school educational system, several deficiencies and issues including the educational program, employee qualifications, the support and outreach for the ethnic and racial balance of the school, and other concerns detailed in the full staff analysis.
The SCCOE board members took a motion on the decision hearing for promise which resulted in a three to three split vote and there was one member absent that evening.
Based on the split motion the SCCOE board could not take action on this petition.
This concludes the SCCOE summary for Promise Academy.
Good afternoon, Stephen McMahon, I'm the Deputy Superintendent for the San Identified School District.
I want to apologize in advance, some of this is going to be repetitive, but as a former mathematics teacher, you've got to teach period six with as much enthusiasm as you did period five.
And when the audience changes, you've got to give that material like you're giving it the first time, right?
So I know behind me, not everyone was here for presentation number one.
I appreciate your patience hearing some of those things.
We're going to do this in three parts, talk a little bit about who Santa's Unified is, give you some specific examples regarding this petition, and what we think should happen going forward.
If you were to describe Santa's Unified in two words, it would be equity and quality.
I don't know how many of you know this, but Santa's Unified was the first school district to adopt an A to G graduation system.
But we didn't adopt it blind to the diverse needs of learners.
There was always backup, supports, and other pathways to make sure they could get their high school diploma.
But we were the leaders in going A to G, and it's been an incredible success over the years.
Quality.
Our teacher evaluation system is recognized throughout the nation.
You can Google it right now and find a lot of positive articles.
It's easy to say a teacher's great.
We don't accept that anymore.
If there's no evidence to support the claim, the claim is irrelevant.
This teacher needs to be dismissed.
I really appreciate Board Member Williams citing data.
We love evidence.
Keep searching for that data.
You'll find that Santa's Unified exceeds the statewide averages in almost every category including the subgroups and is competitive in a very not as diverse county as we are as a school district.
So we're proud of our data and we're proud of the growth we have to achieve.
Throughout this presentation and discussion of this petition, I hope you balance claims and evidence.
It's easy to say something.
It's much harder to validate it.
And I know your work is challenging to validate claims, but please hold us accountable the entire time.
County of Santa Clara, 32 LEAs.
We are a charter leader, as evidenced by the 84 approvals.
It is rare that a charter petition comes before this body from Santa Clara County.
If it's coming here, there are reasons.
There is evidence for why it didn't pass the school district and the county office.
The city of San Jose is a subset of Santa Clara County.
There are 19 school districts within our city.
You heard earlier, not everyone, lots of references to San Jose.
Most of the times they were not San Jose Unified schools.
We take a lot of pride if it's a San Jose Unified issue and address it immediately because we expect quality.
We appreciate knowing the distinction between San Jose Unified and our other partners in Santa Clara County and the city of San Jose.
I hope you do the same because we are very proud of the work we do and very accountable for it.
If we've made a mistake, we want to know it's our school so we can fix it.
If it's not our school, we'd love to go to the neighboring district and give them some best practices.
There are 65 charter schools approved in our city.
Parents have a lot of choice and opportunity.
Within our school districts, 10 charter schools are open.
With your initial authorizer for five of them, two of them were approved on county appeals, and three of them were directly submitted to the county countywide.
We were the first charter authorizer in Santa Clara County, Downtown College Prep High School.
We authorized the first charter school in our county.
We opened our doors, we created them as a partner, they're still serving students, they've expanded to other districts, added middle school options.
We are open to high quality charters.
I had a photo of a bus driver in the earlier slide,
We are committed to choice for families.
We maintain an extensive transportation network so you can get through our banana and parents have options for all 41 schools.
We take a lot of pride in that.
I love hearing charter petitioners say they're going to serve all students and then looking for the evidence in the budget of transportation costs.
And when it's never there, I know.
High needs special ed kid, not going to that school.
Someone from far away, not going to that school.
If you don't pay for transportation, you're not open to every family.
Santa's Unified invests millions of dollars every school year to make sure our families have choice and can travel throughout our district to the schools they want to go to.
Let's talk about some other claims.
innovative partnership with the Tech Museum.
It's in the petition.
You can look right now on page 47 for this statement.
We call the Tech Museum.
There's no MOU.
There's no approved agreement.
There is nothing in writing to signify a formal partnership in existence.
But we have some evidence.
That's Tim Ritchie, CEO of the Tech.
That's Maria Evans, principal of our elementary school.
And that's First Lady Michelle Obama, receiving an award for the Tech Museum's excellent work in the sciences.
Why is our principal there?
Because we have a long-standing, real partnership with the Tech Museum of Innovation.
Maria Evans was invited by Tim Retchie to attend this ceremony and receive the award because of a long-lasting community partnership.
The partnership exists not only at Washington Elementary, but at Burnett Middle School and several other schools throughout Santa Clara County.
It is nothing new.
Parents already have the choice and the option to get a tech-supported school.
Unsound educational practice.
Local review, county review, state review all found the petition to be unsound.
Graduation requirements are a common theme.
You can look at a videotape at the Santa Clara County Office of Education public hearing.
The petitioner says, in response to a board member's question, why are these graduation requirements set this way?
The parents met.
They debated it.
It was the parent's choice.
These are the requirements the parents wanted.
We totally respect that.
Parents should be able to advocate for what they want.
But as public servants, sometimes we have an obligation to say no.
You can't advocate for a school that doesn't serve students with special needs.
You can't advocate for a school that only serves Caucasian students.
You can only advocate for schools that serve all students.
And graduation requirements that would not allow a long-term English language learner to graduate or a student with disabilities to graduate, that's not something the state board, the county office, or the school district could allow.
There's a clear process for this.
You've got the petition with the graduation requirements stated.
And at all three levels, they're found to be inappropriate.
You're reviewing the petition you got per your own implementing regulations and California Education Code.
If you change the graduation requirements this meeting, you should go back to the families who requested them.
They asked for them.
If they need to be different, the families have a right to have that discussion.
There are millions of people in California that count on you.
Sometime laws are unfriendly.
They're not fair to everybody, but they keep our society and our democracy strong.
This statement is from your own staff.
This is your team.
The petition is not consistent with sound educational practice.
It will likely not benefit students who attend, including students with disabilities.
Millions of citizens count on you to make sure schools like this do not open.
You have the findings.
You have the law behind you.
It's your responsibility to take the vote to protect the citizens of California that are not here today.
As I offered before, the entire team from Standards Unified is here.
Ask us for the evidence.
We're ready to provide it.
OK, we're now ready for public comment.
Would the following speakers please line up?
Claudia Rossi, Brian Wheatley, Melissa Urbane, Joanna Latz, Grace Ma, Joseph DeSalvo, Claire Crawford, Peter Ortiz, Brian Greenberg, Brett Bymaster, Stephanie Palmieri, Marla Marcello, Juan Torres, Yana Duran, Araceli Serrano, Silvia Valdez,
Valdovinos, Victoria Cuenca, Noe Guzman, Monica Vasquez, Vera Sloan, Robin Hyde, Adelita Gomez, Tanita Palminter, and Martha Herrera.
I'll call other names momentarily.
Please come forward.
Good afternoon.
My name is Claudia Rossi.
I was one of the trustees that voted to not approve this appeal.
And I'll share with you, I have a concern about this petition in particular.
I took a day off from work.
I ran for my children to get a ride.
I went through a lot to be here and this is what concerns me.
If you approve a school that does not have a strong support system for students who will be required to apply to four four-year colleges and also to take AP courses without the supports in place, that your vote today will mean that students will not get the support they need to fulfill this requirement to get their diploma.
What will you say to them then?
that you let the school proceed with this requirement for them to get their diploma when you didn't take the advice of local and county staff that urged us to not approve.
They are promising students something they cannot support for them to accomplish.
I urge you to please, please think of the children who will not get that high school diploma.
Thank you.
Hi there, once again.
I'm Melissa Urban.
I'm an ELD teacher and resident in San Jose Unified, downtown resident.
Once again, I bring you concerns about the lack of an ELD program in this position.
As you know, state and national best practices require dedicated ELD time, and that program is just not here.
In downtown, about more than 60% of our students are ELs, and that's just not serving the population that's in our community.
Promise doesn't support all students.
I urge you to reject this.
Thank you.
Hello I am Grace Ma on the Santa Clara County School Board and I am one of the three school board members who voted to approve the appeal for promise on a split vote.
I gave you all the academic performance areas of that downtown San Jose area and once again you can see that there is not a lot of choices for these families in the downtown area.
Specifically, this school will have high expectations and that is something that this downtown area really needs.
The high expectations, rigorous academics and a track record with someone as qualified as Dr. Johnson who has done turnarounds, who is experienced with English language learners, experienced with low SES areas.
The community and local groups have met in multiple action meetings of hundreds of families and parents to talk about and design the school.
They have put in countless hours designing a school that really fits their needs.
So from a local control area they are definitely in the right place.
Please approve.
President Kirst, Superintendent Torlakson, members of the State Board of Education.
I'm Joseph DeSalvo, a trustee on the County Board of Education, Santa Clara County Board of Education, and I voted for Promise Academy.
Sacramento, we have a problem.
Our children of color and low SES are hurting, and the village elders and leaders must find the solution sets to eliminate the racial achievement and expectation gap.
Today, not tomorrow.
I represent Santa's Unified School District on the County Board of Education.
I do believe in my heart San Jose Unified School District works tirelessly as a district to address the aforementioned problem.
Yet it is my considered belief that the achievement and expectation gap needs an all hands on deck practice with limited public dollars to meaningfully address the problem.
Board member Williams was right on target with the citation of the data ascribed to Latinos in San Jose Unified School District with the last petition.
The racial achievement and graduation gap is truly not a gap but a gulf.
It must end.
Promise Academy should be approved today to be a small puzzle piece to the solution set of the elimination of the gulf.
Thank you very much.
Hello again.
My name is Johanna Latz.
I'm a special education teacher in San Jose Unified School District.
I'm also a resident in the district.
There's a problem with Promise again for not addressing the needs of special education students.
Special education students don't necessarily graduate and go to a four-year college.
Some of them
that graduate need maybe a two-year college or they need a skills-based transition into skills for life.
Promise Academy does not address multiple or differently abilitied children that are graduating as they get older.
Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon again.
My name is Stephanie Palmieri-Furrias, and I'm the principal of Washington Elementary.
I'm not the one in the picture.
I took over after she retired.
I didn't get to go with Michelle Obama.
But we continue to have a longstanding partnership with the Tech Museum.
We are a tech academy.
We're in our third year of the partnership, in which we are building capacity in our teachers to provide our students
with the opportunities for engineering design challenges on a regular basis and also with basic coding skills.
We have an engineering club and we have a lot of, we do a lot of work with the Tech Museum.
I'd also like to speak a little bit about what I've seen happen when we get students who have come from charter schools that we're not able to provide the support needed for students with special needs.
In fact, oftentimes, and I know I'm not speaking directly of this charter, but what I've seen
is that I get a student and the parent comes to me and said, we were told that you will better be able to serve our student.
We have parents coming with letters already written, and it is complex to be able to provide a student with special needs, all of the services they need, and I am concerned about this petition because of that reason.
Thank you.
Hi, it's Claire Crawford with In the Public Interest once again.
And just a reminder of the numbers that I cited before, in our analysis, the State Board of Ed has approved 71% of the charters that have made it up here that have been denied at every local level.
And just to give a few examples of the schools that have not succeeded after SBE approval,
and some of the warning signs that I would really encourage you to look at today.
In the example of celerity, although the state board did revoke or deny the charters, or I'm sorry, approved charters with warning signs from LACO, identifying inadequate knowledge of the law as one of the problems with the petitions, they went ahead and approved them.
Now there's two schools that exist when the charters have had to be revoked.
for two other schools due to massive corruption, fraud, et cetera.
One of the ancillary effects of that was that the Walton Family Foundation asked for money back from the two existing scolarity schools based on what was happening in the rest of the network.
I just want to mention Synergy also because the board was given notification of all the problems that ended up happening and that school was also shut down.
My name is Adelita Gomez and I currently live in the downtown San Jose area.
I have two children ages four and nine.
My son currently attends a downtown San Jose Unified Elementary School and previously I had him in a charter school in the same area and I believe that Promise Academy is what is best for my children.
I'm neither pro-charter school nor pro-district school.
I'm pro-good schools and pro-family choice.
I'm looking for a better option to be available in the downtown area than is currently being offered by my local school district.
Promise is the option I choose for the family-like support system they offer that we're already experiencing the high expectations of AP courses or college courses and the help that they're going to provide to pay for those associated courses.
I hope that this board will continue working towards giving families like mine more school choices because promise is a choice I will make for both of my children.
This is your chance to help a lot of students that are gonna age out of this program if it's not approved right away since there's a limit on the grade level that's gonna be opened.
There's many families that will be affected if this is not approved soon so I hope you take that into consideration.
Thank you.
Would the following people please line up to speak?
Julie Shakin, Dean Elias, Ramon Lopez, Yolanda Bernal, Carol Montelongo, Molly Castillo, Eva Heredia, Heriberto Soto, Marlene Gomez, Ken Burt,
Conn Russo representing Mayor Sam Liccardo, Linda Alvarez, Jesse Rodriguez, Deva Say, Tech Lemarian, Liz Guillen, and Colin Miller.
Hello, my name is Tanita Palaman.
I am a first generation Thai-American from Edmond, Oklahoma, and a single parent of two kids, five and 10.
I went to an elementary school that used small group strategies like Promise Academy will be using.
I went to a high school that provided AP classes and paid for those who took the class.
That's what I'm looking for for my kids, but I don't have good options.
I work two jobs and can't even afford a room in a school district with high ratings.
My daughter, Natara, loves technology.
Once a more difficult curriculum, she's excited about the challenges that Promise Academy will offer her.
Promise Academy is a unique school that has a partnership with the Tech Museum.
My son, Irvin, loves to build, use technology, learned a little bit of coding recently, and loved it.
He does better in small group learning that Promise Academy won't offer.
There have been concerns about the graduation requirements are too high.
We know our kids can do it.
I do not want the standards lowered.
I want all our kids to be prepared for college.
We know what is best for our kids, and we would be able to decide.
We want Promise Academy.
We ask for your approval.
Are you translating for us?
Muy buenas tardes a cada uno de ustedes.
Yo soy Martha Herrera, madre de siete hijos y abuela de 18 nietos.
No puedo creer que tenga que estar aqu con ustedes peleando en el mismo sistema que pele en 1987.
Y aqu tengo la prueba.
I'm Martha Herrera, mother of seven and grandmother of 18.
I can't believe that I'm here with you fighting for the same system that I fought in 1987, and she has proof.
I want a better education for my children and the community, which is not occurring right now in downtown San Jose.
For me, for my children, in the district they were in, they told me that they wouldn't finish high school because of their special needs.
I personally enrolled each one of them in the university, and I told them,
For my seven children, the district told me that they would not finish high school because of their learning disabilities.
I personally helped every single one of them enroll in college and told them that from here on out, it was up to them to choose their own path.
Esto es creer y preparar a cada estudiante sin o con necesidades especiales.
Yo s que esto es lo que promete, lo de PROMIS va a proveer a la comunidad en San Jose.
This is what's called believing and preparing every child with or without a learning disability.
I know that this is what PROMIS is going to provide in the San Jose community.
And I support education for all children so they can raise to a higher level.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Brian Greenberg from the Silicon Schools Fund.
We cleared up the financial questions earlier.
I won't bother you with the exact same presentation.
In fact, I have prepared remarks, and I'm just planning on saying something sort of from the heart to you all.
In 2004, I came in front of the State Board as a petitioner.
I was attempting to open the first charter school in the city of Hayward, which had never had a charter before.
And I heard many of the same critiques as I've been hearing today for both of the previous petitions.
And the state board had the wisdom to give our charter organization a chance, and we went on to open Leadership Public Schools Hayward, which has since gone on to be one of the highest rated charter schools in the state of California, so much so that the district five years later on renewal said, we'd like to approve you now, and we repaired what had been a damaged relationship.
I'm hopeful that that same story can be said today.
I planned on talking to you about the quality of the petitioner.
I think you heard from his presentation his track record of success.
The reason why we invested in this particular charter and this organization has some of the most authentic and deep parent engagement I have ever seen in my work supporting charter schools.
And we have utter faith that this is demonstrably likely to succeed and to be somebody we would be proud to be associated with.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Julie Chekim.
I'm a refugee from Cambodia.
I learned that my seventh grade math class in California was at a lower level than the fourth grade math in my refugee camp.
My son, Adi, who is four years, wants to go to Promise Academy so he can go to the Tech Museum all the time.
He loves challenges, and I want a school that will challenge him.
Too many kids that drop out of school or join gangs and get into drugs are really smart kids that were bored and weren't engaged or challenged.
Our downtown schools with ratings threes and fours have been doing a disservice to our kids in our community for over 20 years.
We need that change now.
We want Promise Academy because it's a tech school that will prepare our students for college and compete for better jobs in Silicon Valley.
I hear concerns about high school graduation requirement.
I am not concerned because our parent groups have been working with Dr. Johnson to design this school since day one and we want to have high expectations for our kids.
We know that intent is to serve all kids and that school will accommodate students in various circumstances to graduate like refugee and English learner students alike.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, I'm Dean Elias.
I feel honored to meet with you and I'm privileged to represent the Promise Academy Board.
I have two points I want to make about the proposal.
First, it is simply a brilliant design to serve low-income and marginalized students in downtown San Jose.
It's based on Dr. Johnson's nationally acclaimed work on behalf of such students in Merced.
Second, it's intended to be a proof point
to demonstrate that we can educate all students in downtown San Jose successfully.
Critics have focused on specific features such as the graduation requirements or the graduation goals.
The specific complaints ignore the power of the overall design.
Please don't be distracted.
Please pay attention to the brilliance of the design of the school's design to serve low-income and marginalized students and approve the proposal.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Magdalena Castillo.
I have a five-year-old son, Cesar, and a 10-year-old nephew, Zion, who has special needs.
And I know that Promise Academy is made to serve my family.
I grew up in downtown San Jose, and I've lived there all my life.
I attended traditional public schools.
I graduated from high school.
I'm prepared for college, and it took me six years to get an AA degree.
due to time spent in remedial courses.
It's time for change.
High expectations is why I want Promise Academy for my son.
I want high expectations to be what he knows.
The fact is that two district schools in our area are in the orange on the state dashboard.
They are not setting kids like my son and my nephew up for success.
Through this whole process, I have heard that our kids can't meet the school's graduation requirements.
I don't believe that.
I know our kids can do it.
There is a huge demand for this school in our community.
We want Promise Academy in our downtown San Jose for our kids.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, my name is Yolanda Bernal-Somano, and I was born and raised in downtown San Jose.
I am a long-time downtown resident, first-generation college student, and the daughter of immigrants.
I now have two sons, and it makes me sad to see the schools in my neighborhood, some that I attended myself 25 years ago, are still failing.
Just to be clear, my three home schools, my three choices, are Title I schools, rated three or fours out of 10 on review websites, and orange on the state dashboard.
That's why I've been working hard to open Promise in my neighborhood.
Throughout our entire process, we've had a collaborative spirit with the district.
We've invited board members and district staff to research meeting, community action forums where over 100 families attended to demand action on the achievement gap that exists in our school downtown.
Some of us taken up on our offer and others have just simply stated, we cannot dictate to you what we want you to put in your petition.
To be clear, we're not looking for pre-approval.
We're open for open dialogue, communication, and a working relationship.
Throughout our approval process, the district has used unfair processes, and we've included two San Jose Mercury News articles that have been given to you in the handouts.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Ramon, father of one.
I was part of the downtown traditional public school system.
I never knew the importance of college.
I felt that I was just livestock, just another lumber.
As long as I graduate, that's all that mattered.
I'd like to support slash knowledge from my teachers and family.
Will the parents share Promise Academy's vision?
Promise's parent dedication will have brought me to their doorstep.
Promise demonstrates and emphasizes how important it is to place our children's future before anything and being constantly involved in our children's academic endeavors.
to ensure their success.
Every student has potential, but a strong support system is vital.
I promise the effort from our children, parents, teachers, hard work gives them better odds that if they're one of the 1,000 Latino high school district graduates who don't even have the option to apply to a four-year university, if they graduate at all.
I promise I would be satisfied and a confident parent of my sons and every student's higher educational achievements.
I want my son to be passionate about his education and strive for greatness with the tools to tackle rigorous academic challenges.
I believe Promise Academies can ensure that my son graduates and is prepared for college and ready for what life throws at him.
Thank you and please approve.
Buenas tardes, mi nombre es Eveleria y tengo dos hijas.
Y soy una latina que llegue a este pas casi 20 aos, pensando en mi sueo americano.
Pero sobrevivir en San Jose es cada da ms difcil.
He estado involucrada con PROMES ms de un ao y he estado en cada junta, en cada taller, en todo el proceso para poder hacer preguntas y recibir respuestas.
Yo quiero una escuela con PROMES en la cual seamos pocos como familia y nuestros hijos tengan tecnologa junto al Tex Museo de San Jose.
My name is Eva Heredia and I have two daughters.
I'm Latina and I came to this country 20 years ago thinking about my American dream, but surviving in San Jose, California every day is difficult.
I've been involved with Promise Academy for more than a year and attended every meeting and training to understand and be able to ask my questions.
I want schools like Promise in which we are few and like family, our children can have technology in conjunction with the San Jose Tech Museum.
Durante el proceso me sentido discriminada por las opciones para progresar como latinos aqu son mnimas.
En mi experiencia propia trabajo todo el da y queriendo superarme voy a la high school de adultos por las noches y es triste ver la clase llena de jvenes.
Sus estadsticas me ensean que hay dos posibilidades para mis hijas.
Ellas pueden tomar sus chances y ser una de mil graduadas ahorita sin ninguna probabilidad de ir a la universidad de cuatro aos en el distrito.
Mil cuatrocientos latinos seniors o pueden ser latinas graduadas y preparadas de parte de 35 al ao que se gradan en Promise.
During this process, I felt discriminated because the option to progress as a Latina are minimum.
In my own experience, I work all day to better myself and I attend adult high school at night.
It's sad to see the classes filled with young people.
Your statistics shows me that there are two possibilities for my daughter.
They can take their chances and be one of 1,000 students right now that are not graduating with the possibility to go to a university in a district of 1,400 Latino high school students.
Or they can be a Latina graduate and prepared as a part of a 35 a year that will graduate from Promise.
Hello, my name is Carol Montelongo.
I'm a founding parent leader with Promise Academy.
I was an ESL student that was not supported in the traditional public schools of San Jose.
When I think about the public schools in my neighborhood, I worry that they may not give my son the best chance to succeed as a low-income student of color.
I want an innovative school model for my son.
This process has allowed us parents to be the leaders in the school design process and in the political realm.
This is the way charters should be created through community.
There's a true partnership that Promise Academy has cultivated with families, and the demand for this school is big.
Over 300 families, we are already working as a team.
I already feel a strong, trusting relationship with Dr. Johnson, and I know that communication between the school and families is valued.
This type of engagement is what will push my child and all children to succeed and achieve Promise's graduation requirements.
These requirements symbolize our hopes and dreams for a better future.
PROMIS offers the support to achieve higher education, innovative model of 35 students in a grade that's unheard of.
That's how we will support all our students as a community.
Thank you.
Buenas tardes, board.
Mi nombre es Heriberto Soto.
Gracias por la oportunidad de hablar con ustedes.
Cuando yo vi que uno de mis hijos estaba atrasado acadmicamente, tuve que rpidamente buscar mejores opciones.
Si yo hubiera tenido, si yo no hubiera tenido la opcin a las escuelas rigurosas, entonces mis hijos no estaran en la universidad de cuatro aos el da de hoy.
En realidad, es que las escuelas rigurosas que estn probando, empujando y poniendo presin en los estudiantes latinos para alcanzar el sueo universitario lo estn logrando.
Hello, my name is Eriberto Soto.
When I saw one of my children was behind academically, I quickly had to find better options.
If I had not had the option to rigorous schools, then my children wouldn't be in four-year universities today.
We are living the reality that rigorous schools are testing, pushing, and putting pressure on Latino students to reach their university dream, and they are succeeding.
Queremos darles a nuestros hijos una preparacin que les permita vivir, trabajar en un mundo tecnolgico y moderno.
Escuelas como Promise Academy deben existir en nuestra comunidad.
Nuestros hijos tienen la capacidad mental
para poder recibir cualquier tipo de enseanza, pero ustedes la tienen que permitir.
Por favor, les pedimos que nos ayuden para salir adelante, que sean ustedes parte de la solucin a nuestros problemas.
We want to give our children the preparation that will allow them to live and work in the technological modern world.
Schools like Promise Academy should exist in our community.
Our children have the mental capacity to receive whatever type of teaching, but you have to allow it.
Please, we ask that you help us move forward and that you can be a part of the solution to our problems.
Thank you.
Si no hubiera la necesidad que tenemos en nuestra comunidad, no estaramos aqu.
Nosotros estamos buscando ms, no noms la high school.
Queremos ir ms adelante.
Tenemos sueos.
Gracias.
Hello, my name is Jesse Rodriguez.
I'm a parent in San Jose.
I believe that I am and we are my son in fourth grade is a charter success story.
He's doing trigonometry right now.
I never did trigonometry till I got in high school.
He's in fourth grade.
They were coding last year.
I believe the charter school system is good for our kids and our community.
Dr. Anthony has built a village that I want to be a part of because it takes a village to raise a child.
Parents can't do it by themselves, teachers can't do it by themselves, and the students definitely can't do it by themselves.
They need all of us, including y'all, to approve this school.
Thank you very much.
Ken Bird on behalf of the California Teachers Association.
One minute's not enough and I'd like an extension, but if I don't, I want to talk about the local control issue.
Because the comment you made, Board Member Ortiz-Lacombe, I think the problem with your analysis is, yes, you're here to hear appeals, but what is the standard of the appeal?
The local district and the county know the grounds.
They know the witness credibility.
They've reviewed the matter.
They come in and say something is red.
Then the department says it's blue.
And woo, you have a de novo hearing.
You start all over again.
That's not the way it ought to be done.
Like in a court of review that doesn't appeal, the trial court
ultimately knows and is closest to the fact, the credibility, the witness.
The point has been about local control and may have to be legislation, is that absent clear error, when San Jose Unified School District comes in and says it's red, and obviously you look at it and they could have reasonably interpreted it's red, you ought to say it's red.
That's up to your judgment.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Linda Albers, a parent of three boys, 12, 10, and 7, and a lifelong resident of San Jose.
I've experienced firsthand the flawed educational system that does not meet the needs of our community.
I'm a first-generation graduate of San Jose State University, and I have fought tooth and nail facing so much injustice and adversity striving for higher education.
It took me many, many years, more than I should have, to earn a bachelor's degree because I was not adequately prepared.
I, like all the parents here, want nothing more than our children to thrive in this community, and I don't want my children to go through what I went through for an education.
This school and its curriculum is exactly what will work for my children, and I will not lower the standards for receiving world-class education.
And I am making a well-educated decision in choosing Promise because it was designed to serve kids like mine.
It's a shame to see the injustice still present today in the district's process for approving this school.
My boys have dreams of becoming engineers and please don't shatter their dreams of becoming the innovators of tomorrow.
Please vote yes for Promise.
Hi.
Hello.
Hi, my name is Deva Saitak Lamariam.
I grew up in San Jose and attended San Jose Unified.
My experience as a student of color was not very good.
I feel that I was marginalized and did not get much support from the regular public school to succeed.
I currently have two kids in elementary school attending San Jose Unified.
I want to give my kids a better opportunity than I had by sending them to a high-performing school in my area.
Currently, San Jose School District, San Jose Unified School District, two-third of Latino and over half, again, half of African-American graduates from high school do not qualify to attend a four-year college.
I will not allow my kids to be part of this statistic.
Promise Academy has a great small group instructional model that I believe in.
From the beginning, I have been helping design Promise.
The school is here to help this undisturbed community.
We need more high performing options for our kids now.
We will not continue to wait again, generation after generation, for better schools.
This district has failed me.
I will not let it fail my kids.
Equality again.
Two-thirds of Latinos and over half African-Americans don't graduate to go to college.
Thank you.
of Approved Problems Academy.
Would the following four people please line up?
Patrick Bernhardt, Gemma Ables, Richard Hansberger, and Ona Keller.
Thank you.
Hello, my name is Marlene Martinez and I'm here supporting Promise Academy.
I have lived in San Jose for over 30 years and have seen it grow along with the cost of living.
My grandson goes to school in San Jose Unified and I'm very concerned.
My granddaughter is close to school age.
The two of them need a better opportunity to take the next step into higher education.
I have been incredibly frustrated with how San Jose Unified has acted in this process with Promise Academy.
San Jose Unified tried to prevent us from having a fair hearing by falsely disqualifying signatures we had gathered, even though we had over 300.
In the ACCS hearing last month, San Jose Unified publicly admitted that they refused to meet with charter petitioners after they submitted a petition or give them a chance to resolve any issues.
This is what happened with Dr. Johnson.
They have not shown any evidence in this process for actually wanting to work with us.
All we are asking is for the same opportunity that others have for high quality education for our families.
Please approve of this academy.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, President Kirsch and members of the board.
My name is Khan Russo.
I'm here on behalf of Mayor Sam Liccardo of the city of San Jose.
I'm his director of strategic partnerships and performance and direct his education strategy.
I would like to share highlights from a letter that mayor has sent you.
Dear President Kish and members of the board, I write to you in support of Promise Academy in San Jose Unified School District.
Considering the significant benefits that Promise Academy will bring to our students in downtown San Jose, I hope you will vote in favor in support of this charter.
I understand the difficulties of families struggling to survive financially.
Unfortunately, this financial burden most significantly impacts our children, their academic performance, and their future.
Downtown San Jose students have been failing behind academically for years, especially Latino students.
Currently, only 35%, so this is 65%
percent of kids graduate from downtown San Jose schools eligible for college.
Sixty-five do not.
This is an urgent issue, particularly in Silicon Valley, where we have a responsibility to prepare the next generation of entrepreneurs.
And I just want to emphasize, choosing one is not about not choosing the other.
We have such a high demand for tech-oriented schools in Silicon Valley that the more, the merrier.
Good afternoon, Liz Guillen with Public Advocates.
We oppose the appeal and support the department's recommendation.
We believe that the graduation requirements place impermissible conditions on a high school diploma.
These are high stakes requirements and they could have discriminatory impact on students, low performing students who are likely to be students of color, English learners, homeless and foster youth, students with disabilities and immigrant students.
Your job is to pay attention to the petition and the charter, what's written, not what's being said to people in this room so that you can be sure that you're protecting the rights of people who are not in this room.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
Colin Miller with the California Charter Schools Association.
I've been doing this work for a long time, and I haven't, don't always come across groups that have the passion, the experience, knowledge, and the clarity of mission that this organization and their leadership has.
I speak from the heart on that point.
It is, with all the excellent schools that we have in the state, the promise of this school is exceptional.
So I would just leave you with that.
I think I would look forward to the day that we're having a real conversation about having too many excellent schools in our state.
Maybe this school will help us get on that path.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, Patrick Bernhardt, President of the Santa Zeta Teachers Association.
There is much among the Promise founding community that is laudable, but SJTA opposes Promise's petition, principally because of the graduation requirements.
We submit that they are actively discriminatory against students whose
and learning disabilities make it impossible for them to achieve, but perhaps more importantly, they are passively discriminatory against students who might believe themselves incapable of meeting those graduation requirements.
Students like Dr. Johnson in high school, who said that he only began to see himself as capable of meeting those requirements when
when an employee of the school changed his schedule and enrolled him in those AP courses.
By hanging a sign on the door that says, all students are going to graduate for AP classes, only students who believe themselves capable of that will enter the school.
And the response is that there's a long runway to help them achieve that goal.
But in downtown San Jose, with a 33% mobility rate, there isn't really a long runway.
Eight of the students in a class of 24 will be gone by the end of the year, and they'll be replaced by eight new students.
That's the demographics of our city.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Gemma Ables.
I'm the president of the Morgan Health Federation of Teachers and a vice president of both the South Bay Labor Council and the California Federation of Teachers.
But most importantly, I'm a longtime resident of San Jose.
Promise Academy is brought to you by parents, but really it's brought to you by Innovate Public Schools.
Innovate has helped charter schools gain a market share in Santa Clara County.
Framing charters in this model, a business model, helps companies like Innovate provide a common ground when they look for corporate funders.
In this model, your staff and the other staff's analysis of a petition is a risk management analysis.
In this case, the staff on all levels, which has the expertise in all areas of school academics and operations, has determined that the risk is high.
Some board members, including several at the county board level, are willing to take a risk on some charter schools, even when their own staff find a petition deficient.
They do this as part of a business model saying the school will close if parents are not satisfied.
They're willing to risk not just operations of a school, but a disruption in the education of students at that school.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, members of the board.
My name is Richard Hansberger.
I'm a partner with the law firm Hansberger & Kline, and we're proud to represent Promise Public Schools.
I'm here to talk to you today and just kind of deal with the elephant in the room because you've heard some very interesting allegations that somehow this school is going to either be actively or passively discriminatory against students with special needs or 504 plans or EL students.
In as much as these graduation requirements present an insurmountable obstacle, nothing could be further from the truth.
This team in its capacity, who I have come to know over the past two years, is dedicated to serving children of all sizes, shapes, and varieties.
There is no intent to discriminate against kids or deny them alternative graduation requirements.
And I'd urge you to see beyond that and understand that this school and its founder and its entire team is dedicated to that principle.
Finally, I would just urge you to look behind me at the community support that's so clearly evident in this room and the capacity of these leaders.
And that kind of explains, I think, why there was a one vote denial at the district level and a split vote at the county.
There's a lot of promise here, and no pun intended.
I urge you to see it.
Thank you.
Ona Keller, California Teachers Association.
I'd like to address the petitioner's plan for high school education.
They're going to be providing in their petition supposedly a large number of different classes.
But given the small number of students and the limited staffing plan, the school would need to recruit multiple teachers who also have multiple single subject credentials in order to offer the plan that they want to offer.
Given the teaching shortage that we're having right now, especially in science and math, I don't see how they're going to be able to recruit those teachers, especially since they're also not offering STRS.
The other issue is around discrimination.
We've talked about the graduation requirements, but we haven't talked about the discipline policies.
Promise says that a disruption of school activities or willful defiance can result in suspension or expulsion.
This has historically had a discriminatory impact on students of color, and it's why it's not permissible to expel students in non-charter schools for these actions.
The family handbook also allows discipline for such misbehavior as falling asleep in class or not having materials, even though these actions may not be attributable to misbehavior, but rather challenging circumstances such as homelessness.
They don't warrant discipline but our support.
Please deny this petition, thank you.
Eric Premack, Charter Schools Development Center.
We support the granting of this appeal.
This one as well, we again have a concern that the inappropriately high standards or different standards are being applied to this relative to what's required in law.
Again, we see the cash.
in advance requirement being applied.
We see other requirements about high school course graduation requirements being applied in kind of weird ways.
On the one hand, they get criticized for not having enough P.E.
On the other hand, they get criticized for setting too high of a bar with respect to A.P.
With respect to the P.E.
class, those laws do not apply to charter schools.
They're not subject to the same graduation requirements that govern traditional public schools and have some flexibility in that area.
And with respect to AP, while it is arguably excessive ambition, I think we've got bigger problems than that to worry about.
And we have worked with a number of schools that target at-risk populations and have very stiff AP requirements like these.
Thank you.
Okay, that concludes the public comment.
Therefore, I close the public hearing and we're ready for board discussion.
Board member Holliday.
Thank you.
First of all, once again, thanks to everyone who made the long trip here and and made all the effort to be here.
I'd first like to mention something to Deputy Superintendent McMahon.
We have this board has listened to many district presentations over the years.
And yours is about the best I've ever heard.
It was detailed and full and heartfelt.
And I thank you for your comments, even though just a few moments ago, you probably didn't agree with my vote very much.
I do want you to understand.
I think it's worth taking a moment to speak to the district and county and say that
Despite some of the things that are said in this room that seem to be negative or hurtful toward the district or the county or to a charter, this board, I know, and myself in particular, have the highest respect for the work that your district is doing, the highest respect for the effort that you're making, your teachers are making.
And I know that your heart is always in the right place.
And I'm grateful that you do the work you do.
Okay, on that I'd like to ask the first question which is we've heard a lot about San Jose and I've seen some data about San Jose Unified compared to the charter schools that are there.
So I'd like to ask if the curriculum people could present some of that so that we could
In San Jose Unified.
Yeah, I think we can talk about single comparisons, but maybe we could get a broader picture of how they do perform.
Thank you.
Again, I'm Jackie Zell, Associate Superintendent.
This is Emily McGinnis, Director of Technology Data Services.
In San Jose, Emily will give you some very specific comparable data that is all publicly reported, but in San Jose Unified, I do want to point out we've had an AP push
initiative in our district for about five years now.
We are district-wide at 55% of every subgroup taking at least one AP or IB course.
We pay for every single course for every single student except for $5 and we pay for the SAT and the PSAT for every single student.
So we have very, as Deputy Superintendent McMahon said earlier, we're the first district in the state of California to go ADG graduation rates.
Our graduation rates are very high.
Overall graduation rates are very high, including our Latino graduation rate.
There's still a gap, but it's closed considerably.
Our ADG rates have been going up over the last four years in all subgroups, especially our Latino girls.
So we have been making great strides in this area.
I'll let Emily go ahead and talk about some
data.
Good afternoon my name is Emily McGinnis and as Jackie Zeller pointed out I am the director of technology and data services for San Jose Unified.
I'm also a product of San Jose Unified's downtown schools.
My children this fall will attend San Jose Unified downtown schools.
I am very committed to the work of San Jose Unified.
As we heard the conversation around data today, I wanted to take a moment and share just a few points that I think are relevant to this conversation.
When we look at performance within San Jose Unified on the Smarter Balanced Summative Assessments, we do see that San Jose Unified in 2017 did in fact outscore the state in both mathematics and English language arts.
Interestingly, when we look at the performance of our district authorized charters, we see a very different picture of performance.
I then took the time to look at the performance of the schools that we would expect the two applicants to draw from, the nine downtown elementary schools and the two middle schools.
And what we saw is that across the board, with very few exceptions, these schools actually outscore our authorized charters.
We recognize that we have a long way to go.
We recognize that educating students is hard work.
We recognize that educating students in the downtown setting in San Jose Unified is not easy by any means.
But one might expect, given all that we've heard today, that authorized charters already supporting these students might be outperforming the district with these student groups.
And they are not yet at this time.
And I urge you to consider that.
And I urge you to consider what you have heard today with regard to the work of San Jose Unified.
Thank you.
Any other board member questions?
Ortiz-Lacombe.
Go ahead.
Primeramente le quiero agradecer a los padres que han venido hoy.
Sabemos que vienen de San Jose, que tuvieron que viajar hacia ac.
Les agradecemos su inters en esta escuela.
I want to thank the parents who are here and of course everyone else, all the other stakeholders and the district folks.
My questions with this charter are not necessarily with the leadership.
I think that Dr. Johnson, you have a track record.
I'm impressed by your presentation.
I'm impressed by what I've read about you.
I think that having great ambitious goals for students and in particular students who have been historically marginalized is amazing.
The only thing more amazing is high outcomes, right?
And we have to have difficult conversations here.
None of us are sitting here with a rubber stamp ready to approve charter petitions.
That may be the perception, but that is not the case.
And you could roll the tape, because I always ask difficult questions of both sides.
When we talk about high expectations for our students, and a lot of the parents said, queremos una buena educacin, queremos una educacin para nuestros hijos que vayan a la universidad.
That is the goal.
We want our students to go to college, to be college and career ready.
That is the goal, I think, for everyone in this room.
But there is so much to consider when we establish those goals.
San Jose Unified, you were the first to establish the A through G curriculum or A through G requirement as your default curriculum, which was later modeled by LAUSD and several other districts.
And we see that even when you have very high expectations,
The devil's really in the implementation of that policy.
So it's great that you have high expectations for your students, but I do have questions about graduation goals versus graduation requirements.
I have questions about how we could execute those goals when you have an expected graduating class of 35 students.
who will be very diverse.
I know that you're hoping to grow your students, but that's just not reality.
When you run a charter school, sometimes you start at elementary and you're adding a year, a grade level of year, and then you lose students, and then you have to fill those gaps, and you start recruiting at different points in that spectrum.
And some of the students that you start recruiting in the later years may not be your homegrown students.
So you have to now look at,
school culture?
How do you immerse them in this culture?
How do you account for some of their academic underperformance?
How do you bring them up to speed?
And so I'm really concerned about that because having great goals and lofty expectations is amazing.
But how do we then build a support with a school of your size to really accommodate and meet the needs of all students who will come through your doors at any given point in that continuum of K-12?
So it would be great if we could get a little bit more clarification around your numbers.
We're not here to change the graduation requirement.
So explain a little bit about the grad goal versus a grad requirement.
And then also there was a note here about EL students and LTELs.
So if you could tell us how you work with your long-term ELs, your ELs, and students with disabilities.
Thank you.
Shut that down just so I can.
There's a lot, so.
Graduation goal versus graduation requirements, your size of the projected graduation class of 35, and how you really plan to have a tailored educational plan for each of your students, if you have 35 students, that is your graduating class.
And then English learners, students with disabilities, and nail tails, long term.
I mean, the real question is, how do we build support?
And I do see having 35 graduates per year as an advantage as opposed to a disadvantage.
When I was running large high schools, having
over 300 graduates a year, it's very difficult to give kids individualized support and to monitor their progress.
And I believe that systems of support are really important.
I've always worked in environments where we've had transient populations and also transient staffs, so teachers coming in and out.
And so to have a really, really structured model and an ingrained culture of how you're going to deliver high-quality instruction
is really, really important.
And when you have that, when you have the vast majority of your students and your teachers bringing on that critical mass or moving on and matriculating, then it's easier to absorb students who have specific needs or who are behind grade level as they come in because you have those supports in place.
Some of the things that make our school unique, as I mentioned in my presentation, is our one-to-one weekly reflection.
So, that one-to-one reflection where students sit down with a teacher and they go over their goals, they go over where they are, and they plan for the next week, that happens weekly.
Typically, the feedback cycle at a traditional school, and sometimes even at charter schools, is quarterly.
Sometimes you get a progress report in the middle, and that's too long to determine how you need to pivot.
for a child.
And so I think that's advantageous to a student who might be experiencing a transient life where they're moving in and out of schools is that we have our finger on the pulse of what that particular child needs.
When it comes to EL students,
So I mentioned I began my career as an English language development teacher.
I was a department chair of English language development.
And at the schools that I've served, at least a third of the student population has been or was EL at some part of their lives, their educational experience.
And I would say
First and foremost is a culture of inclusivity is is what you need I mean, you can't learn language without culture.
And so as you bring students in making sure that they feel welcome Second is an intense focus and we list out several strategies in our petition of how we're going to address the needs of English learners I can cite the page again in just a second.
I have it written down here, but but basically we want to have daily academic
or language goals for students.
And so they're not outside of a classroom, they're in the class.
And what I found is great instruction for EL students and other students who have disabilities and other learning specific learning needs is great for all students.
And so having a focus on academic vocabulary, having a focus on language acquisition goals.
Also, we have a content workshop portion of our school day where it's completely differentiated.
for every single student.
And so you might have a group of students doing carpet time here who are your assault level ones.
You might have a group of students over here doing carpet time who are on grade level.
And so in a personalized learning environment, you're actually more able to give students exactly what they need as opposed to in a traditional setting as students are floating through teaching to the middle of the class.
So that's the whole design of our school is to make sure that we're addressing the needs of EL students.
When it comes to long-term EL students, this is a tough one.
It's tough for any school principal to address when you have students who have maybe been labeled EL since they're in third grade and now they're in 10th grade.
And when they speak to you, it doesn't seem that they have any type of language acquisition need.
But you know about their CELP scores or the new ELPAC scores.
I'm sorry, I was a CELP trainer from our previous district.
Yeah, and so you see that they are, they have those needs.
And so typically they're placed in a structured emerging class in addition to their other courses they're taking if they're in high school.
And this is a bit different.
We have office hours where students can get one-to-one guided reading.
We have learning lab, learning studio, where students, when they're not in their core classes, we can assign them that learning studio to have them to develop their language skills.
Ultimately, we have differentiation and structures in place and systems in place for those students.
What I want to get at is the concern of the unintended consequence of raising the bar so high, unrealistically high, that we are now depriving a student who is a student that we initially wanted to serve from a high school diploma.
If your graduation requirements are, you know, must be accepted to, maybe you could dispel that if that's not the case, must take an X amount number of AP courses and college honors and apply to university, a four-year university,
If those, which I think are great, however, we know that others have attempted, and I don't know if you could point at a school with diverse student population that has been able to be successful with 100% of their students, but I'm concerned about those students who may not be able to meet that criteria.
And instead of raising the bar for them and holding high expectations, because I believe all students can learn, but I also believe that we need to give them the supports so that they could achieve and learn.
But there could be an unintended consequence that we are not graduating some students and it's the same students that we wanted to serve with this criteria to graduate.
So if you could speak about that a little bit more.
Is this the graduation requirement?
Was this your goal?
And you happen to put it on a piece of paper and everyone's like, what are you doing?
If I could go back in time.
and retitle the chart on page 82.
I really think we wouldn't be here right now.
And then also, it doesn't represent our intent.
Our intent has always been to offer additional pathways to a successful graduation for all students.
We don't make the connection explicitly, and definitely that's what I want to clarify right now, and we're willing to clarify in writing.
But if a student comes into our school, especially later in their high school years, within extenuating circumstances, that student has a different plan.
So, for example, a student who's on an IEP, that IEP dictates what courses are appropriate for them.
The IEP team does.
And in many cases, you make the decision in 10th or 11th grade, okay, this kid needs to be in more vocational courses with supports, but still as much as possible have them in mainstream courses.
If a kid has a
a mental or physical disability that doesn't qualify for an IEP and they're on a 504 plan, then again, that 504 plan is sensitive to what that dictates what the students need and what those graduation goals will become.
The same is true for a long-term EL or an English learner, a newcomer who comes to your school.
You do the best you can and you make sure that kid has a pathway to success.
So in my experience, I've had kids who come in in the 10th grade, they're brilliant, they just have a language acquisition barrier.
And so we were able to offer them an additional year, a fifth year, to make sure that they were prepared or find a transition into an adult program for them to make sure that they're able to
complete that way.
There are realities to being a high school principal that you have to deal with, and we have systems in place.
We didn't explicitly align those with the graduation goals, but definitely that was our intent.
Okay, other comments?
Board Member Williams is next.
I reviewed your petition, not in the way that a staff person would, but I looked at all the staff comments and went to the sections of the petition that the staff comments addressed.
And I thought, and tell me if I misunderstood this, but I thought in addition to 504, in addition to IEP, that for students, that I read that for students who are struggling in any way,
that they would get an individual learning plan.
And that those, just like IEPs, even though it's not required by law, the individual learning plan would supersede the general graduation requirements as needed.
Is that, did I read that correctly?
You did read that correctly, and I'm sorry I forgot to mention this.
But we also, in our tiers of intervention, at a basic level, we have student success teams that evaluate students who have extenuating circumstances.
Maybe a student gets to their 12th grade year, and they have a death in the family.
And they aren't able to fulfill all of those requirements that are above and beyond the California, what the CDE requires.
Then that student success team takes that into consideration.
I will say that, again, my track record has shown that this is not something that I would allow to happen if it comes to that for a student.
We want to make sure that every student has a successful pathway and at a base level that student success team covers anything else that's not in a protected category.
Well, I hadn't quite finished, so let her finish, then I'll finish.
Yes, go ahead.
I'm Amanda Gardner.
I am the VP of Schools at Innovate Public Schools, and I've been working with Dr. Johnson and our families on the school design of this program for well over a year now.
I, myself, was a principal of two, actually, high-performing schools, charter schools in Boston.
I was the school leader for about 10 years.
And the first school that I ran did serve a very diverse population.
About 90 percent of our students were on free and reduced lunch.
Over 25 percent of our students were on IEPs, including students with significant disabilities, intellectual impairments, that sort of thing.
And 100% of our graduating seniors have gone on to four-year colleges and universities.
And so I know that it's possible.
I actually have a graduate from my school in the audience today.
I think he's back there.
I'm very proud of that, to get to work with him these days.
But we know what's possible when we design a school from the ground up to meet the needs of all of our students.
Now, that doesn't mean that there's going to be some serious extenuating circumstances that we need to take into consideration.
But I think sometimes what gets lost in the conversation around these high expectations is that we need to lead with a mindset that the vast majority of our students have the potential to be successful in college and life, and that that's our default.
And the exceptions need to be made for the children who truly need exceptions.
And as Dr. Johnson, I think, just articulated quite well, Promise Academy is committed to making those alternative paths as needed.
As Superintendent McMahon mentioned in San Jose Unified, they have the same practice of making different pathways
as needed.
And just to supplement what Dr. Johnson said on pages 82 and 83 of our petition, it does articulate that if students come to the school grade level behind, how the school will work with them through these individual plans to support them.
Okay, just a couple more questions.
Uh, it's been raised as a concern that, uh, the graduation requirements, which by the way, uh, would be like nine years from now or something, right?
Seven years from now.
Uh, uh, but that, that the expectation of AP exams, SAT, uh, ACT, uh, or a college course that, uh, that you, that those are required and that,
I am going to ask you to confirm something for me.
The reviewers of the petition did not see clearly in the petition that those would be paid for by the school or that they were in the budget.
As I understand it, from my due diligence, they are in the budget.
They are in line items in the budget.
Given that the high school is quite a ways away, there is a buildup of funds that goes on between now and then to pay for all those.
And that you, of course, as a seasoned traditional school public principal, understand the law in California that the school pays for all required fees.
It's just that maybe you didn't either put it in the budget assumptions as clearly or put it in the petition itself.
I think maybe you thought that everyone would know that you knew.
That's definitely a weakness, the implicit understanding of some things that need to be made more explicit, and so I'm going to lean on an expert.
I'm Dina Koren from Ed Tech who helped Anthony design the budget.
And yes, all of those expenses, they are actually quite small when you look at the number of students, the number of courses, the expenses, the discounts that are provided to students who have high needs or are of low income background.
And I think that we've provided maybe the CDE staff or maybe you as the board some more sort of documentation around which budget categories they come from, how would those budget categories be broken down.
There are only so many budget categories that we have in the budget.
So things like instructional materials, curriculum, the curriculum budget, the assessment budget, there's a lot of money in those budgets and plenty of money to cover those.
In addition to that,
Anthony understands the concept of creating a reserve, having an operating income expectation every year.
So if for some reason the students take more classes or need more AP fee coverage than we expect, then we have an operating income and a reserve that would cover those things.
Thank you.
OK.
Board member Strauss.
I want to support some of my board member comments at first member holiday and thanking San Jose for their really thoughtful presentation and the commitment that they are ongoing been working for students.
But also thank your team and your presentation as a former high school principal of a large comprehensive high schools urban.
I totally understand the commitment you have.
and you clearly are translating that into clear practice.
And so I appreciate your commitment to students and for higher standards.
And so I just would support the practices.
It sounds to me like we have to do some modification to make clear your intent from what was actually written
and I'll let some of my colleagues address that.
I just wanna support the intent of the rigor of high standards of access to AP with support for students who can do it.
And again, I support students applying and getting access to four-year colleges, I think the idea.
Personally, depending on an acceptance is a problem because I expect the students in your program, they will get accepted, but I think our commitment is through K-12, not what higher ed does.
So I just wanted to formally support the specifics and the focus and the team that put this thoughtful presentation together.
I think your mission is right, and I think the board members have brought up various specifics that we do need to address, but just to support the mission and commitment.
All right, Board Member Holliday.
First of all, Board Member Sandoval, you haven't had a chance to talk on this topic.
Dr. Johnson?
I did.
No, just kidding.
I heard some references in the testimony to disciplinary practices.
If you could address that.
I heard a reference to consequences for falling asleep in class.
If you could just clarify the facts, please.
Yeah, I'm not sure who it was who presented that, but I do know that we have a restorative justice process in place, and that's outlined in our petition.
And so for any misbehaviors, any instances such as that, there's a process for understanding what's going on with a child.
If there is any type of conflict, to restore that relationship, get them to the services that they need.
So it's not, you know, enlisting that is that, okay, that's not a behavior that's acceptable,
but how we deal with it is through restorative justice.
At my previous school, we called it Return to Excellence, and so that was kind of our way of saying, yes, there was a mistake made, or there was something done that was contrary to our policies, but hey, let's walk you through it and get you back on track.
Suspension and expulsions are, I mean, they're the last, last resort, and that wouldn't, definitely wouldn't warrant that.
And we have restorative practices in place to make sure that doesn't happen.
Yes, you want to comment?
Thank you very much.
Very quickly, I thought I'd just comment very quickly.
Obviously, AB 1360 came into play after the petition was submitted, so a lot of our charters on appeal, and I have another state-approved charter that is in this situation where they're all kind of looking at their suspension and expulsion policies because of Assembly Bill 1360.
We've already adopted, through their board, a fully compliant policy that has already been vetted by numerous local districts and county councils.
So we are fully confident that the school, and if your staff would review that policy, they see that we comply with Ed Code 48900 and all the due process guarantees that are embedded therein.
So I just wanted to make sure you knew that.
Now Board Member Holliday, are you getting towards it?
Almost done, almost done.
It's okay.
The other thing I noticed in the plan, a weekly meeting, so one-on-one meetings, is that with students and academic counseling staff?
Yes, so each morning we have morning huddle and each teacher is responsible for 24 to 25 students.
And so throughout the week, there are teacher office hours where they'll be meeting with those students to go over their weekly goals.
In addition, each Friday, that grade level team comes together and they address the needs of, you know, they huddle and they talk about the meetings they've had with individual students, how to strategically group them and or dynamically group them.
and regroup them from week to week and so you know that weekly meeting is going to inform how we respond quickly to our students needs.
Okay board member Burr.
So I just wanted to build a little bit on what board member Strauss and Ortiz-Lingon said that while I agree I really commend you on the intent of your petition and certainly on the setting of very high expectations for children who have otherwise been underserved.
But what I'm a little bit concerned about, and you've admitted to this, that if you had it to do over, you might provide additional clarification.
On its face, I don't want it to present an impediment to students who otherwise feel like they couldn't be successful.
And I'll just say for me that, especially over the years, and people know about my commitment to charter schools since its inception, there's been growing evidence and concern about lack of service to special education students.
And creating any kind of impediment for a charter school to enroll special education students, whether it's real, which I do not believe it is here, or perceived, we can't support those kinds of charters, in my view.
We need to have a lot of clarification around graduation requirements versus graduation goals and some of those issues.
So I just wanted to make sure that I wanted to be on the record about that because I do think that presents a concern about being in a welcoming environment for every single student to attend.
And I agree with Member Burr.
I do think that it is on its face value right now.
The high school requirements could impede a number of deserving and appropriate students to be a part of this school.
I really do commend the high expectations.
I think it is, it appears to me that this is a team that is going to walk the talk.
They are going to maintain high expectations every day in every way for every child, and I think we, I hope that we can give them a chance to do that, but I am not
I'm not comfortable with the current graduation requirements as stated in this document without some alternative option, path, route for a child who, for one reason or another, cannot make that final cut.
So do you have a motion for us?
I have one, but we're finished.
Oh, OK.
Maybe we ought to get that on the floor now.
Go ahead.
Yes, I would definitely need to see clarification on the language of the requirement, but even if they were able to draft the language to make sure that these are our goals, by no means is this the expectation, you know, with, and I don't run charter schools, so I'm hoping that that side of the room can help.
with 35 students as your senior class and you know I'm guessing that there is a projection of how it funnels up right so you have your k-12 and what are the the the needs that you need to deliver a robust curriculum
to have the supports in place.
Is there something in this petition that describes that plan?
So how you will go K-12 and have a very comprehensive, robust curriculum, and can that be afforded with a number of students?
Thank you.
Yeah.
And to speak to that point just very briefly,
after middle school doesn't it in terms of all the complexities that high school brings, and I agree with you.
I think that there is work to be done to explain that, to understand that, and to make that happen the way it should.
Board Member Williams.
So I am going to make a motion, but before I do that I'm going to make a statement.
First of all, I want to clarify that the State Board of Education review of charters that come to us on appeal is a de novo review.
That was referred to earlier.
I think the comment by someone in the audience was that if the district says it's red and the county says it's red, then the State Board should say it's red.
And if that were the case, then why would we go through this process?
So the de novo review is that we totally respect the hard work it takes, both the political work and the analysis work and the budget of work and everything else that districts and county offices of Ed go through to reach their decisions.
And as you can tell by having one of the board members here wanting to deny it and two of them expressing that they wished it was approved, this is difficult work.
This is very, very difficult work.
But our work at the state board level is not to uphold or deny what the district or the county found.
That's not our job.
Our job is to do a de novo review, which means with fresh eyes.
So what we take into consideration, member Holliday and I as the liaisons, when we do so much due diligence on these, because we know you can't always guess right.
You can't always bet right one way or another.
So for example, we look at the CDE's analysis and see what we think about it.
We look at the, go attend the ACCS meetings so that we hear all of the public comment during that.
Then we review the CDE's analysis again if they've changed anything before it comes to the board.
We also call our state board liaison and ask for special phone calls to clarify our questions.
And then we come and do it all over again here.
So we do as much work as we're capable of doing to make sure we fully understand what the issues are.
And it is the regs and the law give us discretion to come to our own judgment as a state board about the value and merits of a petition.
i've done considerable due diligence to ensure that i understand all the aspects of this and it's my conclusion that the petition does contain a reasonably comprehensive district description of the educational program that the instructional model is sound and innovative and especially for the the students that are being targeted to to come to the school uh... that the petitioners are demonstrably likely to successfully implement this program with the founder board an advisory group that are experienced knowledgeable
and committed to doing all they can to ensure their target population that they seek to serve have the most success possible, that you are wanting to change the trajectory of their lives in the same way your life was changed by that 11th grade teacher that reached out to you.
Dr. Johnson.
So I do hear the concerns about the, not the high school instructional model, but about the lack of clarity around how students that aren't, as it turns out, might not be able to meet all of those requirements.
What are the paths for them?
What are the alternative paths to see that they either get a diploma with
a graduation with diploma or graduation with certificate and are encouraged to pursue other and supported to do other post-secondary options.
I, like I've heard from several of the board members, appreciate the fact that you didn't start out with low expectations.
that you started out with high expectations and a belief that these students can accomplish this.
And the woman sitting next to you from Boston, who has been in a school where she's seen this happen as well.
But the board is not comfortable with the lack of clarity around
the alternative paths, the multiple paths getting there, you make it clearer about how the ILP is like an IEP and a 504 and how that will dictate as you go through what options should be encouraged and are available for kids and what kinds of support the kids could have.
What I'm going to do is make this motion.
Member Holiday and I both support this petition.
And I move to approve Promise Academy as a grade TK to 8 school for a five-year term effective July 1st through 2018.
effective July 1st, 2018 through June 30th, 2018, upon fulfillment of the following, that the Promise Board will provide the CDE, whoops, Carolyn, can you pass that around?
I'm so sorry.
This is the exact language.
This is a path forward that will allow this charter school to come back to us for a material revision with all the clarifications that you're asking to add a high school.
So let me read this again.
I move to approve Promise Academy as a grade TK through eight school for a five-year term effective July 1st, 2018 through June 30th, 2008.
No, 2000.
23, upon fulfillment of the following, that the Promise Board will provide the CDE with a revised budget, with positive three-year ending fund balances, a revised petition that reflects the State Board as authorizer, and a fully executed facilities lease agreement by June 15, 2018.
So it would be an approval if the board approved for the TK to 8 to 8 portion of the school with the opportunity for you to come back at any time including later in 2018 with a revised description of the high school in the areas of concern that we've raised and ask for a material amendment.
Is there a second to that motion?
Board member Holliday second.
May I make a comment?
Yes.
I believe as I sat through the ACCS meeting and listened to the concerns that were expressed, the concerns were with the high school program, the concerns were with the high school graduation requirements.
When I reviewed the CDE, I know there were some other concerns that the department had, but largely I think they were the high school and graduation requirement concerns were the
key concerns and that's why I think that if this charter school is approved that giving them the time once again remembering that they will not have a ninth grader for three or four years depending on how you
you count it, giving them the time to fully respond to the types of concerns that have been expressed by the ACCS, the CDE, the county, the district and us.
Makes sense.
So, yes, I second.
Any further discussion by the board on this?
Board member Ortiz-Lacon.
Is this something that the school, the petitioners are interested in pursuing this?
I mean, we don't want to vote on it if they don't care to do this.
Yes, we definitely will accept this proposal and we'll work to live up to your expectations.
Any further discussion?
If not, all those in favor, raise your hands.
Oh, question.
Sorry.
It's more just technical.
So I guess another way of doing this would be to approve the charter, but then to hold off an opening the high school until such, until we get more information.
We have a motion on the floor and it sounds different.
Yeah, it is different.
So you're going to have to, if this one fails, you can close that one.
All those in favor of approving the motion, raise your hands.
Okay, it carries.
Thank you.
All right.
Thank you very much.
Okay.
Yes, we're going to move on to item 25.
Board members can take breaks if they want to.
This is the revocation of the Beacon Classical Academy.
Go ahead.
Okay.
Item 25 is an appeal from Beacon Classical Academy which had its charter revoked by the National School District on May 8th.
That's okay.
Yeah.
Go ahead.
I think.
Can we clear the room, please?
We're trying to do business.
Please clear the room as quickly as possible.
Two, three, four, five, six.
Nobody else can leave.
Okay, go ahead.
May I go ahead?
Yeah, go ahead.
Please clear the room as quickly as possible.
Okay.
Item 25 is an appeal from Beacon Classical Academy which had its charter revoked by the National School District on May 8th, 2017.
The action item before the Board is to determine whether to uphold the National School District revocation of Beacon Classical Academy if the State Board finds that the chartering authority decision was supported by substantial evidence.
Pursuant to Ed Code 47607F4, the State Board may reverse a revocation decision if it finds that the chartering authority's decision to revoke was not supported by substantial evidence.
In the alternative, the State Board may uphold a revocation if it finds the chartering authority's decision was supported by substantial evidence.
The CDE recommends that the State Board hold a public hearing to uphold the National School District revocation of Beacon Classical Academy based on substantial evidence.
Beacon has been closed as of June 30, 2017.
The Advisory Commission on Charter Schools considered the Beacon Classical Academy revocation appeal at its December 7, 2017 meeting.
As Member Holiday mentioned yesterday, due to a lack of quorum, there was no motion made and no recommendation moved to the State Board.
On May 8th, 2017, the National School District unanimously acted to revoke the charter of Beacon Classical Academy.
On June 7th, Beacon appealed to the San Diego County Office of Education.
On June 30th, 2017, the charter term ended and Beacon Classical closed.
On August 9th, the San Diego County Board of Education took action to uphold the revocation of Beacon Classical Academy's charter.
And on September 8th, Beacon Classical Academy submitted the revocation appeal to the California Department of Education.
Ed Code section 47607C1, A through D, allows a chartering authority to revoke a charter if the chartering authority finds, through a showing of substantial evidence, that a charter school did any of the following.
A, committed a martial violation of any of the conditions, standards, or procedures set forth in the charter.
B, they failed to meet or pursue any of the pupil outcomes identified in the charter.
C, they failed to meet government accounting principles or engaged in fiscal mismanagement, or D, violated any provision of law.
Ed Code section 47607C2 provides that the authority that granted the charter shall consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by the charter school as the most important factor in determining whether to revoke a charter.
Revocation actions must comply with specific procedural requirements pursuant to Ed Code 47607D, which requires the chartering authority to notify the charter school prior to revocation of any violation described above and give the school reasonable opportunity to remedy the violation unless the violation constitutes a severe and imminent threat to health or safety of the pupils.
The process of notification by National School District to BEACON has been detailed in the in the item.
CD staff is available for any questions that the board may have.
Okay, good.
We have a public hearing.
Could I have a clarifying question?
Oh, yes.
Thank you.
First of all, welcome, Lisa.
How's it going on day one here?
Item three.
All right.
Are we having fun?
Yes.
Welcome and thank you for your service.
ACCS.
Now there wasn't a quorum.
Yes.
So because there wasn't a quorum, my understanding was that there was there was no, there was an inability for a motion to be made.
Correct.
So that there was no then recommendation moved to the State Board.
That's correct.
Was there a vote?
Yes, there was a vote.
I'm sorry.
And do we have the numbers on the vote?
Let me, let me get those for you.
I don't have.
I think that'd be helpful.
I just wanted to make sure people understood that the ACCS heard it completely.
They understood the situation.
It was only because one member evidently had to leave suddenly.
And so, but they did take a vote.
And I think that vote is pretty telling as well.
So, yes, I apologize.
I will get that right back to you.
Thank you.
Okay, and we understand the criteria here are different for the revocation.
So could you comment on that, Lisa?
You know, we're
we've been approving charters, now we're talking about revoking one.
So the criteria for that are somewhat... Yes, the action that's before the board is to whether to uphold the revocation if you feel that, if the board feels there is substantial evidence.
So it's either to uphold or you can reverse that, reverse the revocation of the charter school.
if you do not feel that the chartering authority, and in this case would be the school district, did revoke the charter based on substantial evidence.
So those are the two actions before the board, either to uphold or to reverse.
So you're not hearing a petition for a charter school, just making a determination whether you felt the chartering authority had enough substantial evidence to revoke the charter.
And this is not one of our charters.
So we've also been, you know, we've revoked some of our own charters, but I'm not as familiar with this process.
And Judy, you may want to help on this too, but yes.
This is not, we're not reviewing a petition and we're not reviewing the merits of the school.
Instead, our charge is to look at what the revocation process was, make sure that it was followed correctly and that there was substantial evidence.
Judy, is that a reasonable explanation?
That's exactly right.
We're just looking at the evidence that National considered and whether determining whether or not they had substantial evidence to reach that decision.
If they did, then you uphold the revocation.
Okay, I think we're ready now to open the public hearing.
So each side will have 10 minutes to present.
First, we have additional information.
Just real quickly before I leave, the ACCS meeting, it was unanimously to uphold the revocation of the charter.
So it was four votes.
Four votes to uphold the revocation.
Yeah.
And zero no votes.
Correct.
There was only four members at that time.
OK, so now I'm ready for the people who are from the charter school who want to have us reverse the revocation.
You have 10 minutes to make your case.
So Amy, it's not showing up on our screen here, though.
It's not showing up on your screen.
Why doesn't this work?
Is it the same computer every time?
It's not a new computer.
I don't know why you can't make it work.
I think it's a good question.
Yeah, could we look into this, Glenn, and why this can't be?
Are they coming?
Patricia, are they coming?
This is ridiculous.
Yeah, that's it.
Okay, go ahead.
Please proceed.
What kind of presentation do you have?
Yeah, just advance your slideshow that way.
Good afternoon State Board members and Dr. Chan.
Thank you for this opportunity to present our appeal.
We are here as parents and staff representing the Beacon community.
And we're asking you to please listen to the facts with open hearts.
My name is Dr. Alma Van Nuys.
I am the executive director of Beacon Classical Academy National City.
Our team who is here will present a rebuttal of the CD findings.
Very important, if the findings are valid, then we believe that you have an obligation to uphold the revocation.
But if these findings have been refuted or remedied, then please acknowledge this.
Integrity is not about being right all the time.
It's about doing right.
And when one errs, makes a mistake, it's about making things right, no matter the cost.
Our team will be addressing the following concerns, findings, regarding substantial evidence that the violations were refuted or resolved.
procedural errors, misinformation, false assumptions, false assumptions, misinformation, old data, illegal data.
Findings A.
Although National directed Beacon to make comparisons between two different charters, Julian and Beacon charters, we believe are different and therefore unlawful for the following reasons.
Different authorizers, each charter can only be legally evaluated by its own approved petition.
Additionally, charters are different programs.
One was independent study and the other is site-based program.
Different demographics.
When we moved from being independent study with Julian to site-based with National City, 34% of those students rolled over to the new charter.
So those are different demographics.
Therefore, the only legitimate comparisons are
between the two years that Beacon was with National.
The first comparison that could be made was fall to fall, 2015 to 2016.
However, National did discount those results because they said there was a two-week delay in starting those assessments, which was due to Beacon being homeless.
The fall-to-fall data, including cohort data, revealed that students were on an upward trend towards charter target growth goals.
CCSA used our fall-to-fall map raw data to confirm that academic growth is within the range of new charters for the demographics that we serve.
All the data can be located in the following.
that were provided.
We're going to look at the latest results of CASP, which were provided.
I'm having trouble with this.
These bar graphs are taken off the CD website and put into charts to compare the two years.
So for ELA, these are students who met or exceeded standards, we have an increase, an 11%.
In math, we have a 4% increase.
And you can also see that these charts also show a decrease from students in the lower levels.
Looking at economically disadvantaged, again, we're going to see an increase.
Grades three through five, if the data is not presented, it's because it was not included.
But because we're able to access the data, we were able to pull the six through eight as well.
So you have a 7% increase and then you have an 11% increase, a 2.5 and a 6% increase.
Were the students moving towards the charter goals?
Yes, they were.
Math, Hispanic group, we have a 15% increase, a 4% increase.
ELL subgroup, a 12% increase and a 5% increase.
Now, National used this chart to show gaps, but the data is from another year.
It's from the previous year.
And it wasn't recent.
And it's not aligned to our petition.
Our petition says that 85% of our students will demonstrate at least one year of growth towards grade level proficiency.
And students who are below grade level will make at least half a year's growth.
So this is progressive.
It wasn't expected to happen the first year.
And I put together a little chart so you could see that.
If only 30% of the group was able to attain that, then we would expect to see a growth each year.
So let's take a look at that.
This is the most recent data at the end of the year, spring, spring to spring.
And what we see here is that the students at grade level, remember it's at grade level, who started the school year.
So we saw from 53 to 58, and we saw a 5% increase.
We saw 1.5 years, not the one year.
And then for below grade level, from 52 to 57, 5% increase.
And more than one half a year's growth.
At least we see a year and .3.
That is what we're seeing.
Map results.
We're looking at 52 to 74, a 22% increase with an average of 1.9 years growth.
And we're looking at below, students who began the year below, from 53% to 72% shows a 19% increase, an average of 1.6 years of growth, not the minimum half year.
English language learners, although they stayed at 30%, they did show a growth of 2.8 years.
And for below grade level, they went from 44% to 63%, 1.2%, a 19% increase.
Math, we went from 37 the first year to 89% of the students who started at grade level.
And they showed a growth of two years.
52% increase, 100% increase in years growth.
And below grade level from 58% to 72% average.
14% increase, 1.6 years.
So our students were moving towards the proficiency goals.
And you need to weigh the facts.
The facts are that our demographics are 68% Title I, 57% English language learners.
Average student entering Beacon is 1.6 years below grade level.
According to CCSA, you will recall that academic growth is within the range for new charters with the population that Beacon serves.
So consider the hardships that we went through.
I wish I could get into more detail with you about those.
No fault of Beacon.
The school was homeless, red-tagged on 11-4.
And the students did not return until February 13th, a total of 49 days.
During that time, students were taught in a gym, a library, the park.
But the students persevered.
and completed all their work and made academic progress.
Consider our LCAP results.
Attendance rates increased, suspensions decreased, parent involvement by 50%, English proficiency by 20%, achievement across all subgroups.
How about our financial accomplishments?
And note.
that we've had, according with our corporation, including the three years, no problems with our audits, successful audits.
We proved that we were not sectarian.
Repeatedly, this was one last situation that arose.
It's a shared facility with a church.
They use the facility in the evenings and the weekends.
They rent it out to other religious organizations.
They left two books.
They were placed on a bookcase that was in a resource room where our general students do not access.
And if RSP students are brought into that room, they are brought in and taken out and they're not allowed to touch anything else in the classroom.
So we proved again, we're not sectarian.
Time.
Thank you.
Okay, we now have 10 minutes for the people that want to support the CDE recommendation.
Good afternoon President Kirst and members of the State Board of Education.
My name is Maria Betancourt Castaneda and I am the new board president of the National School District Governing Board.
On behalf of the district I want to thank you for the opportunity to present the district position in this action to revoke the charter of Beacon Classical Academy National City.
I also want to thank the Advisory Commission on Charters for their thoughtful and thorough analysis of its issues and the members present on the December 9, 2017 hearing who voted unanimously in support of the recommendation to uphold the District's revocation of Beacon's Charter.
We take our board responsibilities very seriously and are committed to ensuring a sound public education for all students, including the charter school under our district's authorization.
This is why our governing board and cabinet are here today.
The district did not arrive to this decision to revoke Beacon's charter lightly.
As the authorizer of Beacon, we simply could not allow the extensive academic, fiscal, legal, and safety issues to continue without remedy.
Our district is supportive of charter schools and the innovative programs and services they offer to students and families.
in our community.
In fact, the district has a well-functioning charter by the name of Integrity Charter, which has been successfully operating under the district's authorization for the past 13 years.
We have asked our superintendent, Dr. Leangela Brady, to share with you a brief summary of our decision to revoke the charter of Beacon Classical Academy National City.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
It feels like evening, I'm sure, for all of you as well.
President Kirst and honorable members of the State Board of Education, and thank you to CDE staff for all of the extensive work.
I, too, have a PowerPoint that I sent up.
So I'm not sure how to.
Is it in the folder maybe?
Yes.
Thank you.
Sorry about that.
Yeah, we have it.
OK.
Is it playing like a typical slideshow?
No, we don't have it now.
It needs to be going to presentation mode.
Just hit that.
OK, I'll bring it over there.
There you go.
All right, great.
As I stand here before you, I ask that the state board please uphold the NSD decision to revoke Beacon Classical Academy.
As you heard and as you've read in the thousands of pages that we submitted and the two board members that were there at the commission to hear the facts and to review the documents, we did try to work over several years with BEACON and did do a lot of informal things to try to support them, including 125 page instructional audit where we went out to the school
We observed their classrooms, their lessons, we reviewed their documents, we had some face-to-face meetings, and gave about 35 to 40 recommendations of ways that they could get their school back on track.
However, when things didn't continue to continue without remedy,
We did move to more of a formal timeline.
Throughout the formal timeline, we extended timelines, we accepted late material, even though the law said we didn't have to consider those things.
We did end up at a place where we had no choice but to make a recommendation to our board to revoke, which was a unanimous decision by our board.
It was appealed to the county.
The county also made a unanimous vote to uphold the decision.
And again, as you heard today,
from board member Holliday that the decision at the commission was a unanimous vote of the members present.
While there were many factors that led to the decision to revoke, we did weigh academics as the most important factor.
When we looked at the state CASP scores in the fall, it was our first indication that something might be wrong.
We saw some significant decreases in those test scores, both in language arts and in math.
And as you can see, several grade levels had 0% of the students proficient or advanced.
Whether we look at the preceding year or not, still at the current year, there were 0% of students proficient or advanced.
So of course, we wanted to look carefully at the local measures to see if students were making growth over time.
When we did that, we got lots of charts that had very confusing data, and they appeared to be showing growth over time.
But what we were seeing when we were visiting didn't match what the charts were telling us.
When you look at the MAP data, which was the majority of the data that we received were from the MAP test, MAP data really varies only from five to 15 points within each grade level, yet the charts we got had ranges of 30 points.
We also saw kinder through eighth grade on the same chart, which really gives this impression of growth over time, as opposed to really breaking it down and seeing what we were looking at.
you see in a blue and red bar that it appears that they're growing over time, fall to spring.
But what it doesn't show you is that that line above it is the norm.
The expectation is going up and this chart needs to show us how students are doing in their growth toward the rising expectation.
So what we did is we, sorry I went the wrong way here.
We broke that down, and again, these charts that you see in here are illustrative of multiple charts that you saw in the administrative records.
So in this one, it's just one snapshot, but every grade level was broken down in language arts and math to see, is that current achievement getting closer to that expectation, that norm?
And we saw consistently over all of the charts in language arts and math that they were getting farther away from that expectation and that norm.
In addition, when we looked at some of the data, you saw this chart in Dr. Van Nise's presentation, we were looking at cohort data, the current kids in the current programs in the current school.
What was the projected growth?
The projected growth was illustrated by that little chart.
gold diamond.
But the actual growth, what the students achieved, is represented by that purple bar.
And you can see the students are falling short in every grade level.
Now, you heard Dr. Van Nuys say, this was a different year.
This was fall to spring the previous year, because at the time we were considering revocation, we didn't have the spring data.
However, every chart that we had was included in the administrative record.
And this is the same type of data that we saw.
Again, it's illustrative for the presentation.
When we zoom in on that chart, we look at what's called the conditional growth index.
This says if an average student makes a year's growth in a year's time, that number is going to be zero.
If a student is catching up and making more growth than anticipated, that number will be positive.
But if a student is making less than a year's growth in a year's time, that number is going to be negative.
And you can see across the board, those numbers were negative.
That was alarming to us because students are not catching up.
In fact, they're falling further behind.
In the fall, we heard about the English learner data.
This was also concerning to us.
Only 2% of the English learners at the school were proficient or advanced in English language arts and 4% in math.
When we went to the school, we found they didn't have a curriculum, although in their charter, they said that they did.
When we went into classrooms, we saw, even in April, when we were invited, April 26th, right before revocation,
They had a classroom that said, what is ELD?
Written on their daily schedule.
And several of the daily schedules had no ELD at all.
So again, there were findings in all four areas, but academics was our main reason for pushing for revocation.
There were also material violations of the charter, fiscal mismanagement, violations of law, and you heard safety concerns as well.
And for these reasons, we ask that you uphold the National School District Board's decision to revoke the charter for Beacon Classical Academy.
Good afternoon.
My name is Kristen Armitas and I am a business advisory consultant for the San Diego County Office of Education.
We received the petition on June 7th from Beacon Classical Academy National City and we reviewed that petition as well as the documents provided by the National School District in the same fashion that's presented to you today under Education Code Section 47607.
The San Diego County Office of Education was tasked with making sure that the findings made by the National School District were supported by substantial evidence and that academic growth was considered as the most important factor in that revocation.
The San Diego County Office of Education staff report found that the National School District followed the correct procedure in issuing a notice of violation and provided reasonable time to cure.
The National School District had substantial evidence to support the revocation, and the National School District considered the pupil academic achievement for all pupil groups served in determining whether to revoke the charter.
And so on August 9th, 2017, the San Diego County Board of Education unanimously voted to uphold National School District's decision to revoke Beacon Classical Academy National City.
And so with that, the California... Yeah, I think your 10 minutes is up.
We can ask you back in public comment.
So our board member questions, I would say also.
So you will have to stop at that.
And now we'll take the public comment on the item.
Would the following people please line up?
LeAngela Brady, Maria Betancourt-Castaneda, Maria Dalla, Barbara Avelos, Alma...
Sarmiento, Chris Carson, PJ Whitney, Kristen Armitage, Gretchen Shipley, Alma Van Nise, Elsa Flores, Tamara Peterson, Kathy Polley, Ruth Prado, Christine Kallenberg, Lorena Olson, and Janelle Rooley.
Thank you.
Please come forward.
Good afternoon.
My name is Barbara Avalos, board member of the National School District.
I would also like to acknowledge and express appreciation for the support of Assemblywoman Lorena Gonzalez-Fletcher, the recommendation by the staff of the Advisory Commission on Charter Schools that the revocation of Beacon be upheld.
And the unanimous vote of the ACC members present their recommend that the revocation of the Beacon Charter be upheld.
Without a quorum, that recommendation was unable to move forward to you today.
Thank you.
Hi, my name is Chris Carson.
I'm the assistant superintendent of business services with the National School District.
NSD feels this is best summarized by the proposed recommendation by CDE staff to the ACCS.
NSD action to revoke the BCA charter was supported by specific factual findings of violations of law, fiscal mismanagement, failure to meet generally accepted accounting principles, and material violations
of the conditions, standards, or procedures set forth in the charter.
Further, the CDE finds that NSD did consider increases in pupil academic achievement for all groups of pupils served by BCA as the most important factor in determining whether to revoke BCA.
The CDE finds the findings of fact were supported by substantial evidence and that NSD did provide due process to BCA prior to revoking the charter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon my name is Paula Jameson Whitney and I am the Assistant Superintendent for Educational Services for National School District.
I would like to state that the district weighed academics as the most important factor as we move forward in our process of revocation of the charter.
As outlined in the district's presentation earlier the scores from the 15-16 CASP results were alarmingly low.
failing to meet Beacon's stated growth targets.
Further I would add that the district's instructional audit revealed a lack of curriculum, lesson plans and supports for English learners and even after our instructional audit
Beacon did go ahead and contact us about what types of supports to put in place for English learners, yet when we did our visit in the spring, they had still not provided those supports.
In addition, so with the English learner, lack of English learners, oh, wow, that was fast.
Thank you.
Thanks so much for coming.
Good afternoon I am Alma Sarmiento.
I am a member of the National School District Governing Board for 25 years now and the district worked with Beacon for about a year and a half trying to correct the violations of its charter.
During this process I was most concerned about the lack of curriculum and progress for our English language learner students.
It wasn't until midway through the past year that Beacon made efforts to acquire ELD curriculum.
Dr. Van Nuys told our board in February that their board had adopted curriculum, yet when some of our board members participated in an invited walkthrough months later, they were just then introducing ELD, or in some classrooms, ELD wasn't included in the daily agenda at all.
We want all students to have a sound educational opportunity and unfortunately Beacon failed to operate according to its charter and meet the needs of their students.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Maria Dalla, and I'm a member of the National School District Governing Board.
Today, I'd like to read a letter from Assemblywoman Lorena Gonzalez Fletcher in support of National School District.
President Kurz and board members, I am writing to support the California Department of Education's recommendation to uphold the revocation of Beacon Classical Academy by the National School District.
along with the Board of Education for the San Diego County Office of Education, and the members present during the last meeting of Advisory Committee for Charter Schools.
I strongly support this decision.
As the Assemblywoman representing the National School District and a mother of school-age children, I am a strong supporter of public schools.
As such, I work closely with my local school boards to hold all schools to high standards and ensure opportunity and success for all students.
To maintain accountability, a school board must provide effective oversight of charters within their jurisdiction.
Our local schools must be trusted to encourage the same results from charters that they expect from their neighborhood schools.
Unfortunately, Beacon Classical Academy has failed to provide our South County students, especially our English learners,
with a quality education, engaged in fiscal management, committed materials violated by their charters, and violated provisions of law.
For these reasons, I ask that you vote unanimously to uphold the revocation of Beacon Classical Academy by National School District as recommended by the California Department of Education.
Sincerely, Lorena Gonzalez.
Thank you so much.
We have a copy of that as well.
Thank you.
Good afternoon.
My name is Gretchen Shipley.
I'm legal counsel for National School District.
And we understand that charter revocation is a very emotionally charged issue.
But I just want to take this opportunity to reiterate what you talked about at the outset, which is the legal standard here before you today.
It's unlike the charter petitions we've heard earlier today, de novo review.
The standard is at the time of revocation, did the district have substantial evidence to support its findings?
And looking at all the information presented today and in the administrative record, it's clear that there was substantial evidence.
And on behalf of the district, the board, the cabinet who are here today, I just ask that you all, we respectfully request that you uphold the district's action to revoke the charter.
And we thank you for your careful attention to this matter.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, esteemed board members.
My name is Elsa Flores, and I'm a staff member at BEACON.
According to the NYU Measure U Force, when a disaster or crisis occurs, requirements are suspended.
BEACON was without a facility and in crisis.
NSD ignored.
the major force clause and immediately began three audits.
MOU finance and instructions.
One, Beacon was unable to access their files from the building.
Two, NSD declined to the dialogue to clear up my misunderstandings.
Three, consequently, NSD issued an NOV on December 15th.
Four, although BEACON could not access the files, BEACON refuted, remedied, or proposed to remedy every allegation by NOV February 7th in the deadline.
I have many examples of, they wanted to over, to turn in all the information, but we're very, we're in a very tight crisis and the examples are right there.
Please do review it and reconsider.
Thank you.
Hi, good afternoon.
My name is Tamara Peterson.
Two of my three children attended Beacon Classical Academy.
I wanted to use my time to address items B1 and D3 regarding the Department of Industrial Licensed Contractor Information with information provided by Dr. Van Nuys.
Labor Code Section 1720 required the use of DIR contractors when work is paid for by a political subdivision.
Section 1721 of the Labor Code defines a political subdivision to include any public agency of the State.
However, a charter school is a non-profit benefit corporation as defined by the California Education Code, section 47604.
Section 47610 is understood to allow charters the use of non-DIR contractors to perform small construction projects.
BEACON provided evidence of valid handyman certification as well as qualified work experience for the three contractors who provided those services.
Beacon clarified its compliance with the labor code and proposed to hire not to hire DIR contractors moving forward.
Therefore, those items were refuted and remedied.
I'd also like to just say as a parent and as a spouse of one of the teachers, the first classroom review that they did that the district did was in the gym.
I believe the students first day outside of their classroom environment.
Thank you very much.
Greetings to all board members and distinguished panel.
My name is Ruth Prado, parent advocate for Beacon Classical Academy.
I will address finances.
The school provided their financial ledgers and bank statements that contained all the transactions and check details.
According to CSMC, Beacon's back office updates to the SAGE reports
weren't possible to change.
And all the details were uploaded prematurely.
We can address more later with questions.
Alleged missing checks were fully accounted for through voided and canceled check copies.
Beacon explained that checks were written in three sources, payroll, CSMC, and
the school office.
That's why there are three different numbering systems.
Regarding contractors and tax benefit issues, after talking to six different entities, the tax benefits were reimbursed.
Five, conflict of interest payments, reimbursements to Beacon were fully paid off.
I urge you to reverse the revocation.
These are rectifiable measures.
No fiscal management.
We weren't hiding anything.
Unsuccessful dialogue with NSD also.
That's why we're here.
We welcome your more questions.
Thank you.
Hello, esteemed board members.
My name is Catherine Polly, a teacher at Beacon.
I will address item B2.
There has never been a lack of grade level curriculum at Beacon.
Grades K through 2 used a spelling, writing, reading program based on Orton Gillum phonics supplemented with standard based readers.
Grades three through eight used grade-level literature books, which are aligned with Common Core and classical education, as well as a supplemental spelling using Greek and Latin roots.
Math program used Eureka and Math in Focus, which are both standards-based and Common Core aligned.
National stated that Beacon's ELD program was not Common Core aligned.
and recommend EL Achieve.
Beacon wanted to immediately implement this program in November 2016, but was denied the use of the district trainer.
Once again, putting one more obstacle for Beacon's success.
Please reverse revocation.
Good afternoon.
My name is Chris Kallaberg.
I'm a teacher at Beacon.
I would like to speak about refuting the findings of B-5, the Brown Act violations.
The number of members were corrected after two resigned and one member died.
The bylaws allowed for a temporary lapse.
According to the bylaws, no staff or parents could be on the board due to possible conflicts of interest.
This made it harder to find candidates.
Beacon did their due diligence in soliciting new members and gave national proof of their searches through text, emails, agenda items that were listed in candidate information reviews.
Those were on the minutes in 119.17.
Beacon did not conduct any voting on 11.16.
They finished a discussion after a board member left early, but stopped when a quorum was missing, when there was not a quorum.
And 117.
Beacon meeting minutes noted five members and at 4.17 a vote was retaken when an item was listed as information that voted on.
We would like you to reverse this revocation because we have refuted the issues the Nationalists present.
Esteemed board members, my name is Lorena Olsen.
I am a Beacon parent and grandparent.
Rebuttal of CDE determinations of finding D1 FERPA.
Students who qualified for reclassification as English proficient were listed on a board agenda posted on the website.
English proficient students were also celebrated with certificates and gift cards at an assembly.
The other finding occurred at an NSD board meeting.
NSD asked about the percentage of
ethnicity and was told that it represented two students.
This happened twice until Beacon learned that data was less than 10 students is not included.
To address these findings, Beacon approved a FERPA policy and face-to-face meeting to apologize to the families.
A complete record of the apologies was presented to NSD.
The violations were corrected.
Thank you.
Good afternoon, board members.
Janelle Rooley with Young Mini and CORE.
From Beacon's perspective, this was an unfair battle from the outset.
At the time when the district issued the notice of violations, which started the process, Beacon was homeless, as you heard about, due to a dispute between the city and its landlord, which the charter school really had nothing to do with, but ultimately couldn't access its facility during that time.
We recognize that the procedures in the Ed Code and the regulations don't require the district to take extenuating circumstances into consideration.
Nevertheless, the regulations do contemplate a legitimate, good faith, back and forth, iterative process around these violations where we can refute them, we can propose a remedy or we can actually remedy.
Beacon did all of that.
To every violation there was an answer, I'm sorry, there was a refutation, a remedy, or a proposed remedy.
The district, though, applied its own judgment to whether those solutions, those answers, met its own subjective standard, and that standard was never actually communicated to the charter school.
The district never engaged in discussion with Beacon about how the time scope might have met the district's expectations.
Thank you.
Okay.
I now declare the public hearing closed.
And so we're ready for a board member discussion at this point or further questions or Bruce Holliday.
Thank you.
I am once again the liaison.
It's been my day.
So first of all, thank all of you who took the time to come here and make your testimony.
Thank you very much.
First of all, Judy Sias, am I, I am correct in assuming that they
There is a moment in time when the authorizer makes their judgment based upon the information they have.
That is the report.
That is the revocation.
And it's not that a year later or six months later things were different, right?
We need to look back at that moment in time and the process that was used.
Is that basically correct?
I can't hear you.
Sorry, you need to look to see if the district had substantial evidence at the time they conducted the hearing.
Right.
Wanted to clarify that.
And Lisa, could you come up please?
Thanks.
So in testimony we heard a number of statements made refuting or attempting to refute what the authorizer had found and what you had obviously approved by making your recommendation.
As you heard any of those statements of refutation, do you, have you changed your mind on any of those pieces of evidence?
No, I mean what was what was described by the petitioner
In essence, we went through each piece that was submitted to us and at each stage that the chartering authority went through, and we felt that they not only followed the education code in terms of when to file a notice of violation first and then inevitably a notice of revocation, we felt that they met each of those standards and also that there was substantial evidence at that time to move forward with the revocation.
Are there any other board member questions or queries?
Motion?
Well, I am sorry that the charter school went through a homeless period of time.
And obviously, that was very disruptive to their program.
However, my sense is that the authorizer not only followed the correct procedure and process and gave ample time for response and change and improvement,
I believe that they did have adequate evidence.
I do think that the CDE review was thorough and accurate and therefore I would move the CDE recommendation.
Is there a second?
Second.
All right.
Any further board discussion?
None.
All those in favor, raise your hands.
That's unanimous.
The board is adjourned.